this comprehensive course will teach you
how to turn your idea for an app into a
reality all from a business perspective
professor sluter is an experienced
teacher and he's great at explaining
things so anyone can understand
[Music]
hi in this video we're going to talk
about the business of building mobile
apps normally in this channel you think
about apps and the technical parts of
how to program them how to design them
how to troubleshoot them how to make
them work and now we're going to talk
about maybe the business side of it so
if you're kind of a business person or
you're looking into changing your role
from a programmer into a team lead or
business leader then this is going to
have some good advice for you so here's
what's ahead of us in the next few
videos in this video we're going to talk
about the motivation for building an app
because if you don't know why you're
building an app you're probably going to
fail
in soon videos we're going to talk about
effective design and making your app
work for your users so you ask your user
what they want and build exactly what
they need rather than choosing the
features that you like and are cool the
next part is about marketing we're going
to look at how you can actually turn
your app into something successful that
people want to use how do you make money
on it and whether you support a business
or you're trying to create a business we
need to ask the principals about
supporting and monetizing
also
many users just ignore their apps they
install it once and then forget about it
so what makes the difference between the
apps that are sticky and the ones that
get thrown away or ignored so there are
some pretty standard principles for how
to build an addictive app and increase
user loyalty
also what's the tools what do we do when
we come to decide on which language
which platform cross-platform
which frameworks what's going to happen
in the future how am i going to find
employees to work for and now we're
going to see all of these questions in
one of the most critical technical
decisions that you can make about
building apps is choosing the right
tools
also not just the tools for building
your app itself but the supporting
infrastructure
what's called the full stack involves
not only just the things that you see on
the screen
but the databases behind it the cloud
services the integration between
websites and mobile apps and so there's
a lot of technology that is unseen and
if you're not a technical developer this
could be a huge blind spot
and so we'll talk some advice about how
to build
for a more scalable cloud service and
now we're going to talk about speaking
of your technical people how do you
choose a development team what's the
right way to create a job requisition
what's the right way to find the right
person that would actually help you
and so we're going to give you some
advice for hiring people and choosing
the right people that will make their
career a happy place
if you are their manager and then
finally what are some emerging trends so
you don't want your app to
be expensive and
be replaced on a regular basis you want
it to be able to grow and expand and
what's coming down the road what things
are we going to do with our mobile apps
that we don't do very well right now and
so that's some of the things that are
ahead in the videos that are beyond now
first of all we're talking about the
motivations and so that's why you came
to this video
what reason do you have if you want to
make an app so some people it's about
money some people are solving problems
maybe you are just trying to make things
that people love to use or you're trying
to save the world
now you might ask
why an app then if i'm going to build an
app are there better ways to invest my
money is the app the right solution you
have to understand your problem before
you begin typing obviously
and so apps are expensive web apps might
be better
a good app for a bad business plan is
probably going to fail and so make sure
that you answer some of the fundamental
questions about why you're building an
app in the first place
of course some people are going to say
the motivation is just that i've heard
you can make a ton of money as an app
developer and an app creator well for
some people yeah it's true there's a one
percent club that seems to do very well
at that but for the rest of us
not so much maybe you have a good
motivation to say my app is going to
save the world some way i'm going to
reduce carbon emissions i'm going to
help people with anxiety i'm going to
provide services for the underserved i'm
going to promote racial harmony i'm
going to make our government work better
and so there's a ton of things that you
can provide services for that you could
put into this category of
saving the world and maybe you don't
even have to make much money at it but i
bet in the long run if you really come
up with one of these solutions that you
say you are you're on the success track
already even though money wasn't your
first motivation
however what you have to get right
is this question here
what problem are you trying to solve
and so we're going to take an entire
video in just another one or two steps
here to figure out how you can identify
what problem needs to be solved if you
don't get this one right
you haven't gotten anything right so
solving a problem
is the
fundamental problem of designing and
managing your app so in the world of
apps
there is this huge
uh ocean of apps to choose from a very
small percentage of those show up on the
top as a matter of fact
i think 60 or more are never downloaded
uh most never make any money
and so
your pro your proposition
isn't so much about how can i make money
but it's how can i solve the right
problem
clearly
there is an app for every need
but there's not a need for every app
so most apps are used once and then
uninstalled
there are a great many solutions out
there that are probably similar to the
idea that's brewing in your head right
now
and you better be darn sure that there
are customers that you can identify
that actually want to use your app and
even more
are willing to pay you money or
desperate to give you money if you've
got the right solution
so what you need to do in your
motivation stage of an app is to think
about the value
you provide
so let's think for a second about one of
the most popular apps and one of the
greatest success stories in app
development
let's talk about airbnb
if they were to state their value
proposition you might think it was this
one here
they said
airbnb allows travelers to stay in a
room that is less expensive and better
than hotel rooms
now i wrote that value proposition i'm
not the obviously the ceo of airbnb but
i'm thinking
this might be their value proposition
i'm their customer and this is what they
provide me
well i'm kind of their customer but
really their customer is not me i'm the
customer of the person renting the room
so the customer for airbnb is the person
that has the property
and so maybe a better way for their
value proposition to be stated would be
something like this i want to enable
property owners to make money
by renting space
and so you can see the formula here is
that in one sentence
they can justify the expense and the
business
model that they're trying to build
and so airbnb might be an app but really
it's an app that is a business or
business that is an app
so your value proposition this is your
homework you've got an idea right now
for an app can you state it in this term
that my value proposition for my app is
something like
x
my business x
is a service that allows y
y is my customer
that allows y to do z
in a better way
and so you have to be very specific
on each of these
what do i do
who do i do it for
and why is it better than the
competition
so
do your homework see if you can write
out a clear statement
and if you can
not only are you sure about what you're
going to be working on but your proposed
investors
and employees
and your entire organization has a clear
vision
of what you're trying to do
so your business might need an app to do
its service
but a better question to start with is
are there people who need to do why
are there people that are willing to pay
you to do it
and so this is your homework before you
even begin to write code let me give an
example so i look at my phone and i have
this app on my phone called all trails
now i hate paying for software probably
just like you
i have microsoft office only because my
employer pays for it
i try to get the free stuff whenever
possible
now all trails is an exception to that
for some reason i'm willing to pay
thirty dollars a year for this app on my
phone why is that
well it's because i am their target user
i love hiking i like backpacking and so
if you look at what they're trying to
say my proposition is
you can plan ahead with detailed maps
you can navigate on the trail so my gps
tells me exactly where i am
and so i don't get lost in the woods
which of course has happened
and so as a result they have identified
exactly who their customer is they know
who i am
and
even though it pains me i am willing to
offer them money on a yearly basis
because they do this better than anyone
else and so they found their niche they
found their persona they found their
customer and they provide me value that
i'm willing to pay for
now here's the other example so
if you are an elementary classroom
teacher or you know somebody
you could that does that you could
probably ask him do you use class dojo
in your in your room
so you're probably not an elementary
teacher just by statistically speaking
but here's what it is 95
this is a huge market penetration they
say 95 percent of schools use this app
in their classroom
so why in the world
does everybody adopt it well you can see
first of all it's free
and so that's a pretty easy proposition
and it does exactly what a teacher needs
so all of your classroom tools in one
place there's a good value proposition
so you can see they throw an example in
front of you
how many groups do you want in your
classroom
you can see that they are grouping
people
with the ease of an app
and they could probably just show this
right on the screen in front of the
classroom to say hey random groups today
click or you might say what does this
app do for communicating with my parents
you could also do things like keep track
of classroom discipline or give bonus
points to students you can modify their
behavior you can keep track of things
you can translate
in other words they have found
what a teacher needs they have either
lived in the shoes of a teacher they
were a teacher or they know teachers so
well through study that their app now
rests in 95 of all classrooms here in
the united states and so your goal then
is to have a value proposition for your
service
that fits somebody that somebody might
be plumbers
it might be accountants it might be
kayakers it might be chiropractors
bicyclists it might be hair stylist so
you don't want to say well my app is for
everybody anyone that has a car no you
want to have people that have specific
needs people that have car seats people
that have babies people that commute to
work
whatever their issue is you have an
identified solution for them and so like
class dojo or the hiker app they have
picked a segment and they know exactly
who they want to serve also here's the
question about the motivation do you
really need an app
or do you just need a better website
because here is a principle if you're
thinking about spending a whole lot of
money on an app
you can serve a great deal of your
customers through a properly designed
website so this is called mobile first
web design and you can see in the
example
that a properly formatted page is just
as easy to use on a phone as an app is
and if you do it right you can have one
server one set of code one programmer
and you don't have all the expense and
hassle of an app store
and so maybe you should think about does
my service or does my solution really
require an app or can i just make it
better with a website so fortunately
google has given us some advice on
what things people prefer
in
which format
so as you can see the top of the list
is heavy on tasks that people want to
use an app for
so games why would they care for games
well probably performance you have high
speed graphics you have better downloads
games just work better when they're an
app
how about tracking your physical
activities you probably have built-in
heart sensors gps accelerometers you can
tell how fast you're moving
uh listening to music navigation so
there are certain things up here that
are focused in on the performance or
feature of the phone so obviously
pokemon go is going to work with an app
and not a website
now if you look down at the bottom you
can see the opposite of the spectrum
so don't bother with an app if you're
trying to do one of these things so
search or browse the internet
find things to do order take out
find things to do or eat organize your
leisure or business travel read the news
so all of these are probably just as
well done or even better with a website
so just use your chrome browser that's
already built in on the phone and then
you don't have to worry about building
an app so think about some of these
issues before you go out and hire a
mobile development team and invest a lot
of money so one of the next things we
need to do is think about the categories
of apps that you might want to develop
what's the competition in these
categories and how much money can you
make a second question is
who is your app for and so knowing your
user is the second video that i
recommend that you look at next
[Music]
hi and welcome to the business of
applications we're talking about mobile
applications and the business of making
your ideas work and so here's the agenda
that we're looking through on the class
so we're in section one right now which
is motivations for building an app
so in this video we're going to talk
about the categories of apps and which
categories are profitable which ones
that you actually have a chance of in
competing and perhaps the one that
you're best suited for based on your
expertise and so let's look at the
categories out there and help you make a
decision about that great app idea
that's in your head
which category would be best for you to
compete in and so let's talk about some
of the things that we could do so first
of all fact number one
if you're trying to sell your app you
may get some money for it if you put a
price tag on it if you do we can know
this that the average price for a
premium app on the app store
is two dollars and 17 cents now that
sounds pretty good if you made a million
apps
but if you're in the majority of people
you're probably far below this because
when you think of what an app is
most people expect it to be absolutely
free and so the best way to make money
is not actually to charge money for the
app itself
but to get it in other ways and so you
could probably think about getting
in-app purchases or trying to sell
advertising which apps do the best by
the way so if you're trying to put a
price tag on your app you should
probably think of who is willing to pay
for it notice at the top we've got
technology and finance yeah both of
those are kind of rich people things
or they're actually pretty useful things
that uh solve annoying problems look at
the very bottom though if you're like me
you probably think games are cool
they're kind of neat to build
and they're also some of the things that
people don't want to pay for so you're
going to have to come up with other ways
if you're going to make money for your
app than just charging for it now here's
a principle that would make sense if you
want to actually compare you with the
average so really there is no such thing
as an average when it comes to our apps
so think of the big monstrous companies
do you really think you're going to make
something like amazon or you're going to
make the next mcdonald's app probably
not so if you're comparing apps think of
how a realtor would come up with a price
for a house you don't just take the
average price for the city you take a
look at your house and you compare the
same number of bedrooms bathrooms same
square feet location's pretty close and
then you have a better idea of what your
app can do so instead of looking at
these top lists of the
averages or the top 100 in the internet
look at people that are doing something
that is like what you're doing and so
another way to do this is to try to
compare on scale so if you know that
clash of clans makes over 2 million
dollars a day in purchases
don't just think that your app can
somehow make 2 million either so what
you need to do is maybe divide so how
many customers does the app serve and
how much do they make in a day and you
can come up with something that is a
little bit closer to what you can expect
a better way to compare yourself with
other people in the app store is to use
the median instead of an average and so
you know in a median you just take the
middle score of a value so if there are
some really high end people which there
are
that way the median isn't so much
affected so take a look at premium apps
here so i just stole this right out of
the google app play store and to see
what they're advertising so what people
are willing to pay for in an app can
tell you something about maybe the app
that you're thinking about building
and so it looks to me like we have no
games here we've got some tools
uh the star walk i think that's a cool
one where you can actually
use your phone to track where things are
in the sky
and so sometimes premium apps are there
because people are willing to pay for a
service without having to look at
advertising so a good piece of advice
for coming up with the amount of money
that you're going to make is actually
not to think about the money at all it's
to think about who your customer is and
how you can satisfy them so if you can
scratch an itch you can meet their need
you can solve a problem they're going to
eventually pay you whether you charge
them at the beginning or along the way
and so your priority should be to think
of how to make a great app that they
love to use let's take a look at the
first category that you'd come across
in most app stores i think most people
would think of social media is probably
the most common app that they've got on
their phone and so it's a crowded field
all of these things that you're looking
at here are probably one or two or many
of them
on your phone right now
they're huge though so think of how big
the apps are
and how far away you are of actually
competing against them so if you're
thinking about building the next
facebook you could probably do that in a
semester so one of the courses that we
teach uh
uses a social network and you build
connections and you have a database and
you can add comments and send messages
to your friends and so technically we
got the solution put together in one
semester but realistically the app is
still worthless because
nobody's on the app the the real value
of a social media app is
how many users do you have
and so maybe a good strategy for you to
compete in this category is to think
about
augmenting or adding on to something
rather than competing against it so
unless you've got the next tick tock
you're probably not going to bump
somebody off these are tough categories
to compete in but here's an example of
something that you might think of if you
were in social media so here's a tool
it augments what facebook does or maybe
you could come up with some kind of a
twitter
actual add-on or something so think of
the ways that you can make an existing
app a little bit better
now a great category for a beginner
especially somebody that would be in one
of my classes where you're learning how
to program is to build a game
so games are really a good place for you
to start if you're just trying to
experiment with the app store and build
apps and try to get some customers
not because you're going to make a lot
of money but because
games are a nice way to build an app
that you can understand and what you can
do
instead of make money with your app is
maybe just as good as you can add it to
your portfolio what do you mean by that
a portfolio is a collection of projects
that you can show potential employers
and you bring it to your interview you
put it on your linkedin and you say
listen i built this app
and it's kind of like angry birds
and it's got a bunch of graphics i used
framework for building cross-platform
apps i have a database i'm using a rest
service i learned react and so if you've
got all those keywords in there and you
have this working game it's a really
good project and i recommend that you do
that if you're trying to get a job
and maybe have someone hire you to be an
employee for a company that builds apps
and so you might end up working for
pizza hut and ordering a pizza app
instead of creating your own business
but it's a pretty good job if you're
going to be an app developer so i've got
another video that compares the the
prices and the salaries and the
expectations about a web developer
versus an app developer and it's worth
checking out while looking at the chart
here you can see that these are some of
the most downloaded and they're also
some of the most profitable apps that
are in the market
so social media and gaming probably
dominate what we mostly think about
about our phone purpose and what we do
with it and so we're always on one of
those two now look at this category this
graph here
is amazing um you can see that the value
of daily revenue
by category is like really skewed toward
the games area
and so twenty two thousand dollars a day
is the average app revenue in the
category then we split up the game
category again and we can see that
strategy games
are the most profitable
and so you might think oh great i'm
gonna make a strategy game and get rich
remember what i said about the uh the
balance between an average and the
median
well this is where this math comes into
play so the top
game in the category
back in 2016 was clash of clans and over
2 million dollars a day in revenue
well then if you look at the 50th
percentile which is pretty good
you might squeeze out 150 a day well you
could almost make a living on that maybe
if you were just
had no expenses and then if you look
below you have the 20th percentile in
other words the games that are probably
the ones that you and i are going to
publish they average
zero dollars and so they might not even
get downloaded
another category that would be useful
for you to experiment with if you're
trying to get into the app market is
this lifestyle category now for the life
of me when i look at the apps that are
in the lifestyle category i don't really
see the theme what is lifestyle mean
anyway i mean there's realtor apps
and there's tinder and pinterest and
it seems to me like
baby monitors and e-harmony don't have a
lot
as far as the commonality of how the app
works and so
whatever whatever this category means it
it's it's something that affects your
life so fitness apps is something i can
understand
what does
a fitness app gain that's pretty good
you can see
that this graph here shows the top 200
fitness apps on their daily revenue
whoever the first guy is he's making 45
000
a day you could make a living at that
one and the average is 1500 so once
again let's take a look at the
the median score rather than the
averages so the 50th percentile once
again
zero
so expect that if you're
if you don't have a billion dollar
company backing you up you're probably
going to have
that zero number so when you look at
averages you should probably just ignore
them because they are not going to tell
you anything about
you and your experience at all take a
look here this is probably strava so
this would be a typical winning home run
app everyone seems to like this one so
you can track yourself you can analyze
your workouts and share with friends and
make connections so a great tool and it
seems to be clicking with everybody that
is into exercise and so that would be
one of the better lifestyle apps that i
can think of so the key of a lifestyle
app is to find something that people do
and make it so that it works really well
for meeting their needs
another category that is really useful
and this one actually where you can sell
things is the utility category so what's
a utility well the utility is something
that enhances the operating system
or does some kind of a task for you so
for instance this one here is going to
figure out
where your empty spaces are and make
your uh make your phone work better so a
utility could be any of these on these
this category list here so you can see
that things such as adding fonts for
some reason chrome is considered a
category of a utility
i would think of you know things that
make your phone work better things that
encrypt your data
things that
make your spam calls go away those are
good utilities and so anything that
would enhance your operating system
would fit in the utility category
a close relative of that is the
productivity category and so people are
usually willing to pay for productivity
if they're going to have something
useful
so these are some of the most commonly
used things some of the services that
people would use on a regular basis so
dropbox cloud storage note taking
microsoft office
any kind of tool that is going to make
your job
work better
and so productivity apps are something
that you can
probably come up with as well do you
have a problem do you have something
that you're trying to work on you have a
note-taking app do you have some kind of
a score card do you
work with pictures what what what does
your utility need to do
and if you can find a winning solution
you can see that sometimes we can
actually charge people now utility apps
is probably the one place where you
don't want to put ads
ads are annoying of course even people
that play games don't even like the ads
even though they get spammed with them
all the time but especially don't put it
in a utility
app your utility is supposed to save you
time not annoy you and so try to come up
with a way that you can give them the
free version and then go to the freemium
model so that way they like their
experience
a category called shopping of course is
going to be dominated by the big people
such as amazon and walmart but you don't
have to once again compete directly
against them i mean you're not going to
come up with carfax that's like just not
going to happen right but what you can
do is think about that strategy of
augment rather than compete
because people are going to be using
their phones to make purchases
so if all you need to do is make
recommendations for purchases and then
send them to somewhere to buy such as if
you're
working with an affiliate program on a
store
then really you have taken a cut you've
taken the slice and you can make a
living if you have enough people looking
at your ad and making a decision so some
kind of a price comparison now news and
information another category that has a
lot of variety in it so if you look here
you can see that some of these are
actual
people that make news such as the wall
street journal or the washington post
once again
good luck in trying to compete against
an established newspaper what can you do
well take a look at police scanner for
example
what they're doing is they're taking
existing data and they're packaging it
in a way that the user can see it
other things such as your news
aggregators so if you could come up with
an app that is able to predict what the
user is interested in you look at their
habits and see what stories they read
you can give them more stories that
would be similar
and you can probably make their news
reading experience better and so you
don't have to be a reporter you don't
have to own the newspaper you just have
to be able to organize the data and
deliver to the user
now here's a good category if you've got
a specialty
of what you know and you want to share
it
go with education so education could be
anything like
language learning or math those seem to
be the two that are like the leading
categories
uh coursera is something that obviously
you're not going to compete with if
you've ever looked at coursera it's like
universities across the world publish
entire courses and coursera is just
publishing those in a nice format but if
you have some special content
you might be able to sell it so for
instance let's say you're an expert
guitar player you could offer guitar
lessons with your app
or if you're going to help people learn
reading or maybe english is a second
language or if they just need to learn
how to do a hobby do they need to learn
how to ride their bike play ping pong
they need to learn how to fix their car
they need to fix an air conditioner i
mean education is really what we hit the
internet for
and if you've got an app that can make
it work
then you've got yourself a market
so here's a page that i thought was very
handy for figuring out what kind of
categories you want to compete in so
this is kickstarter and i'm looking at
the page called apps that were recently
funded
and so these are idea pages where you
can think about what people are building
now that really are not big yet
and so there's room for uh competition
obviously if these people are successful
so you notice the first one that's on
here it's called fluent forever it's a
learning education app
look at here the next one called seed
time the fastest way to plan your garden
kind of a utility
free photo prints that one looks like
more of a business than it is an app
you can see that we got scripture
listening uh we got
learning to code so two educational apps
here so i would i would go through this
and just get ideas from
who else is out there that is at pretty
young stage in their in their life of
their company
and you might find some ideas that can
help you
trigger what might work for you so
here's a list of the top uh educational
category apps right now and you can see
that we've got a few things that are
doing math and language it seems that's
a pretty popular one
so let's sum up here what we're trying
to learn so perhaps the best lesson is
if you're trying to pick a category for
building an app and choosing the idea
that works for you
then go for this first principle
pick something you know a lot about
because if you're trying to solve
somebody else's problem
that might work but it's going to take
some very
careful research and interviews and
you're probably going to have to walk in
the other person's shoes for a while but
if you've already got an idea you've
already got a problem you already got a
field that you're good at
then you know a lot of the things that
you need to do principle number two make
sure that instead of focusing on which
app is going to earn the most money
think of it maybe as
which app can i build that will make
people super happy
with my product i'm going to make
something that people love to use and
then you can figure out the money later
and so that's maybe the best principle
for which order you think in
and part number three
if you have a
mega category such as social media and
you know you're never going to replace
amazon or facebook then what can you do
what you can do is create an app that
can make the experience slightly better
for the user and so those principles
here are going to help you in which
category you want to choose to build
your app one of the jobs that you have
to do if your app's going to be
successful is identify a problem that
people have and so check out this video
that helps you do that the second thing
is you need to be able to identify the
user that you're trying to serve with
precision you know exactly who's going
to use your ad so check one of these two
videos out for the next step in learning
the business of apps
[Music]
hey welcome back to the business of
applications in this course we're
studying some of the motives and some of
the design that you would do if you are
building an application so we're in the
first part of the course still we're
talking about the motivations for an app
but as you can see there are other
course items that are coming so stick
around
and if you want to see them all make
sure that you subscribe my name is shad
slooter and i teach application
development at grand canyon university
so let's get into this subject today so
we are trying to find a problem to solve
that's pretty much fundamental when it
comes to designing an application you
have to ask yourself what's the motives
why are you doing it and in this video
we're going to talk about some
strategies that you can do to discover
problems that people have and how you
can solve them here's the principle of
what we're trying to present here in
just one sentence that an idea that does
not fulfill a need
is really not a business opportunity so
you've got a great app but nobody cares
you might as well not even build it so
here is a analogy that has been used in
many different situations like this when
you talk about coming up with a need for
an app
so
are you selling candy
are you selling vitamins
or are you selling painkillers so let's
talk about what that means because we're
obviously not selling any of these but
we're using them as an analogy
so kevin fong gets credit for
this uh analogy here so he's
an entrepreneur from silicon valley and
uh this is his quote so he says we
divide business plans into three
categories candy vitamins and
painkillers
so he dismisses candy as just junk it's
things that we just discard without much
thought
we look at vitamins we know that they're
good for us but don't really use them on
a regular basis
and he says we really
like painkillers now when he says we
he's talking about the venture funding
people these are the angel investors
these are the people you need to talk to
to get money to make your business work
and if he says we really like
painkillers he says you must have a
problem
identified
and
people are willing to pay you for it
then he says
we especially like
addictive painkillers
and so painkillers are the products that
you can't live without
so let's look at each of these
categories individually so a a piece of
candy is something that is perhaps what
you would call a game app something
that's cool it's fun
it could be a fad and disappears quickly
and so that's the danger of of of a fun
app so i know it's fun i'm wasting my
time but i like it so have you ever
played trivia crack
yeah i played it too
it came and went like within months
maybe you're not the right age group to
remember it but it was certainly a piece
of candy it was fun they probably made a
lot of money but it didn't stick around
how about this one though clash of cl
clans uh that certainly is candy it's
kind of eye candy it's fun to play with
just recently i checked the stats on it
and they made 20 million dollars last
month in revenue so
even though candy can be a fad if you
sell really good candy you're going to
sell a lot of it
here's the idea of vitamins though
if you look at a feature or an app and
you say this about it you say that's a
really cool idea
i could probably use it i mean you can
justify it and say it is nice and all
but
you might forget about it you say it's
good
and then it doesn't stick around so for
instance
i have the amazon
echo um alexa in our house
they bought it for my birthday and it's
fun to play with right so i can say
alexa play some music and then off in
the distance musical station based on
your listening history
[Music]
alexa stop
[Music]
just a minute i'll be right back
[Music]
okay so i consider alexa to be fun
uh but you know if you took her away
from me i could probably still do life
just fine so she's convenient to yell at
to argue at and to have you tell some
jokes but really she's in my case she's
a vitamin she's nice to have now the
painkillers though are a different
situation so
when you say this when you say
something's wrong
i need this now
here's my credit card and by the way
what did it cost that means that you've
got a product that suits a need so well
that you're going to be
you're going to be covered with
customers people are going to come to
you asking
when they can sign up and so sales are
really easy and it's probably an
addictive app because if people really
want to pay you that much they're going
to so i looked at my computer and i
thought what are the apps that i
must use i can't live without and pretty
much anything that is made by google
seems to fit this category so
for instance could you live without a
good search engine can you find your way
around without maps can you find stores
can you locate things can you send and
receive email without thinking about
gmail
really those three are pretty successful
now microsoft has office which has
pretty much become the default standard
for any kind of the utilities that i
work with
i know there's free alternatives but
office seems to just come back all the
time for instance right now you're
looking at a powerpoint presentation
i've certainly tried to get rid of
powerpoint but i keep coming back to it
so the idea is that you want to have a
solution that is
addictive and people cannot live without
so that's really what a painkiller so
here's a nice quote that says once we
come to depend on a tool
nothing else will do and so you've come
up with a good painkiller solution for
your app if you can build this app
you're going to be rich you're going to
have many many users
but you can see that sometimes apps fit
into
multiple categories so let's talk about
facebook
is facebook to you a
piece of candy
is it a vitamin kind of nice to have
or is it a painkiller
so look at the first guy obviously on
the top row
he's bored
and to him facebook is as good as
playing
a video game so he might just pass the
time
and then the second one is perhaps this
mother here who is
probably more dependent on facebook
she's talking to her friends she's
scheduling meetings she's finding out
what's going on
but look at the grandma down in the
bottom
she is isolated she's far away
she lives alone to her having facebook
or zoom or any kind of social media to
her is a painkiller it is something
that she must have
and so i i certainly uh visiting friends
that are like this have discovered their
dependence on it uh you know they ask me
for technical help to say i gotta have
my i gotta have my app
this is the only way i stay in touch
with my friends
and so
facebook would like to be the pain
killer for us all uh for me it kind of
fits somewhere in the
uh nice to have category i honestly
don't check it very often so a single
product can be different things to
different people and so don't just judge
your product based on one person's
opinion
so here is another way to find out if
you're solving the problem think about
higher needs rather than the immediate
need of your program what does that mean
so for instance
our higher needs are things like
we have a desire for fulfillment
or you might say we have a desire for
belonging that's certainly a higher need
and these are strong needs need for
recognition i mean look i'm checking how
many people are subscribed to my channel
what in the world is the need here so
youtube is solving a need for me that i
hate to admit but i'm getting
recognition through this tool how about
security security financial security
security in your relationships security
of your home physical security the
security of your job future and so
sometimes products can help us with
needs that are just as basic as food and
water
now here's a way to find out really what
people's motives are this is a
technique
that was used in the toyota motor
company and probably still today it's
called the five wise and the idea is
that you ask a bunch of whys to find out
really what's at the bottom of
somebody's request
and so it requires literal digging and
digging into their mind and into their
psyche
so you define the issue by asking the
question why
five times you say why is this happening
and they give you an answer and then you
say why is that and then you ask then
again why is that and then finally when
you get to the maybe about the fourth or
fifth level there's really no specific
number but somewhere down there you're
going to find
that there is a stronger reason than the
one that was first given to you so in
the case of toyota they ask questions
like why did the production line stop
and then the quest the answer is well we
ran out of parts and then they asked
well why did we run out of parts well
the the manager refused to order uh
extra supplies and he said why is that
well he was trying to do lean
manufacturing and he didn't want to
spend the money
on excess inventory well why is that
well our stock price is getting hit
because we have not used their money
efficiently and so you can see that
there's reasons behind why the
production line may have stopped and so
then they can address those bigger
reasons if they can identify the whys
behind it now when we talk about a
product we do the same thing
so we would come up with different
solutions depending on how the user
responds so let's say we want to build
an application that produces recipes now
what kind of recipes do we want we want
ethnic recipes do we want home cooked do
we want quick do we want diet so all of
those questions are going to be asked
at the uh at the panel you might have of
users and your interviews and so let's
ask this so
somebody does respond to you in a
request for your
information to say hey i'm building an
app that's going to do recipes and you
say you need to make them or you need to
use them so why is that
and so the person says
well i'd like to eat healthier well
don't just stop there you say
why do you want to eat healthier well i
want to live longer
okay so why do you want to live longer
well that's pretty obvious
i want to see my grandchildren
okay
so why is that important to you why do
you want to see your grandchildren are
they not annoying enough already when
they're visiting you
and she says family is important to me
so
there is a value at the bottom of this
thing about
i want recipes
and really
what this person says
is i want food to bring my family
together so that's a pretty powerful
need isn't it and so if we're building
an app to serve this person
we would have maybe a slogan right this
on the left side it says the right food
brings family together now that sells to
this person in particular
but we might ask the same question and
get different results so we might have
to slant our advertising or the design
of our app to this the right food can
make you pretty so listen to this
question so
this person says i want new recipes
okay why is that
well i want to lose weight
okay
why do you want to lose weight
i'm 30 pounds overweight
okay why are you overweight
i eat when i feel bad
i think i do anyway
and then why is that
because people laugh at me often
so these are obviously getting into some
sensitive areas too
and so if we can provide something to
help an uh a person overcome their deep
emotional problems then we've got a
painkiller app
so the right food
can make you pretty i don't know maybe
that's a lame way to advertise it but if
we can make a product that will help
people lose weight not just to get thin
but to be liked
then you've got yourself a painkiller
app how about this one the right food
can help you get ahead so same recipe
app but we've got a different motive
going on now so this next interview the
person says to us
i want new recipes
and so we ask
why
then they say
i only have 30 minutes to cook
okay
why are you in such a hurry
i work full time
okay don't stop there ask again
why do you work full time
well i want more money
okay obviously what you have isn't
enough so why do you need more
because wealth is a status to me
and so the conclusion is
time is money right so i want more time
i want my food preparation to take
little time i've got bigger things to do
i've got bigger fish to fry
and so we could advertise the
convenience of these recipes as well
so now we've got ourselves we've got
these different
types of opinions and remember the goal
here the video is to teach you how to
identify the problem you're trying to
solve so if your solution is build an
app for recipes
and you talk to a variety of people
you might find that your initial reason
or what you thought was the reason for
the app is not actually the reason of
what your users say
so i love my family i feel ugly i'm very
busy these are all reasons that are
being input into your why you want to
make your recipe app
so if you do some research and you talk
to a bunch of people and you start to
hear the same things over and over then
you start to make conclusions about who
we're going to serve who's the first
person on our list of of things that we
want
so most of the people that we let's say
we talk to
are saying i want to find healthy food
and so comfort and quick and easy were
not the highest priorities so the next
steps for us would be to build an app or
at least to design the features about
identifying the nutrition
about maybe the
the benefits for the food that you're
eating and how it can affect your health
so in this scenario that i just set out
to you you would obviously then
fixate on healthy food and why that
works so if you'd like some more
information about how to discover that
niche where your app can suit a need
that no one else is meeting take a look
at the next video about finding a niche
if you'd like to take a look at all of
the videos in this course about building
apps in the business of apps then take a
look at this playlist here and make sure
you subscribe and join me for class next
time thank you
[Music]
hey welcome back to the business of
applications this is a series of videos
that i'm working with my class on how to
make your business thrive using
applications and so this is a seven part
series and we're in part one right now
which is about the motivations of
building an app but you can see that
there are other chapters that we're
going to cover here so if you like what
you're seeing here make sure you
subscribe my name is chad slooter and
i'm a professor of computer science and
software development at grand canyon
university so please join my class here
as we learn the business of apps so in
this video we're talking about the idea
of finding a niche in the market and so
since it's probably pretty hard to
compete against the really big mega apps
we need to find something that makes
sense for you
and so there's some strategies in this
video for making your product work
so let's talk about a product niche
what's inside of it well when you think
of a niche in nature you think of
something where there is little
competition and so that's what we're
trying to find here in your market is to
see where there is unmet needs also make
sure that there is a market so you might
have a great idea because nobody else is
doing it but there's a good reason is
because nobody wants it and so you have
to find a overlap here between what
people want what's not being met and
then also it would be nice to make some
money to be able to pay for your app and
so with these three intersect we would
find a niche now these are obviously
hidden because if
that was a problem that everyone knew
about then there would be an app in that
niche already and so what we're trying
to do is figure out where you can find
your niche now the word niche usually
comes from biology so when you think of
a place where an animal lives where
there are few competitors and that is
able to thrive and so that is the idea
of finding somewhere where no one will
bother you and so if you think of the
dung beetle this is a great example of a
niche where nobody seems to want all the
dung that's rolling around on the
savannah in africa except for these
beetles and they've got it all to
themselves so if your business is
collecting dung then there aren't a lot
of competition for you
so here's what it looks like in the
market so if you hear somebody say we
are the uber of
or we are the amazon of you've got this
mega leader in the category and you are
trying to do similar things but in a
smaller category so here's an example so
this was what something i found on
reddit in the app ideas
thread so taskrabbit is one of those
service apps where you can find somebody
that's willing to work on something that
you're willing to pay for and then
taskrabbit takes a cut and so they said
hey there's a unmet need here personal
beauty care and so perhaps this is an
idea
wow that's an idea so maybe you could
develop it it would take an entire
business of course but get started so
one way that you can find a niche is to
see if there are new areas opening up
that weren't there before and so that's
called following the trends so if you
were to just do google trends you can
find what's going on
month by month day by day or maybe over
a longer period of time such as what
people are searching for
in the year
so for instance 2020 it was a year where
these were the items that were trending
they didn't appear before and then they
showed up so
maybe you could come up with an idea
that way more than likely most of these
are just ideas that are
in the media so what's a better way for
finding a trending use pattern for
mobile apps so i did some google
searching to find out what trends are
happening in mobile applications in
general so look at here here's a four
trends that are shaping 2020 so this
deals with technology so the first trend
is they see that pcs are still in place
and what's the next one here number two
wearable ownership is growing okay so
there's an opportunity do you want to
make something with a watch or glasses
so it looks like that's on the trend
upward how about this one the smart home
market is growing so connecting your
devices that's kind of an iot thing so
is there an app opportunity there so i
know for sure that in the canyon
ventures a section of the university
where i teach there are companies that
are in this market what did you say
canyon ventures was it's the
entrepreneur startup section where
businesses come and recruit students to
work for them so these are new companies
and they're growing so
smart home market is one thing that i've
noticed that was over there let's see
what else is here gaming gear is busy
well 2020 was the year of the pandemic
and so gaming was a major major growth
area so maybe those are some things that
you could find as trends so google
places like this to see if you can learn
something about what's coming so here's
another site that i found that had
something about trends and mobile
development so here we got 15 of them
let's see if there's anything that we
could follow as a trend here's the trend
that says iot is growing so application
integration looks like the trend is
going to continue off into the future uh
apps for foldable devices oh i don't
have a foldable device but maybe that's
on the future
5g can you take an app and
take advantage of faster internet
connectivity how about number four uh
wearable devices that sounds like a
previous blog item that we saw before
beacon technology so beacon technology
what in the world is that it looks like
we can have down here a description that
says
clients install this app and when they
go near another place where there's a
beacon they get a notification
i'm kind of skeptical that that will
actually be a trend i really don't want
people annoying me any more than they
are but hey they say it is uh mobile
commerce
well that's kind of like a given
artificial intelligence okay so that's
pretty much a good trend
mobile wallets uh augmented reality i
would bet on this one as a trend
and let's see chatbots uh superior app
security i'll vote for that one
predictive analysis so that way we can
have more ai
and then on-demand mobile apps i kind of
like that so the idea is do some
research figure out what the trends are
and then see if you can come up with
something that is going to fill a niche
before everyone else jumps in on it
here's another idea
if you can find an app or a process or a
game or something that exists and add a
feature to it add a twist and make it
yours so here's an example
words with friends it's really just
scrabble but then it's added the
multi-player dimension to it some social
media and you've got yourself an app
that is still very strong and popular
then you could also say well
maybe words with friends just took a
regular board game but you could also go
look around at apps that you know exist
so you look at one app and you look at
another app and you think there's some
overlap between those what are the
features that i could do so if i could
combine app a and b then i get what's
called the twist
and so you can invent a new app
based on what you've already seen others
do so really that's what a lot of
inventions are it's just combining two
other people's ideas into your own so
there's hardly anything that's actually
original here's an example of combining
two apps so waze you haven't used waze
it's basically a map like google maps
and it allows you to talk to other
drivers so you can plant a little pin on
the map that says hey there's a police
waiting here to give you a ticket and so
essentially what they've done is take
google maps and they've added some
social media and enhancement to it and
kind of made it a gamification so you
can
win points by taking trips
whoever thought that driving would be
that much fun but anyway waze was
purchased by google for probably
billions of dollars and so it was a
successful spin-off of just the standard
driving app
now if you're trying to find a niche
then maybe the most obvious advice of
all is
do your own thing what that means is do
you have a specialty a need that you
have to fill yourself there's not an app
that exists for to do what you want to
do for example here's an a fill your own
need item
just a quick glance at this shows me
somebody
came up with a brilliant idea to fix an
annoying problem so this is a magnetic
wrist
and so it's just a velcro strap that
goes around your wrist and with magnetic
plates in it and you can glue all your
nuts and bolts and screws and
drill heads and even the pencil
so you've got yourself something like a
pocket
but very much accessible or one-handed
used pocket
and so what a great idea this person
came up with a simple solution to a
problem that annoys almost all of us
so i can see this as an invention for
someone on their own needs but then
quickly spreads to everybody else so
what app would you build to fix a
problem that you have and then only
worry about finding customers later
because if you like it more than likely
somebody else will
so if you're trying to find a niche then
think about improving what's already out
there so take a look at the landscape
and see if you can fix it
so when you compare competitors you're
going to find features that are similar
to apps that you would like to build
but is there somebody that has an app
that is missing a feature or you see it
in the user comments
for instance and the reviews in the app
store if only this app would
that is like free market research for
you if you'll read through those
comments and see what people would like
the app to do that it doesn't and so you
find a gap there it's called a niche
also you would find if people are being
annoyed so if advertising is becoming
the best way for a certain app to make
money you can guarantee the users are
going to be annoyed maybe you could come
up with a replacement for it you can
sneak in on market share and then you
can figure out later how you can be the
annoying advertiser how about this if
you're looking for competitors are you
competing against microsoft or google or
are you competing against a single
programmer or a small team
so that'll tell you a lot about what
your competition is up to so
there's only infinite resources at
google and microsoft so don't even
bother if you're trying to reinvent
google maps now also think about updates
if you look in the app store you're
going to see that some people build
their app and then forget about it so
has it been five years since they've
updated it there is a niche you could
probably just walk right in do an update
to the current ad and you can start
picking off users how about poor ratings
that's a pretty obvious sign that
there's opportunities here people have a
need that is not being met and there's
your competition red flag to say i'm
going to step in here and fix a problem
that people feel but what happens if you
look at your competition and they have
good ratings well that just tells you
that it's free market research as well
that tells you what people like and if
you build a similar app you better make
sure that some of those features are for
you
so back to words with friends so if this
is one of the most popular games in the
world then tell me this when i look at
the reviews why in the world are all the
reviews currently showing up as one star
and you look at it it's all about the
ads and about how annoying the program
is to work with and so
people want to play this game
but they really don't like to play
this version of the game there's a niche
they're opening the door for competition
uh here's another one i've actually paid
for this app many years ago because i
wanted to have a good
place to show podcasts
and so i probably wouldn't buy the app
today because if you look here you can
see that most of the users are annoyed
with it every time they do an update
something breaks and so i don't know if
a podcast manager is really a good app
anymore because
apple and google have pretty much taken
care of that need right in their
operating system but if you wanted to
build one
this one here would certainly be a good
competitor to try to beat so do your
research come up with a chart
and go through um
a bunch of competitors that you find
that are similar to the app that you
have in mind
and so you just put down a chart to
compare what's their popularity what's
their notable features how do they
monetize themselves what's their company
size when did they last do their update
and what kind of reviews are they
getting and so when you have a
comparison chart here you're going to
see perhaps opportunities arise so this
might become a large spreadsheet as you
mine the data to find what you want so
make sure that when you're doing your
comparisons that you're not trying to
compete against the monster companies do
similar apps that are about the same
size and complexity as what you're doing
learn from what they do well and then
see if there are some opportunities
where they leave the door open so that's
your ideal so where are you going to
find this information so uh for beyond
pod i
did a search there at sensor tower
and for this app you can see that it's
kind of an
c minus grade
so what's the competition for what
you're trying to build go look at their
ratings go look in their app store and
then check them out here on sensor tower
to see if there are opportunities for
you to take advantage of so that's some
advice for how to do a niche now the
next stage is to get some users together
or potential users and ask them a lot of
questions it's called listening to the
user and so check this video out to see
some advice and how you can do that well
if you'd like to see the entire playlist
for all the lessons on the business of
apps then i'll put it here as a playlist
[Music]
hi and welcome back to the business of
applications this is a course where we
talk about the business of planning
designing marketing your application so
we're in the middle of a class that has
several sections we're in part one right
now which is on the motivations for
building an app so we're identifying the
problem and our users and trying to come
up with what fits in the market you can
see that there are other topics that are
coming up so make sure that you
subscribe if this kind of thing is
interesting to you my name is shad
slooter and i teach software development
at grand canyon university so please
join us for class and tell us what
you're doing now what we're going to do
in this video here is talk about the
elevator pitch or you might call it
listening to your users so you're trying
to talk to real people about an idea you
have to see if it actually is grounded
in reality so here is what a lot of
people would do in their elevator pitch
so when you're an elevator pitch is
usually about getting a job or trying to
sell your business and you've got about
30 seconds and so here's your goal state
what the problem is
tease with a solution and then tell them
how you can add value so here's an
example of an elevator pitch so you
might say the problem is we have a
process that currently takes our
employees about 30 minutes to accomplish
and we can make that better if we put
some software in place as a matter of
fact my value proposition is that you
can reduce this task to just four
minutes are you interested
and of course 30 minutes to four minutes
sounds like a great value proposition so
that's kind of the idea that you want to
do when you're selling your app in one
sentence you can describe what your app
does and why people should pay you for
it so what you should do then is you
should probably have some kind of a
prototype or at least drawings or
something that you can show users give
them the 30 second pitch about what it
does have them look at it
and then honestly watch them
don't try to argue with them just see
what they say you've got yourself a
maybe a one-minute time frame window to
get their first initial reactions which
are probably accurate and then take the
lessons with
humility
and either throw away your idea or
modify it or run with it if people seem
to like it
so don't worry about your idea being
stolen
ideas are cheap everyone has a great
idea but it takes a lot of work to make
an app and so if you have an idea
without any execution
you've got nothing
and so the app store has a a lot of
people that put work into it they don't
have ideas in the app store so like i
mentioned be humble and be open so
feedback is going to come in various
ways if you show your prototype or your
idea to somebody and they just are kind
of confused
means you're probably lacking clarity or
if they say that's the stupidest thing
i've ever seen
don't argue with them just see if more
people tell you that it's really that
dumb however if you get a few good
reactions like this one
keep moving because of course your mom
is going to think it's great
your friends might be a little bit
critical for you but strangers see if
you can get some people to evaluate it
objectively and if you can get some
positive ideas then maybe you're on to
something so speaking of ideas go to
reddit there's a whole reddit subreddit
on
app ideas and here is where you can read
about other people's ideas and post your
own to see if there's some feedback so
you can go ahead and steal right here
because as i said ideas are cheap
execution is everything so post your
ideas or go look for ideas so make sure
that you get the process in order so
this here is what some people would plan
for their order of operations
they would say i'm going to create this
great app and i'm sure there are
customers out there which will then lead
me to make some money so unfortunately
this is probably a failure
you got to find this in a different
order so start it this way find the
customers give them an idea of what
you're going to build so build something
very simple or at least draw some
pictures that don't take a lot of time
investment
once you have the users that are going
to tell you yeah i think this is going
to work
then you can go ahead and work on
building something great and then
following that you'll have the money so
the next critical step in building your
application is to make a user profile
how to find the ideal person you have to
be very specific so check out the video
here on targeting the ideal user and if
you want to see the entire playlist i'll
post this here as the link as well so
keep watching with me and subscribe and
thank you
[Music]
hi welcome to the business of
applications in this series of videos
we're talking about how you can take a
product and turn it into an app
so the business part here is got several
topics and we're in part one right now
which is about the motivations for your
app and so we're going to get to the
others
but so if you're interested in building
a application and knowing how the
strategies work we're looking at best
practices for all of these topics so
make sure you subscribe so my name is
shad sluter and i teach software
development at grand canyon university
and so i'm inviting you to come to class
and get an a plus education so in this
video we are talking about a task called
know your primary user and so knowing
your users is one of the most important
things that you can do early on in the
development of a product or service so
having a very targeted user is going to
make you an effective person for how you
design your product and how you interact
with your people a piece of advice is
make sure that you have a narrow enough
focus about who your customer is so that
you can say
i have at least 100 true fans instead of
a lot of publicity from people who
really don't even care
so the goal of this video here would be
for you to have
identified
who the person is that is most likely
going to buy your app or use your
service and so you can literally come up
with a profile of the age
the type of work they do how much money
they have
what kind of hobbies they would do
what bothers them
and so
if you have all these relevant things
targeted
then your job of finding out what your
product is supposed to do will become
easier
so one of the questions might be can you
just invent this profile
or should you check to see if they exist
in the real world and so trying to find
out if these customers exist in the wild
is part of the strategy here
so one way that you can actually do some
experiments to find this out and verify
your assumptions is to create what i
would call a coming soon page so here's
an example so let's say you have a
great business idea we're going to call
it tech
and the idea is that we are serving
freelance
businesses so single employees that are
trying to make a living
and so
this doesn't exist it's just a vaporware
you might call it but we would advertise
with a website like this to describe
what our features are
and we would uh post
google ads to see if we can get people
that are searching for our type of
service and if they click it they would
be brought here
and if they are willing to enter their
email
and ask to be put on a waiting list for
when your service launches
then you've got some data that you can
compare with how many people click the
ad how many people see your product and
actually sign up or how many people just
bail
and go away so these are great ways to
do experiments with limited amounts of
money no software development and you
can find out if your ideas are actually
going to work in the real world here's
another one go blog so
go blog is in the works it says
we're going to have a blogging community
for people who are passionate about
everything
so
this obviously exists already but we're
going to see if people are willing to
sign up for our service and so you have
a landing page like this here's another
one so uh here is a more of a
long-term one so i have somebody that is
trying to
get paid it says get jobs get them done
get paid with work week
and do you have a small service work
week is all about getting your paperwork
out of the way does this sound
interesting would you pay for this
service if so
go ahead and
sign up
so
you can find out if people are
interested
now also this is a nice mailing list
because if you actually do launch your
product maybe a year from now you're
going to have a whole bunch of people
that are actually willing to download
your app on the very first day which
helps a lot
with the google services
here's another one here so a design and
prototyping tool so we can take a look
at uh tools to build apps so you might
be the target audience on this one so we
can build prototypes without coding
here's the list of features looks like
it'd be a great service so be the first
to get on the list and get this
installed on your phone if you're
interested
go ahead and subscribe and if you're
ready for this we are ready for you so
make sure that you can get some feedback
about real-world situations so putting a
landing page out there is one way
now check your assumptions because
you are probably convinced that your app
is great but that's not the right answer
you need to find out if other people are
feeling the same way
so conduct interviews start with your
friends your family
work with people that you meet and ask
them these questions so how do you
currently do activity x
so for instance how do you currently
manage your freelance operations that
would be a good question from one of the
examples we just looked at
do you like your current process if so
tell me about it if not what would make
it better
and then i show you the solution
and here is the screenshots this is the
outline this is what i think will happen
do you think this would help you
and then please explain
and so this is a great way to verify
that people would buy into your app and
hopefully you have honest feedback to
say nah or yeah and so then you've got
something actionable
so where are you going to conduct these
interviews where you're going to find
people that are willing to talk to you
hopefully you have some targeted spots
well you can start online
so i did a quick search here for
some comment reviews on youtube so you
could publish a youtube video talking
about your service
you could sell ads to get people to
watch it and then ask for comments to
say is this a great idea would you pay
for it so here's an example
so apple just launched the purple iphone
now my opinion of it was
seriously
apple has billions of dollars and
brilliant engineers and the best upgrade
they could come up with was purple
however looking at the comments of this
youtube i can see that
there's a lot of positive feedback
now i don't know are those people that
were hired by apple to go out and
provide some good feedback
or these actual users so that's
unknown but anyway there's some feedback
that you could use as some research
here's another go to reddit and sign up
for the thread called app ideas and you
can post your idea people can tell you
whether it's a good idea or not or you
might discover some other people's ideas
now this specific idea i kind of liked
have an app that uses gps to track your
walking or running or cycling miles
and instead of just showing you the map
overlay it against a fiction map such as
middle earth and you can see how much
progress you make on a daily basis
before you get to mount doom
and so you could do other maps uh
fantasy places so you could go to
narnia or middle earth or you could have
people crossing other continents
you could climb mount everest if you
were doing a stair-stepping app and so
you could have people set goals and have
some fun doing it so
this app doesn't exist
it got 38 up votes it looks like so
apparently someone thinks it's a good
idea
so you could go there how about this you
could just come up with your own web
page just say i'm gonna launch this and
start to advertise it and get feedback
from people so it might cost you a few
dollars to set one up but you're going
to have more information before you
actually start spending the real money
about building your app
here's a great way to get user feedback
in your own town
so meetup is a nice app and website
where you can find special interest
groups in your community
so i've certainly found a bunch here in
phoenix where i live about software
development and everybody at the meeting
is looking for a job or they have
interests in finding other people that
are doing the same thing that they are
and it never fails
that people go there to
learn from each other so we learn about
who the companies are that they work for
you learn about new software you learn
about new techniques
and this is a great spot where you could
do informal interviews when you got a
drink in your hand and you're just
talking to people and trying to pitch
your idea getting the feedback that you
need
show it to your friends show it to your
family show it to co-workers show it to
anybody that would give you the time
and watch what they do
so you can see their feedback whether
it's confusion disbelief or maybe you've
got some good ideas in there so
refine your idea based on what they tell
you
if you got some money you can have other
people do your reset search for you such
as mintel
so you can see that they will sell you a
report from anywhere from 2000 to it
looks like about five thousand dollars
and they will actually do market
research about trends about here it says
families in the uk what they're doing
uh health and wellness in china
so you can find your report here and if
you've got the money you can save
yourself a lot of time
so they'll tell you if people are
willing and how willing they are to
spend their money on certain things
uh here's an example from mintel
so about research in the united states
so what people are doing with insurance
and for forty five hundred dollars
you can answer that question so if
you've got the money you can save the
time so here's another example of
mintel's market research it says here
hbo now users are twice as likely
from any other streaming service to
cancel their subscription
when a specific show ends
okay so if you're trying to do market
research for streaming services
you would want to know what did mint or
what did hbo do
that causes people to leave them so
easily
and what do other people do that makes
them sticky
and so you can gain insights and adjust
your plans for your own product with
results like this
here's a great way to conduct your
interviews first of all listen you're
there to learn because the expert in the
conversation is the customer
you are trying to gather data you have a
proposal and your your whole goal is
here is to experiment and test it and
see if it is as valuable as you think it
is and if it's not you want to know why
so understand what their problem is so
your solution might not be quite right
but if you could tweak it it would be
the right product for them
show them a prototype to see if
concretely
it matches what they believe so
showing a prototype is a lot better than
just explaining an idea the more
specific and graphic and concrete you
can make it the better they'll
understand you
then get a reaction so listen for
suggestions see if they're confused see
if they're blase
you can measure pretty much on scales of
1 to 10 and what they feel like and
actually give them that opportunity to
rate what they believe with a number and
so these interviews then are going to
provide you with a lot of good data
another way to do this is to conduct
what's called focus groups and so you
can bring people in
and provide them
benefits such as money
or a good meal and just ask them
questions
so people will sometimes give you their
time if you make it worth their while
you can also hire these focused research
groups
from other companies that do surveys
and
i don't know if i would
find them as a great value or not i
think you'd probably have a good
experience of doing it yourself
and spend similar amounts of money but i
know that they're out there so if you
want to do focus groups you can get some
more information
so let's take a look at an app that i
that i said i used in a previous video i
said i used all trails what would an
interview look like if they were coming
up with the plan and so they look at me
i'm a hiker i'm a backpacker and they
ask me these questions so they would say
currently how do you find good places to
hike
and i would say i read magazines i look
at google images i look at the map i
watch instagram and then i try to go
from there but i really don't know if
i'm finding anything good or not until i
actually show up so how does that work
for you
the information is usually incomplete i
must make a guess
and so i would like it if there were
actual more concrete suggestions so what
features do you like in our solution
well i would say i'd like to have photos
of the hike the park where i go to i
want to see what the national park trail
looks like i want to have actual reviews
from people that hiked it maybe just a
week ago is there snow on the trail or
is the bridge out those kind of
informational
tidbits are really important on user
reviews so to me it looks like they did
their homework they found their ideal
users and then they asked them these
questions and they incorporated exactly
what was needed so like i mentioned
earlier in another video i pay them
money on a yearly basis which is kind of
painful because i don't like to pay for
software but in this case it's very well
worth my time
here's another application that i
purchased so
some time ago i was a math teacher and i
was doing tutoring on the side and so i
was helping people do their high school
trigonometry their calculus
and
one tool that i kept buying for my
students was
wolfram alpha a strange name
but it is the ultimate graphing
calculator it can solve problems and
show you visual solutions
and so if you ask how do you currently
solve math problems i use pencil and
paper i use inflection points and
vertexes and
it's tedious
i will pay you
whatever it takes because you are you
are creating a solution that that solves
a painful problem for me and so a lot of
my uh students paid for this on their
own
based on my recommendations so
they obviously know their audience as
well that's my point here is that they
did their focus groups they did their
user interviews and they met exactly
what the users wanted
now here's what's going to happen then
so you do these interviews
and you're going to have
what you think then
is a pretty good idea of what people
want
and so
you must do these because if you
have this
we will build it and they will come
attitude if you think that way you might
spend a lot of time and effort when they
won't come now this i think this comes
from field of dreams the movie where uh
was it kevin costner decided to put a
baseball diamond in the middle of a
cornfield
and
he said if we built it they will come
and of course it's a horrible marketing
strategy
if you build it they might come so make
sure that you verify your assumptions
with interviews and tests
pay for the google ads if you have to
pay for the interviews because the money
you invest will be well worth it and so
what you're standing on right now is the
left side of the cliff
you are looking at what current data is
you have uh other models to follow you
have businesses that you can imitate you
have track records in history but what
you're trying to get to is this
vision to say i'm pretty sure they'll
come
and so before you take that leap try to
close the gap
by verifying things let me give an
example of a company that did exactly
that
so zappos
owned now by
amazon
was a startup company some years ago
that wanted to sell shoes online
so
they had an interesting problem
they didn't know if people would
actually buy shoes online
so
instead of building an entire
distribution system
they started a website and advertised
some shoes
at the current competitive retail price
and they said buy shoes from us and so
people would fill in the form and click
buy and they would get an email so how
did they fulfill their orders
well amazingly zappos literally went to
the store where the shoes were sold so
they went to their local department
store
bought the shoes went to the post office
and mailed them
and of course it was a huge loss they
took money to buy the shoes and the
postage was completely
expense right out of their pocket as
well as the time and effort but their
point wasn't to make money selling those
shoes their point was to prove to
themselves that people were willing to
buy shoes
in the mail
and the experiment worked and of course
zappos is worth quite a bit of money
today and they're owned
by amazon and so what you want to do
then is to verify who your user is
and whether he or she is willing to use
your product and if it doesn't match
then you can abandon the idea without
spending too much money or you can
adjust your idea so it fits exactly what
your users need
the next step is to figure out how to
design the perfect application
and so that's the next video and then if
you want to see the rest of the videos
in this course then check out take a
look at the playlist here and you can
follow along on some of the other topics
so thanks for watching and welcome to
class
[Music]
hi welcome back to the business of apps
this is a series of videos that i'm
doing with my class right now about the
business process and the design of
building an app and so you can see all
the different topics that we're talking
about here so we're in topic one right
now which is the motivations for
building an app and what i'm going to do
is give you an activity so if you're in
my classroom i would actually assign
this and grade it to you if you're just
watching along then take a look at what
i think you should do next so what i'd
like to assign is something to listen to
about airbnb
and lyft so these are obviously two
mobile applications that are very
successful leaders in their world so the
first is an interview with the founder
of airbnb
so this appears on a radio program for
npr called how i built this and so it's
a very interesting interview it talks
about the story behind how the business
airbnb came into existence so this
doesn't really show a direct line from
point a to b for this business plan uh
at the time it seemed very strange why
would anyone want to stay in a
stranger's home and why would you let
anyone come in and sleep in your living
room and so how did they create a new
business model that has now
control of more
hotel rooms than any other hotel company
in the world
the second interview is also from how i
built this and this one comes from lyft
which is also a mobile application and
they grew from a campus ride sharing
service into a an uber-like company
the greatest competition that uber has
really and so with these two different
interviews i'm going to ask you to take
a look at five questions
and so if like i said if you're in my
class i'm going to ask you to write
these out so the first one is
after you hear these two people talk i
want you to
answer the question what is the core
business of airbnb and lyft each of them
have a different core business obviously
but
what i'm trying to distinguish here is
that the app itself
is just a means to an end and so if
you're thinking about app development
and growing it into a business um think
in reverse maybe and so ask yourself
what does airbnb do
and why do they need an app to do it
second question
how does the mobile app enable them to
function could they do it without the
app could they do it without computers
and is there anything secret about it
that would make that success and so they
had to do it at this time and no other
to become in the business that they are
also
think about a wider scope so what
besides the website or the mobile app
does this company need to
provide successful service to their comp
to their clients
so do they need people to answer the
phone do they need quality assurance do
they need sales people do do they need
drivers do they what do they need to
make their business run
and so if you are thinking about i'm
going to build an app business
look at these two examples that are
clearly app businesses
and think of how much else they have to
do besides create code
and a website and then here's another
one
so besides mobile apps
how else do they communicate with their
customers
so the mobile app i think is central
but what other services do they do and
then finally
why are these two companies successful
literally you could build either one of
these apps
as a semester project
in one of my classes you could learn all
the technical things about
programming the interface putting the
database together scaling it even on the
cloud
but yet you wouldn't have airbnb or lyft
when you're done
you would have an app with no users
and so how did they go from
the app stage to
millions of user stage what was the
secret what was the
process that they followed what were the
challenges that they faced and so what
i'd like you to do in this activity then
is to consider these five
and then also
consider your own project so likely you
have something floating around in your
brain don't you i mean you've we've all
got
an app that we would like to make and so
i'd like you to then take a look at
these same questions and apply them to
what you're working on now or what
you're dreaming about now and so using
airbnb and lyft as case studies we can
learn a lot about our own selves and
perhaps
if we have that in our future if you're
interested in looking at the motives for
how to build an application and some of
the questions you have to ask before you
even code then i have a video to check
out here also if you'd like to look at
the entire playlist for the business of
mobile applications then take a look at
the link that's here and thanks for
watching and please subscribe
[Music]
hi welcome to the business of building
apps in this video we're going to talk
about an assignment that i'm going to
give you if you were one of the students
in my class so the business of building
apps has several chapters and we're here
in chapter one which is about the
motivations for building an app
so we're going to call this assignment
activity 1.2
and so what we're trying to do here is
examine the current marketplace of
applications and see if there's any
results that we could glean from the
market and where there might be
opportunities for you to build an app so
the first thing we're going to do is
look at app annie so i'd like you to go
to this address and look at the top apps
um what we're looking for are trends
or for any gleanings of information
about what makes an app successful or
if it is so unlikely that we are going
to succeed against them to see if there
are any opportunities where we could
find something that we might be able to
compete against
so for instance you're probably not
going to replace minecraft or youtube or
roblox as you see here but if we look
down the list we might see some
opportunities so a second source of
information that i want you to examine
is here at sensor tower
and so you can see that it looks like
the same kind of a organization where we
have the top apps for each category so
you can look at games and fitness and
other different categories but if you
look on the left side sensor tower
provides more information than app annie
does so you can examine the details of a
single app you can compare
in this section called app intelligence
to know more about it and so for example
here clash of clans we get some drill
down detail on
when they made their money and how much
uh activity they see do we see any
trends seasonally so if you're trying to
compete against clash of clans this
obviously is an important report
we're trying to think of our own app
though that's that's the goal of this
course is we're starting to form our own
opinions about
what our app can do and who our
customers are and so clash of clans
probably isn't one that you want to
compare directly against but find a
competitor
that you are probably going head-to-head
with and see what kind of results they
have and maybe you can glean some
information there
so statistica this is another website
that can give us insights into mobile
apps and so i went to their web page and
picked a current uh report that was here
that says total value of global
consumers spending on
mobile apps in the fourth quarter of
2020. so obviously we see a
kind of a gradual trend and then
suddenly there is this massive jump
something happened
what do you suppose that might have been
so what we're doing right now is we're
just looking at raw data and reports
and i'm going to ask you in this
assignment to draw some conclusions so
here's what we're going to conclude
i want you to provide
several statements at least three of the
market in general
so where would you find some
opportunities that's really the market
research here
looking at what's going on with trends
and where would you find yourself
something that can lead to success or
failure so it's an open-ended assignment
here you are now a business analyst
you're not just a programmer or you're
not just answering questions out of a
textbook what i want you to do is
pretend that i'm your boss right
and i look at you and i say
find me
a market opportunity go look at the
competitors see where things are moving
what is opening up to us and where could
we possibly enter and so really that's a
very high level kind of a question to
say analyze and compare and make
predictions so you're not in high school
anymore we're trying to make you a
business analyst so the conclusions that
i want you to do are things that might
look like this so
we're going to say these topx apps
accounted for 80 of all downloads so
what would that do for your manager
well it would tell us that there is some
very dominant players in that segment or
we might have a different kind of a
observation so looking at our category
so we'll call it category x
looking at our type of app that we're
considering building there is no clear
market leader
and so therefore you would tell your
boss i think we've got a chance to
become that market leader there's nobody
yet that has dominated that space
or we might say category x our category
has increased in user downloads by a
massive percentage in the last 12 months
or contrary you might say what we were
thinking of doing online donut ordering
is actually not something that people
care about and it's falling in the last
12 months i don't know what the
statistics will be you're the one that's
going to do the research and find that
out how about this we
we found a new emerging leader so app x
recently created an entirely new
category
something that is unique and it is
growing rapidly so we could probably tag
along with them maybe and see if there's
an opportunity to become maybe second or
third in that category and compete or
how about this you might find a
conclusion that says x percent of apps
get less than y per downloads per month
so there's some category that we were
considering but we realize nobody cares
about there's hardly anyone downloading
there so maybe that is your conclusion
how about this one we could find a
different conclusion that says only x
companies account for 80 of downloads
similar to number one and then similar
we might have another dominant leader at
the bottom that says there's only a few
apps that are collecting all the money
or new apps account for percent of some
total monthly downloads so
the conclusions that you draw here are
not something that i can tell you
exactly what the right ones are
so that's what market researchers do is
they try to find the needle in the
haystack
and so those are called market study
conclusions
so when you're done with that it's a
better idea to present something to your
boss in a summarized graph so this is
where excel comes in where you can
create pie charts and line charts and
trends and then you can you can
visualize your statements very easily
and then finally i'm going to ask you to
do a summarize so write a paragraph to
answer the following question to say
what category should i compete in if i
were to build an application really
that's the conclusion that's the whole
point of all this research is we're
trying to find an opportunity out there
in the market so
if we've got several opportunities that
would be great and we can consider
options a b and c but that's your goal
here so for the deliverables i want you
to create a one-page document and you're
going to embed a chart
and i want you to tell me where the
opportunities are
if i were your boss and you were the
business analyst
what should we be doing
what opportunities should we pursue so
if you're one of my students i will
evaluate you on how well you can write
and how well you can draw conclusions
from a wide variety of sets of data i
will put a link here so that you can see
the rest of the course material and then
see some background on how we came up
with this
also if if you're not one of my students
then feel free to put these kind of
conclusions in the comments below and
everyone else can evaluate your work
based on the youtube commenting system
thanks for watching
[Music]
hi and welcome to the business of
building applications in this video
we're going to talk about an assignment
that i would give you if you were in my
class so this is a course about building
apps and the business plans that go with
them so we're in number one which is
chapters about motivations for building
an app and so that's what the activity
will be so we'll call this activity or
assignment 1.3 so the third one that i'm
going to grade you on if you were in my
class so this activity is going to be
about writing down the details
of a plan so a plan for building an app
and building a business
so what i want you to do first is think
about problems that would be able to be
solved with a business solution
so this is where we're going to be
writing in just a minute so background
information here is to think about how
other apps are solving problems for
instance how to find a hotel room
quickly that's a business problem or how
to save money while grocery shopping
that is also addressing a business
problem or maybe how to visit a
destination using a virtual tour guide
maybe not so much business as just
tourism but the idea is that each one of
these could have an app that would be
the solution to this person's issue
so then what i want you to think about
then are the personal interests that you
have or the problems that you face in
your own work those are currently
things that are bothering you those are
often the best kinds of solutions that
you can invent and so that's where i'm
going to have you think so what i want
you to do is to think of a product idea
hopefully you've already got one that's
been brewing in the
dreams of your head
an idea and we're going to write about
it in six different paragraphs
so first of all i'm going to say
identify what problem exists
for the ideal user so we're thinking
about what they call a persona somebody
that fits the mold somebody that fits
the profile of who would buy your app
and so what problem do they have
tell me that that's your first paragraph
the second is
more about that ideal user so the ideal
user is you're going to tell me their
age range you're going to tell me their
gender what hobbies they have or where
they work
why they fit this category what things
do they do on a frequent basis what
preferences do they have do they have
strong political beliefs do they have
certain practices such as are they an
environmentalist or are they a gun
activist
or where are they in the education world
you know those kind of
demographics and
ideas that kind of categorize people
so then the next question is and you're
going you're going to write this
paragraph is
what do you do
in your app
that will solve a specific problem that
this person experiences so we're doing
the profile and now we're coming up with
a solution
so what does the app look like so here's
we're making a an app plan right
so your solution then is going to be
what does
your app have for screens the wireframes
what what you know what's the navigation
how do you get from the title screen to
the first screen and so on
and then i'm going to ask you
what competition currently exists for
your app so you've done some market
research right
who are the people that already have a
solution that is
like yours or adjacent to yours
something that is a competitor
and then what do you propose
will be your distinguishing
characteristics what makes you different
why is your app slightly better
and so in six paragraphs you're going to
give me a business plan essentially
why your app makes sense
and who it makes sense for
so then what i want you to do then is
after you've written up this document
you don't just turn it in and say i'm
done i want you to take this and
actually do some real world interviews i
want you to get some user feedback and
so you can go talk to your friends or
your family or if you don't have friends
or family you can post it on reddit or
somewhere and get some user interviews
what i want you to do is to describe
your app you're going to show them
the problem you're going to show them
the wireframe or whatever you've got for
pictures
and then you're going to get the
reaction
so you're going to give them open-ended
questions so in your interview you ask
your mom
tell me what you like about this product
maybe your mom's not the best person
because she'll just say i love
everything that you do
so
tell it to one of your friends what do
you like about the product and what do
you think it's lacking
what would you change about it did i get
close to what your solutions are do you
care about this and if you do what would
you make a difference on a scale of one
to ten then how likely are you to use
the app if it were available today and
of course maybe a follow-up question is
would you be willing to pay for it
and so that is your user interviews so
what you're going to conclude then from
these unit user interviews is one
you've either got a great idea or two
you'll get a gigantic yawn and people
will ignore you
so the summary that i want you to get
from that is
who did you interview and why did you
choose them and then finally what did
you learn did you get anything from them
because you thought you were the expert
when you started this process but you
quickly learn that you are the student
the real experts are the potential users
and so what did you learn after you
presented your ideas to them so then
part three then we've created a plan for
part one part two we've shared it with a
few people
and now we're going to do
plan b you might call it and sometimes
that's the best thing you can do is
figure out what doesn't quite work so
based on the feedback that you received
i want you then to write what you did
would modify
what features would you need to add or
people didn't care about what
modifications would make your app better
conduct new interviews then so you can
go back to the same people or find
somebody similar
and see if there's a different response
then after your
suggestions were implemented and then
finally i want you to re record any of
the insights that you learned from these
people so this is somewhat of a big
writing assignment isn't it not only do
you have to write but you have to talk
to people and figure out what they want
so then for the deliverables this is
what i want you to submit to me i want
you to write a three to five word page
word document that describes the ideal
app idea
what your user is
what did you put in for the features
what suggestions did you incorporate
from your users and what did you learn
from these interviews and so if i were
to grade you i would base your grade
based on not only how you write but how
thorough you were and how well you
learned and listened to your users so
really that's the goal here when you're
designing an app is to conform it to
what the users want rather than your own
preconceived notions so if you'd like to
see the entire playlist for this course
i'll post that here and if you're not in
my class then you can feel free to put
these assignments in the comments here
and let the youtube comment system do
your grading for you and you can comment
on other users too and based on what
they think their app ideas are so thanks
for watching and make sure that you
subscribe
[Music]
hi and welcome back to the course that
we're teaching right now called the
business of building applications so
we're talking about mobile applications
and the process of design and running
your business so you can see that we are
in several different units of study
right now and we're on the second one
which is called designing an effective
app however there's a lot more material
here so if you would like to take a look
at some of these others make sure that
you subscribe to the channel and watch
along my name is chad slooter and i'm a
professor of software development and
computer science at grand canyon
university and so the course that we're
working right now is called building
apps and the business of design so in
this video we're talking about the
features that you would put into an
early version of your app perhaps the
first version of your app so application
design includes these four topics that
we're going to see in the next few
videos so we're talking about the first
one right now which is which features
should you put in there the user
interface answers the question of what
does your app look like the ux or the
user experience is how is the user
experiencing the entrance the actual
flow of your app the product delivery
and things like that so the experience
is the overall feel and then finally we
have what's called the mvp which is
called the minimal viable product and so
getting your app to market involves
making some very strategic decisions
about how it looks like how your users
experience it and how much you spend on
the early development stages so taking a
look from google we have some advice for
what users think about what makes their
application valuable so the question is
what users find most valuable about
their favorite apps and so if you're
designing make sure that you focus in on
these key features so number one on the
list they're easy to use and navigate i
suppose if you get that rule right
you've probably made almost all of the
right decisions
there's always something new to explore
that's number two and so in a future
video we're going to talk about making
your apps addictive or a nicer way of
saying
increasing user loyalty and so we'll be
addressing that in its own topic and so
then you can see down the rest of them
they drop off quickly but the first one
is probably the most important getting
your app easy to use and navigation and
so that's what this video and the next
few are all about
so we are in this process let's get
context of where we are
so in earlier videos we talked about the
problem that we're trying to solve
identifying a solution to have known
need number two is finding our niche and
so looking at the competition and
finding a place where we're going to
succeed and the competition won't crush
us
and now we're into this third one here
about figuring out what user features
are really important and which ones can
wait till later
and balancing the user needs and the
costs and then finally the user
interface and the experience is where
we're going today
so the question is if you've got a list
of nice things that your users want you
to create
which ones are you going to prioritize
so you don't want to create what's
called a frankenstein app where it has
every feature and nobody cares about it
you want to address what matters the
most
so one way to do this is to take a look
at your competition uh apps that are
similar to what you're trying to develop
and compare what they have
so earlier we looked in another video
about the
opportunity here about an app called
words with friends one of the biggest
apps that you've probably seen in the
games
and we found a pri a surprising
discovery here if you look at the
reviews currently they're receiving
mostly one-star reviews because of one
single problem
they're advertising so they're annoying
their users even though it's a free app
people will still expect a good
experience
and so if you're looking at building an
app and you have a similar review
problem in the app store take close note
of that because you don't want to make
sure that you do the same mistake how
about this is there an opportunity here
so i remember at one time it was kind of
a joke to put on your resume that i'm a
an application designer for craigslist
or
i am a css expert for craigslist it's
almost like a friend of mine who was a
architect for the aldi's grocery store
and if you know anything about all these
they pretty much look like craigslist
they're a warehouse where they just
throw boxes on pallets and expect people
to shop there and so there is there an
opportunity here craigslist was so
dominant well there is
i have certainly used offer up it's
craigslist but with a good user
interface
and you've got yourself less spam going
on you've got less corruption uh you've
got a great communication tool the
browsing and the the video the pictures
are good um i haven't used craigslist
since
now here's what you want to do then if
you're looking for some kind of an
opportunity like that whether it's
you're trying to kill craigslist or
words with friends or likely some other
app that you're targeting right now
think of what you guys have in common so
your proposed app
and what the competition does that
overlap will call analogies and you want
to check to see if the user experience
is good in those areas and if so then
don't be afraid to copy it i mean
certainly every time snapchat or tick
tock comes off with something cool
instagram is not afraid to copy exactly
what they see there because
we don't want to lose out on what's
actually working
now what the competition does
and what you choose to leave out we
could call the anti-log that would be
the
anti-analogy
and if they are doing something wrong
make sure you leave that part of it out
and make your app somewhat unique and so
that way you take the best and leave
what they don't want so let me give you
an example so here is something i found
on reddit where a person was doing some
research
and their research involved comparing
different weather apps that are
available so you can see that this uh
reddit thread is android apps so this
person is talking about designing their
own weather app and they did the
research to find out who's out there and
what they can do
so you can see they created a table
and they have all of the different uh
currently published apps out there they
talk about the weather providers the
number of
widgets that are there the hourly
temperatures and all the features and so
they go right through everybody's
competition and come up with a pretty
good
chart to know
what is available now so if you were to
try to get into this crowded market and
build the better weather app you'd
probably want to look at this chart very
carefully and see which features are
working which ones that are really
important to the users and which ones
are just complete add-ons or even
annoying and so you can tell that the
research here is done with quite a bit
of time and effort
also in the typical reddit fashion
there's all kinds of very honest reviews
and feedback about people that talk
about which app they use and which ones
they don't like and
what works and even in some cases you
can talk directly to developer here in
one of the apps and so do something
similar to this if you are anticipating
creating a list of features
so once you get yourself a little bit of
competition and you make a table like
this then it's time to identify the main
features of your application let's say
you're going to build a social app so
something along the lines of facebook or
instagram and so you're going to put
down the user stories or different tasks
or different abilities that your app
will feature so for instance
one feature of your app would be to say
users will create an account using
current google or facebook password you
put it on a sticky note so that way you
can move it around users will be able to
set up a profile that's another action
that the users will do
the main part of your app of course is
post a public message with a video or
photo or browse other people's posts and
maybe comment on them able to write
things or put a like and so this is
pretty typical social media things now
you put these together and you start to
see the number of hours of work adding
up and so it's time to prioritize which
of these features are going into your
app by the way there's nothing really
unique on this app so
what do you have that is the twist what
is the unique feature or value
proposition and that should probably
show up in one of your posts so once you
have most of the main features then you
want to be able to put them into
categories and so a user experience
should have some kind of a cycle or
process that they follow through
and as well you should probably think
about
which parts of your application have
good amounts of these features and which
don't so think of the first problem
called activation so which features help
you activate your app or how do users
find you you better have a feature in
there acquisition means how do you on
board the users get them from a
interested party a curious party to
somebody that's registered and somebody
who is an active user
then the retention part is what is the
main point of your application it better
be interesting it better be engaging it
better be entertaining it it better be
useful there's something there that is
the main reason that people came now
this is the main course and now then you
get to the point where you say i want my
app to grow so there should be some kind
of a way to refer others whether you
invite them to play a game with you or
to share a photo or to at least get some
kind of another download from another
user and then lastly perhaps somewhere
in here there should be a monetization
so either you ask the users to pay you
money or you show them an ad or some
kind of a way that you can do a cut of
business and so monetization can fit in
one of these categories so let's give an
example here so if we're talking about
our social app we would probably say our
activation comes because a friend
invited you to respond to a picture and
then the next step is the acquisition so
as you have to log into the account
you're invited to create your own
profile and then you're hopefully going
to respond you're going to either play
the game with them or you're going to
read the post or put a comment on it and
then hopefully you share a picture and
invite somebody else to look at it and
then the cycle repeats and once again
make sure that there's some kind of a
way to make a monetization play here so
show an ad that seems to be a pretty
typical thing for social media now ads
aren't always great but they're pretty
typical as a solution so this is our
feature map with the objectives so let's
put in here the first one which was
activation so the users will create an
account so they're going to use google
or facebook password so activation we've
got that one covered we also have they
will be able to set up a profile so
we'll put that in that column retention
means what are we doing that creates
actual value or entertainment to the stu
to the people that are here and so
posting a public message with a photo or
video would fit we can also browse other
people's items and so we have an
interesting activity going on that's
retention and then we have the ability
to write now you might be able to say is
that is that part of the retention or
that might fit into referral so maybe
one of those two categories would fit
now i've got some gaps though because
i've only created two columns and i have
three empty ones so i might start to say
well let's add some new features that i
hadn't actually thought of because we're
not covering all the bases so we have a
new feature called share a picture with
a friend with either a phone message or
an email and so that clearly fits in the
referral category well we don't have
monetization and acquisition filled in
yet so what are we going to do there
well how are we going to monetize well
maybe people have a a desire to promote
their photo or their picture or if we
were doing some kind of a job posting we
could pro we could
promote your uh your resume or something
that people are willing to pay for for
other people to notice and so we'll put
that into the monetization category
here's another one notify the user when
your post has been liked oh we all want
to know that three people have seen our
video and so we'll put that into the
retention area so that's interesting how
about this generate a web page so how
are we going to get people to look at
our images how we're going to invite
them into the app
well you can rely on people inviting
other friends that's one way to do it or
in this strategy we would create deep
links and so if somebody is posting
about a picture or a subject about
something that would be hit in google
searches a place a geography place or an
event or a celebrity or something
then we can hopefully get a few people
that are doing web searches with google
and we pick up them through web pages so
then you've probably mapped out most of
the columns by now and you have the
basic features of your application now
the the point of this video is to try to
focus on limiting your desire to fill
everything
in the first stages of building an
application you want to do what's called
a minimal viable product you don't want
to have the entire thing developed
because that's expensive and it's still
untested so what we're trying to avoid
is a frankenstein app so frankenstein of
course is the movie or the story of
building a monster out of body parts and
this actually is a photo from
experiments that were done in the 1700s
of using body parts with electricity so
the danger of creating too many features
is that you have created things that
your users don't actually need so let me
refer you to a good blog post on the
subject so uh beware of feature overload
a case study and so even though this was
written some years ago it's still very
uh applicable today so i wanted to
capture this picture here so
live chat was this person's company
communication tool
and the point of putting it on the blog
was to talk about how bad the user
interface was how many features that
they've tried to crowd in on one item so
look up close here we've got ourselves
every feature possible
and to the software developer it makes
total sense they've got everything there
but for you and me that have never seen
the app before
it's a little overwhelming where do we
start what feature is most important
and when you're trying to onboard
somebody the goal is to leave them
basically one option
just the one option that they need to do
next and hide the other features until
they've become a little more proficient
with the app and so this is
i don't know if you could call it a
frankenstein app but it's certainly
overwhelming
now if we scroll down a bit they came up
with another version of the same tool
now this one here is called live chat
and
it certainly presents a whole lot fewer
options i assume all this all the
features are still there you can
probably find them if you click the
right menu and then you're looking for
those features but if you're trying to
scare away your users with overwhelming
amounts of choice
then the first version is your goal so
you can see down here the conclusion is
the lesson learned product teams should
learn to say no and that's the point of
the video that i'm telling you here is
that when you're picking your features
for your first version of your
application pick only the ones that are
absolutely critical and simplify your
app so let's do a summary of what we
talked about so far so that for the
features that you're going to include in
your app make sure that you have them
proven to be necessary you've already
done your interviews with your users and
they've told you what they think is the
most critical parts of the service and
so make sure that you include those also
you might want to include things that
are fairly easy to develop so that you
don't invest a lot of time and money and
so really what you're developing then is
considered the minimal viable product or
mvp and we'll talk about that in a later
video so once you've identified the
features it's now time to create the
user interface and so if you want to
look at that the next video in the
series is exactly about how you can
create an effective user interface if
you want to see the entire list of
course material then take a look here at
the playlist that's in the other link so
thank you for watching and welcome
aboard
[Music]
hey welcome back to the business of
building apps this is a course that will
help you create apps and the business of
making sure that it's a profitable
business for you so in this course we're
talking about seven or eight different
categories so we're in item number two
right now which is about designing an
app but as you can see there are other
chapters and other topics that we need
to cover and so if you'd like to see
some of these make sure that you
subscribe and watch the others my name
is shad slooter and i'm a professor of
software development and computer
science at grand canyon university and
so welcome to class and please join us
for others so in this we are talking
about application design and so really
those are four questions about how your
app's going to look first of all which
features are we going to choose second
what the app looks like third what's the
experience of the user and finally what
goes into creating a minimal viable
product or the mvp and so we're here in
section two if you haven't seen the
others please look at the other items in
the playlist for this course so what
does the app look like is what we're
asking today
and what that question is is what is the
user interface going to be what are the
principles of design and how do you make
an effective user interface and so to
answer that question we need to talk
about a process called
onboarding so onboarding is a way to
turn a novice or completely ignorant
person about your application into
somebody who is a minimal user somebody
who is adopting your program
so onboarding sounds exactly like what
it's it's talking about getting on a
ship and so let's think about the
process of a
cruise company and adopting users into
their system so you're the crew's client
you're going on vacation and you show up
at the boat what are the questions that
you would have when you get to the dock
the questions are going to be things
like immediate needs where's my room
does my key work
or where do i put my suitcases so if
you're trying to onboard a customer in
this situation you better make sure that
these questions are answered don't shove
a menu in their face or give them a plan
for how they're going to get off and do
tours at the first island those are for
later and so once people get installed
into their room and they got their first
cup of coffee and they start to feel
comfortable what are their next
questions going to be they're going to
say what's the wi-fi password or when is
supper or what entertainment is
happening on the ship and so these are
questions that you would present to the
user when they get to this stage and so
you might have a piece of paper or a
poster in the room or some kind of a
guide on an app or whatever you're going
to guide them through the process of
onboarding and so you want to do the
same thing with your applications and so
don't present them with all of the
features of your user interface at the
beginning just give them
one or maybe two options and make it so
obvious that they always choose the most
logical thing so only show the most
urgent and essential features of your
starting screen and in our case since
we're starting a brand new app
maybe that's the only features that are
in your app and so your user interface
makes sure that the essential features
are obvious and super easy to adopt so
perhaps one of the best examples of
making things obvious is
google no wonder they're a good search
company well they give good searches but
there's really only one thing to do here
uh you have a search item
and you have this other i'm feeling
lucky i don't even know why they still
have that there i've never clicked it
other than the first experimental time
but anyway they're pretty simple they've
got a great user interface now consider
what they used to compete against
yahoo was really the only other viable
choice for search engines and
what in the world are we supposed to do
here so if you knew what you were after
when you started yahoo you probably hit
the search bar
but they've got so many other
distractions going on am i supposed to
download a toolbar well no thanks on
that one am i supposed to browse news am
i supposed to get weather
and there were a lot of choices and i
think the strategy was let's just give
every kind of idea possible to our users
and increase interactivity there instead
of focusing on one really good thing
such as search
they tried the buffet approach and other
than giving away all of their user data
in a data breach
yahoo just was completely defeated by
google for a number of reasons so don't
be yahoo when you're trying to create an
app so it's fun to hate people so let's
go take a look at another one that i
would like to criticize so this is adobe
illustrator
photoshop and illustrator are like the
dominant tools for design and graphic
arts so i consider myself somewhat
proficient in both of these i teach them
in school
but the one thing that always bothers me
is
ironically the tool used to design user
interfaces and choose layouts and
wireframes in itself is a horrible
example of a user interface
as you can see if i want to select a
color there are multiple ways to
get to that and so adobe apparently
thought that multiple ways is a good
thing and the users have flexibility you
can even
you can even customize the user
interface so that only you understand it
and everyone else that looks at your
computer is completely baffled
and so
this is an example of succeeding
in spite of having a bad product
and so
what do these icons do
if you look at these photoshop icons you
can see that they have
some kind of a purpose and then you
click and hold on them for goodness
sakes who have ever thought of that you
click and do a long click on them and
you get more menus that pop out beneath
them
the only way you can know what these are
is either to have a youtube video from
some 14 year old that's going to
demonstrate the the process for you or
take a class
what software requires you to take a
class in other words to become a user
that's just telling me that there's
way better solutions that could be done
take a look at here's another example
how to export a file so i choose export
and now i'm presented with what a dozen
different things to export in different
ways
please help us this should be a dialog
box and so adobe
ironically has
the market on all of this here's their
layers palette so what are you supposed
to do here what is kind normal
what is going on with these little icons
at the bottom some of these are effects
some are browsing folders
it's a it's a complete overwhelming
experience for a new user now if you're
already an adobe user and you know all
these features you're probably proud of
the fact that you've mastered the
program well good for you for the rest
of us though we want to have something
simpler so what is this thing this is
sketch
so a competitor
that does a lot of complex things to be
fair photoshop and illustrator are
complicated programs they do very
sophisticated things but there are
better alternatives out there
basically because of their user
interface and user experience they have
all the features but presented in a much
more
straightforward manner how many people
actually need to read the manual for
sketch what a contrast to what there is
for adobe products here's another one
that i picked up
this one this is what happens when you
let developers build the user interface
so
check this one out what in the world are
we supposed to do here how many check
boxes do we need
every one of these should be hidden away
in another separate section where it
shows up only when we need it to be and
so if you're a developer don't take
offense there are people out there
better than us i consider myself a
developer there are people out there
that are better than us at user
interface design
and so it might be worth your time or
money to get some advice
and at least get some plans from a user
interface perspective before you go
ahead and develop your first
vision so here's the design order of
what we're trying to create so let's get
some context here so first of all we
picked out what our user needs are we
figured out which features are going to
meet those needs and now we're on
creating the views so every feature that
you create
has to have some kind of a screen to go
with it the view and then finally we'll
get to the navigation at a later point
so let's talk about some of the ui
elements that are going to make your app
effective some best practices so this is
just the 10 minute version of an entire
profession so
a mobile application should have some
consistency you should probably have
something as a
the
typical app so don't try to get too
creative on your user interface here
make sure that you have a bottom toolbar
and a top toolbar where users can see
the same thing on each screen
so separate the functionality each
feature that you're trying to do have
its own screen so don't try to create
the monster screen with 50 different
check marks and different menus that you
can pick from separate the tasks and put
each task into its own view
and now you need to imitate and say
look at the favorite apps that you
already use and know and you admire and
just copy their design their their plan
so
some people say that user interface
is like a joke
what does that mean
it means if you have to explain it
you probably did it wrong
so i pulled up some examples of people
who are designing user interfaces so
there's two things going on here first
of all the user interface is each screen
that is going to be in the app and the
second part maybe we're getting a little
ahead of ourselves but it's closely
related is how they relate to each other
so that's the user experience the
navigation essentially and so what you
want to do then is before you write code
just draw pictures so you can do it as
this was a pen and paper obviously not
too sophisticated or you can get other
tools that are actually nice to draw
with and look like professional graphics
here's another example of an app that's
going to be a diet app for your pet
and so the the the motive for the app is
that healthy food is best provided to
your pet by creating your own food in
the kitchen and so this app will help
you create recipes share them and
be able to
improve the health of your pet so
every screen here represents a different
task that's going to be done in the app
and then of course we can see the
navigation between them
here's another example of a project that
somebody's working on this is called the
time bank app and so it's a time
management so you can literally budget
amount of time that you plan to do on
each task and for each calendar day
and you can borrow time from the bank
and then when you run out of time you
stop working on that task and go to
another one so i don't know if i would
use this app myself but it's certainly a
novel idea and for some people this
might be just what they need but the
point here i'm showing you is that this
person has thought about
each task that the user plans to do and
they've drawn it out in a very nice
pencil and paper format and then shown
the navigation between them
and so you can see the link here it's
from flickr and you can find out if this
process is going to work for you so let
me recommend you a resource i like the
title of the book it's probably just
worth that in itself don't make me think
and the idea is that user interface is
supposed to be obvious and so what are
some of the things that steve would
recommend that you would do to make a
user app so extra credit reading for you
go check it out so along the lines of
creating a good mobile experience think
about the thumb
so as you design your screens
the top left corner of the screen is
hard to reach with a right-handed person
for sure
and how in the world are you going to
put the main navigation menu in the top
left corner if you are actually thinking
about this so
consider someone riding a bicycle and
trying to select a new podcast item
we're going to put the button
they're going to have to stop their bike
and use two hands if you put it in the
upper left corner so user interface is
about knowing who your users are and
when they're going to use your app so
fortunately google and apple the two
main mobile application companies have
not left us in the dark they've given us
some pretty straightforward advice so
check out their human interface
guidelines and so i'm going to just
scroll through here to show that they've
got very good principles outlined here
and so they're basically stealing every
lecture that i'm going to provide to you
so i'm just going to point you to them
and you can see that there is an entire
book worth of material here to figure
out how to do branding and colors and
typography and how to use icons and
navigation
so really this is the resource that you
should be looking for if you're building
a mobile app for apple so google has
done the same favor for us with their
android documentation so this is a
developer page and you can see that they
have an entire book's worth of how to
make a good android app based on the
principles of design and so you can see
that they have an entire course worth of
material here to follow so
run from me now and go to the experts at
either apple or google to see what they
have to say i can't believe i just told
somebody to stop watching my videos but
go ahead and check them out and see if
you can learn something about basic
design from the experts
so let's assume that you're not a very
good designer well you can just buy
templates that are pretty good they've
already designed many of the features
that you're probably thinking of so
find a site like this so here is a
design template for somebody who has a
book app
and so you can see that there are
screens to show you individual books and
how to browse for books what else do
they have let's scroll down until we get
to the next one so if you're into a
cooking application so recipes likely
we've got ourselves an entire ui layout
for most of the screens that you can
imagine for cooking
education so 19 screens here you get the
idea so each different type of app that
you're going to see
is got a template so it's probably worth
spending some money here or somewhere
else where you can buy a full template
and user design already designed for you
and all you have to do is adapt it to
the specific details of your app so
taking the time or investment to create
a good user interface will help you in
several ways first of all think about
who you're designing for number one
you have a good idea for yourself of
what the final product will look like
and not only you but potential investors
and partners are going to have a
concrete image in their mind of what
your app is
also if you hire a developer then and
they have a great user interface to
start with they're not going to have to
make any decisions or inventions that is
not in their area of expertise and so
developers are good at creating
something if they've already got a
pattern to follow and so investing in
user design is a great way to start the
next phase of the design process is to
talk about user experience and so check
out the next video here about the flow
and experience of a user in your app
also if you'd like to see the entire
playlist for this this course series
then check out the next link which is a
playlist of all of them so thanks for
watching and welcome to class
[Music]
hi welcome to the business of building
applications in this course we're
exploring the business process of design
and developing an application in a
mobile field so as you can see we're in
several different chapters of a course
so we're in section two right now which
is about designing an application
however there are other sections that
we're going to explore in other videos
so if you haven't subscribed please do
that now and then you can join us for
all of this material if this interests
you my name is shad slooter and i'm a
professor of software development and
computer science at grand canyon
university and so if you're in my course
welcome and if you're not and you're
just looking along then please join us
and receive a degree that will actually
get you a really good career so in this
section we're talking about application
design and really there are four parts
to app design we're going to first of
all or we did already talk about which
features that are essential in making a
successful app the user interface is
about what the app looks like in this
video we're going to talk about the
experience that a user has
as he or she is going through the flow
and the execution of your application we
want to make sure that that is good
because that's essential for retaining
users and making apps addictive and then
finally we're going to talk about the
principles of mvp which is the minimal
viable product that you would present to
investors and to potential users it's
kind of the version
1.0 or the beta version of your app that
makes you either confirm or deny that
your app will actually work so we're in
the section called user experience or
sometimes called ux
so how is this different from the user
interface well really the user
experience is the is the overlap of
several different things first of all
the design which is what most people
think of as the user interface
the the technology that is there so
what are the actual
interfaces whether it's a tablet phone
web page virtual reality or the third
one is the strategy so what are you
trying to accomplish and does the user
actually meet those goals and so that is
perhaps what we would consider the
experience of the user so for us we
would consider it that's a five star or
a one star experience it has far more to
do than the colors and fonts or the
layout that you choose it's the whole
process of your application so let's
revisit a cycle that we talked about in
the previous video so as your user is
going through these four sections they
are going to experience your application
or the ux so first of all the
application starts somewhere so how do
users find you and then how do they get
on board how do they begin the process
of becoming a registered user and active
in your in your app
then the retention part is the addictive
or the interesting or the engaging part
of your application that keeps them
coming back do you have something worth
doing in other words in the retention
stage and then finally referral do they
invite friends do they have actions with
other users is there a way that hooks
new people to come in and repeat the
cycle and of course then your audience
grows
and finally somewhere in this process
you have to figure out how to monetize
your app without annoying everybody so
too many ads of course will ruin the
user experience too high of a price and
people might not even get in the front
door and so there's a balance of where
the successful companies have learned to
use
experience and monetization at the same
time and they of course have a great
program
now here is a previous uh user layout
that we showed in the last video
on the user interface
so user interface are the actual views
each screen could be considered an
interface however the process of linking
these together and the logic flow of the
program is just as important as how
clearly they're drawing
now the time bank here app is to
have somebody organize their time so
that they can decide how much they're
going to spend on exercise or study or
with their family or commuting or
whatever and so it's a great way for
people to bank their time
i guess that's the the theory of this
app is that you can
budget your time and use it like you
would
money and so that's called the time bank
app so i don't know if it's a good app
or not but the process here is obviously
done well you can see how the user
experience will begin
and end and all the steps that are in
between there now what would make this
even better is that if you put it into a
process or a drawing tool like figma or
something like that and you could test
it out you could click the app you could
watch the screens transition and then
make some decisions and refinements
based on a prototype so you could think
of the user flow is the process of how
the user goes from the beginning stages
to the end let's take a look at an
example here of what might be a shopping
experience so the user opens the app
they do a search for our products they
compare several products so your user
experience might be to show a table you
know side by side comparison or a save
to cart or wish list or some way to
compare help the user figure out what
they need to do then of course add to
cart is what we want
shopping makes makes the order and then
make a frictionless way to pay it you've
probably seen that before
and then finally you receive
confirmation and hopefully the amazon
guy shows up at your door and rings the
doorbell and you're happy and so the the
confirmation process outside of the app
is just as good as the experience inside
the app so you can imagine that amazon
and people like them have spent
literally billions of dollars making
this user flow so easy and so obvious
that now i see on my phone
one click buy so i don't even have to do
the shopping checkout process make it
easy
make it fun
and then i don't even notice that i just
spent some money so let's revisit this
user flow again the experience of what's
happening so you can see that we have
the four stages of our app experience
acquisition activation retention
and referral and so there's a different
label we could put on the person at each
stage so what's happening there so our
goal then is we would think about what's
in what's happening and who the user is
is our goal is to make it easy for this
to happen we want the user to install
the app the next thing is we want it
easy and obvious to register an account
which is why so many people just use the
google login or the facebook login no
one likes to type in passwords and
confirm their password retention is a
really engaging or entertaining or
something that is very useful something
that serves the need
and so we don't want to confuse or annoy
our users in this stage it's the core of
our application and then our goal here
is for people to invite a friend and so
don't just say invite a friend
maybe invite them to play the game with
you or invite them to share in a
experience or to share a photo
or somehow
cooperate and so you want to make it
natural in each of these stages and so
that's the idea and the thinking of user
experience is you want to reach the goal
in each of these stages without sounding
contrived or
overwhelming or annoying in any way you
want to make it the natural thing that
the user wants to do and then of course
if you're successful with all of these
what's going to happen is the cycle will
continue and you'll have a virtuous
cycle of new customers coming in by word
of mouth
now the conversion rate is something
that you would want to keep track of so
once you have an app up and running
you're going to think about
what is happening at each of these
stages and of course you're going to
lose a few people along the way and what
you want to do then is find out where
the choke points are where are people
dropping out of this experience and
that's where you need to focus and
refine what you're working on so are
people dropping out when they get to the
checkout
what's going on are you
having them create all kinds of
confirmations and credit card entries or
is that process smoothed out and
automated and so you're only you are
going to be able to figure out where
those problem points are if you've got
data on how your users are acting
now expand your idea more than just
about your app because the user journey
begins before the app happens so they
get an invite or they have some kind of
a notice or they found you in the app
store and so you want to make sure that
that's a good experience the in-app
experience is how smoothly it runs
during navigation ordering or posting
and then finally when you are done does
your app provide
just entertainment while they're in the
app or are they going to receive a pizza
when they're done or what's the goal of
your service
and so probably thinking about the
beginning and the ending and not just
what they're doing inside the app is
going to help you as well
so a good exercise to make this
successful is to create what's called a
user empathy map
so you would identify your user and try
to predict and live in their shoes
what does your user say
what does your user do
what is he or she thinking
and how do they feel about the
experience at each stage so let's take
an example here of somebody that's
ordering a new item from a restaurant
what do they say well obviously they
said i want to order food or maybe they
said i'm hungry or i don't want to cook
tonight and then what do they do they
open up the app they browse the menu and
they do comparisons so you can watch
what they're doing you can see how well
that's working but you can also say
i can try to imagine what the user is
thinking what are some of the important
items
well they might say when's it going to
arrive is this expensive will this food
taste good is it going to be cold stale
soggy
are there people going to be rude and so
you can imagine that there's all kinds
of questions that would be in that
person's mind and how are they feeling
who are you dealing with well you're
probably dealing with hangry customers
people that want to order food and get
it now are going to be impatient or they
might be excited they're going to say oh
good chinese food tonight i haven't had
that for a while and it tastes so good
and so
this experience is far more than just
coding and user interface
this is about how users
feel about your program
and so the only way you can really know
this is to talk to your users watch them
observe them measure them
and get lots of feedback and so the user
empathy grid will make your user
experience far more successful than if
you just assume a lot of these things so
qualitative user experiences are going
to be things like this
watch what they do so literally you
could put them in a lab situation or
give them the phone and just observe
quietly did they complete the action
without any questions did they get
frustrated did they have to ask for help
did the user do the correct answer did
they did they or thought they were doing
something but a menu led them down a
false path did the user misunderstand
something was the menu not clear or was
it hidden did they even not know that it
was a menu or was the icon just a
mystery to them maybe they didn't know
it was an icon and so all of these
things that seem you that seem obvious
to you as the developer are going to be
measured did they have to try multiple
times before they finally got it right
if they if the answer to any of these
questions comes out wrong
then
you either have to fix the app or just
assume that a great deal of your
customers will never come back and so
user experience requires you to watch
and observe and so here's a piece of
advice that seems a little
counterintuitive at first but it says
don't listen to what users say
observe what they do instead and so the
idea is to observe carefully and watch
to see if there are problems
so if you were to talk about a range of
positive to negative user experience you
could put it on this pyramid here so at
the very bottom of the pyramid we would
say
the application is useful in the fact
that it does what it says it works okay
so that's the minimum user experience we
would want it functions
then the second one up is probably just
as important obviously it says you need
to be reliable so reliable means not
just that it won't crash but also it's
reliable in the fact that it's
consistent so one place where you would
put
a command is going to follow through for
the rest of the application or you do a
process that is repeated in similar ways
also in convenience is this a natural
and obvious and efficient way to do
things
so i know in certain applications that i
use if i want to do minor things that
require 15 clicks with a mouse i get
angry i get annoyed it's like who
designed this who used this obviously
they never tested it out
is your experience pleasant okay so
that's getting pretty high now where
people say i actually like to use my app
it's attractive it looks nice i get a
good feeling when i open it and then at
the very top i guess we would call it
meaningful means that overall it's a
very positive impression i enjoy using
the app and i will be back and so your
ux is trying to course to meet the top
end of this so in order to achieve the
goals of this
meaningful and pleasant experience let's
talk about six principles that will help
you whenever you're talking about making
a positive user experience make it
minimal
find your way to do it without a lot of
extra trim
so remember the experience of the
contrast between yahoo and google
google is minimal
how about intuitive groupings and so we
think about the way you menu you can you
organize your menus and your dialog
boxes
and the clusters of
things that belong together logically
fit together
it flows naturally so you don't have to
tell your users to figure out what to
click next there's an obvious button or
there's a process of sliding or
or clicking that's that's going to be
exactly what they expect make sure that
the icons are obvious
invent only new icons when there's
doesn't exist one already so just use
the standard icons that most
applications use
make efficient motions
so in a mobile application think of your
right thumb
as the place that's going to do most of
the work or if you're working on an
application that covers an entire screen
make sure that you don't have too many
clicks or you don't have to move around
too much
now finally
above all probably is consistency
throughout
if you pick a plan stick with that plan
so you don't have to surprise users or
confuse users from one part of your
application
to another now the next step in building
this project is called the mvp or the
minimal viable product so check out the
video here that will give some
principles on designing an mvp also if
you want to see the entire playlist for
this course uh click here and you will
see a class list of mini videos so
thanks for watching and please subscribe
[Music]
hi and welcome back to the business of
building applications this is a mobile
app course for people who are interested
in the business of design and running a
service so there are several options and
several chapters that we're studying so
we talked about the motivations and now
we're in part two which is about
designing an mvp or a minimal viable
product there are other considerations
ahead of us so if you would like to
subscribe you can see these as they come
out if this is interesting to you my
name is chad slooter and i am a
professor of software development and
computer science at grand canyon
university so please join us in class if
this works for you
now what we're going to talk today about
is application design in part four down
here at the bottom we're focusing on
mvp which is the minimal
viable product we've already asked about
which features we should include in here
what the user interface is like and how
to make a good user experience so now
what we're trying to do is come up with
version 1.0 of our product that we can
use to test out with users and show to
investors so that's called our mvp so
it's certainly not the most valuable
player like you would see in sports but
the minimal viable product so this term
isn't my invention of course it comes
from a book called the lean startup and
so you can see that it's a new york
times best seller and a common basic
idea in entrepreneur circles so the term
is defined like this an mvp is the
product that in the shortest time
can create value for one or more users
on a continuous basis so some people
have the idea that the mvp is like
super basic and ugly and barely works
and others are saying no it's more of a
fully functional product that we can
test out and so there's a range of ideas
of what people think is mvp so what i
want to do is to show you some advice
and some principles that will lead you
to a successful mvp
and make your business work
so we've all got a list of features that
we want to put into our app
and we need to prioritize them so the
mvp are the core essential things that
make our app work
the future ideas we're going to call
that version 1.1 maybe or two or three
but we're going to leave those for later
after we've proven that our business
concept is successful we're going to see
if users actually like what we made and
if the investors can go along with us
and so the mvp is just to get us started
it's not really the full vision yet
so we've gone from prototype which is
kind of like the drawings and the
wireframes maybe something that you can
actually work with like with a clickable
interface
mvp is like somewhere in the middle and
then a real product is still ahead of us
so we're in the intermediate stages now
so think mvp has limited goals and
very close attention to how much it
costs now mvp can be considered like an
incremental process or it can be
considered an evolutionary process so
the first one as far as incremental is
not an mvp so if you were to build a
truck
it is not the process of building wheels
then frame and then a body and then
assembling it because you really can't
use the wheel by itself now if you were
to talk about mvp you're going to say
we're going to build a transportation
device that's going to carry cargo well
the first requirement is that our
transportation device actually moves and
can carry something it doesn't go very
fast and it doesn't carry very much and
the bicycle is a slight improvement on
that it goes a little bit faster and of
course the motorcycle goes fast but
doesn't carry much the idea is that we
have a functional product at each st
each point of the the stage of
development and so completely different
than just building from the ground up
and building foundation first and then
building out from there
so how much does it cost to develop a
scooter
not very much how much does it cost to
build an entire truck obviously quite a
bit
so our investment risk in the scooter
stage is quite low and that's the whole
point
so if you were to build a service that
does automated coffee production
you would consider an mvp like this
we want to know if the users like the
idea of walking up to a machine putting
a quarter in and getting a cup of coffee
do people actually want that
well you could invent a robot to do it
for you and that would cost a lot of
money but if all you're interested in is
testing out the concept then literally
you put a guy behind the cardboard he
makes the coffee and hands it through
the hole
do people like that
and you really don't know if they how
well they like it until you test it out
so
it's a physical a demonstration of what
an mvp looks like so if people are
having to place orders with you and you
manually configure them and fulfill them
that's fine now a good example of this
process being manual is from the company
zappos so in a previous video i told you
they ran an experiment to see if people
would order shoes online so that was a
good question so instead of building an
entire warehouse and then running a
business to answer that question they
simply put up a website that sold shoes
if somebody ordered a pair of shoes they
would take that email and it would go to
the store
and they would buy a pair of shoes from
the retailer and then they would put in
a box and mail it to the customer now
obviously they had no markup there was
expenses in doing all of that and
postage so they were losing money in the
process but they were able to answer the
question is our minimal viable idea
really viable will people buy shoes
online and of course the answer turned
out to be yes and so they turned into a
big investment
and eventually were purchased by amazon
and you can buy zappos online today
now the idea of trying to build
a mvp
relates directly to the user experience
so we want to get our mvp to the top of
the pyramid
but not have a great amount of money
invested
so here is a way to do it wrong this is
terrible okay so terrible is to say i'm
going to take the strategy where i'm
only going to build the easiest features
not the most important ones and so we
have a broad
part at the bottom of the pyramid that
says we have lots of useful things that
we can do in our mvp
the experience is bad but at least it
works so we don't want to do that so how
can we get better than terrible
well we could get to the level that
we'll call
bad that's not terrible so what is bad
well bad says we'll take a slice and
we'll get a little ways up the pyramid
so we'll have maybe one or two features
they work
but we don't really have that experience
of
what the end goal is yet
so we can provide some value so we want
to do better than that so let's go up
one more so from bad we'll go to good
so good says we're going to take a
narrow slice
so we'll have maybe one feature
that feature is both reliable it's
convenient and it's very pleasant and
the experience will be good for that one
thing
so
the answer to the question is which
features capture the most value for the
customer and so it doesn't do much but
it does one thing very well
now we can even do better than one step
above this we go from good to best
so best is we'll just skew the
development a little bit
so that maybe we'll have not two
features but one feature
that one feature is very good it looks
nice the user experience was thought out
and a user can use the product so
they would like to have more features of
course but the answer to the question is
which features best demonstrate the
value of my product and we make sure
that that experience looks really really
good
and so we want to make sure that we can
answer that question that's the point of
an mvp
so let's put it into writing here so the
mvp answers the burning question
is
how will users receive your product
this is really a mystery until they
actually have in their hands and they
can test it out so do they yawn at your
product if they say this is really
nothing special or is boring
then you fail fast and you might just
decide at this point
not worth it
the investors flee we abandoned the idea
bad idea nobody likes it or we could say
that the users come back with a mixed
kind of a review they say it's a nice
app but i would prefer it if it were
slightly different if so then we know we
have a roadmap for version 2.0
or if we hit it right and we have a
great experience and the users are
excited then we roll and we can start
adding development advertising the thing
marketing and new features are in the
future so implicit in this discussion is
the idea of keeping the costs low so
your mvp
has a a relationship to its cost based
on the number of features you put in
so keep that slice
small
one good feature
and the cost of development is lower so
instead of spending a hundred dollars an
hour for your developers for each
developer to create features that are
really not critical
then keep those out
so there's an inverse also a
relationship to the amount of acceptance
and understanding that your users are
giving you so they have a limited
bandwidth of what they can give you for
feedback
so
fewer features
means you get the right feedback from
your users
so their understanding of what your app
does is better
when there's not as many choices
so lower cost
and more accurate feedback on the
burning question
so really the question is
what features should be in our mvp
answer that with three questions
does the user need it
how simple is it to develop
and does it provide value to the company
and of course we want those answers to
be positive
and then we know which features are in
the mvp
now does the user need it that's our
first question
obviously you have the core idea so
don't try to chase down things that are
nice to haves so then the next question
is what does it cost to develop
so not only do you have to calculate the
cost of your computers and the time that
you pay for your developers but you
think of the opportunity cost you want
to get this business started and so if
you
don't answer the question right then
you're probably going to be losing in on
opportunities that you could be working
on now the last question is does it
provide value to the business
so the first value you can think of is
revenue
so one luxury you do have is that you
can postpone the development of the
revenue part until later because the
goal is to find out if users like it
and then get it get them hooked on it
and so don't annoy them with your ads
just see the if they like the feature
first
now double check when you get to this
point in your development and you have
an mvp you've presented it to users and
they've given you feedback
ask yourself
am i developing anything that is truly
unique
this is a double check do my users see
it as a differentiated product
do i think that it's going to be an
improvement
where are we going with this that's the
double check point
now also keep track of your backlog
because everyone's got these features
that they are anxious to put in
we know that we're going to promise the
people that they're going to be there
and that's what your backlog does so
version two is going to have numbers uh
four five and six and version three is
going to have all the great things in
the future but we're not going to invest
money in those until we know that
features number one two and three are
the ones that users will actually adopt
and so it allows the users
to see the future
and the developers can build something
that they can
adapt and extend
and plan for in other versions
so now you got your mvp in place you've
tested it with a few users and you can
answer the question truthfully now is
this a good idea
not only do i think it's a good idea but
do other people like it and will it sell
and so that is really the one goal that
you have for an mvp is to test your idea
and see if it's going to launch
now in the next video we're going to
talk about monetizing and marketing your
app how do you get people to adopt it
and use it and how can you pay for it if
you'd like to see that click the video
that's up here on the screen also i have
the link to the entire playlist so you
can see all of the subjects of the
business of building applications thanks
for watching and please subscribe
[Music]
hi and welcome to the business of
building applications this is a video
that will give you some ideas of how to
complete an assignment if you were one
of my students we're in part two of an
of eight chapters of a course and this
is about designing an effective app and
so this video here is going to give you
some details on an assignment if you
were in my in my class at grand canyon
university this is what i expect of you
if you're not in my class then you're
feel free to do the assignment but
you'll probably have to just put your
things in the comments below so what i
want you to do in this assignment is to
look at some design examples and so when
i say design examples i'm talking about
app design this is going to look at some
people that really did a great job on
how they would build an app
so
we're going to take a look at some
people that know what they're doing
and we're going to evaluate how well
they've covered the basis and what we
can learn from them so i'm going to show
you three case studies three design
projects that are posted online that we
can look at and number one is about an
app that would do pet food recipes and
so this uh website that we're looking at
for these examples is called uxdesign.cc
and so the first one i want you to pick
out is this one here called a
step-by-step guide
to the process of designing a pet diet
app and so this is their first page i'll
provide the link to this below
so this here is the it doesn't exist
this app doesn't exist this here is the
the layout this is the sketch this is
the the prototype for the app so you can
see that when you look at this web page
you're going to see that they started
with this process of sketching out with
literally a pencil and paper
the wire frames what the app's going to
look like and then you can see
navigation links between it
then the wireframes are a little bit
nicer than just the sketch it's done
with a drawing program
and so it's a little bit easier to read
and then
this user created an inspiration board
so they went to look at other apps that
were similar to get uh
probably graphics and uh color schemes
and what they did for the the look and
feel
and then here is a nice uh design
process so i don't know if you do this
or not but
iterations so you're going to design
something and you don't take the rough
draft and just start implementing it you
create three or more things to look at
so that way you can compare them and
judge
based on what you've
what you looked at from a distance or
you can provide it to other users and
get their feedback and pick the one that
people seem to gravitate toward so
anyway in this case study you can see
that the green one was
selected by the user to say i think i
did the best job on this one
so when you look at these three
which one would you pick i'm not sure if
i agree is three the best
it's kind of a personal preference
and then when they're done here they
have this
fully formed
graphical user interface they can see
the whole app
number two that i'm going to ask you to
look at is a food ordering app so once
again i'm going to take you back to the
same website which is the ux collective
and in this case
the student created an app for ordering
mobile
mobile meals
and so
the steps here involved maybe a few
other things
notice that they used what they called a
user persona so these are fake people
but these people are
representative of the ideal customer
and so
you can see that they have certain
targets that means their preferences
where they hang out online
a little biography about who they are
where they work and how old they are
what they like what frustrates them and
so
these are the ideal targets for this
application so that's called a persona
that's actually a terminology that you
should start using the persona the
target person for my app
then we're going to have a process here
so this person not only thought about
the user interface
but they are considering the user
experience so the user experience is how
does the app work and how does the
entire business work with the app what's
the user going to experience from the
moment they open the app to the moment
they pay for it or get their product and
so ux then the wireframes come next just
like the previous example and you can
see that they're designing uh very
detailed plans for what the app's going
to look like and then
they organized it so
more ideas from other users and more
other apps and then finally you get to
this this is a nice clean
photo ready app that doesn't work yet
it's just a user interface
but you could provide this to your ideal
customer or to your boss
and have a very good plan on what you're
going to be building
so the third case that i want you to
look at is this number three called the
fitness app so this fitness app is a ux
case study again so fitter me is the
name it doesn't exist in an app form as
far as i know but it does give you a
pretty good idea of where they want to
go
so
this case study has a competitive
analysis
so the competitive analysis will tell
you who's out there already so obviously
strava is like a huge market leader
why are we building an app that replaces
strava i'm not sure but the competitive
analysis is supposed to tell us
why
maybe there's some weakness or some
specialty that we can exploit so who's
the target so we've got this pretty
broad range we've got some segments of
people who are going to be likely users
of the app
we have some interview questions so this
is a great way to
find out what is really happening in the
minds of your potential users is
remember in the previous activity and
the assignment that i asked you to do
was to go and talk to your friends and
family and present your idea of your app
and then get feedback so this is exactly
what this person did here with the
interview questions so why would you
want to use my app what would you change
if you could modify it and how much
would you pay for it how much how how
likely on a scale of one to ten are you
going to use this app once it's released
and so remember this market research
will save you hundreds of hours and
maybe lots of money because
if you find that nobody cares about your
app then
don't even bother advancing beyond
so next this user created a persona and
empathy map so the empathy map is asking
yourself what does this person think
what do they experience
so
how do they
find the process of
exercising right now is it frustrating
to them are they inspired or
you try to have empathy for them not
just in
you know being a psychologist that
listens well but an empathy in
understanding what makes them tick
then we get into the wireframes and the
connections between them so the site
navigation so they've got a pretty good
idea what their app's going to look like
now what i want you to do is after you
looked at these three in more detail
than what i just showed you i want you
to write about what you learned
so question number one
i want you to notice a couple of things
that these case studies followed a very
common format there are certain
ingredients in each case study and each
design
that they all addressed so what are the
common sections of a user design
document
then the second is
some of these you might rate as more
complete or more compelling than others
so which of these three
do you provide or do you think what
provides the best idea
and the best guidance
for an app developer to follow so if you
were their boss
which one would you promote and which
one would you send back for a second try
then the next question is that most apps
in the stores
hardly get any downloads at all
clearly there's an app for every need
but there's not a need for
every app
so based on the
business ideas that are here
which of these three do you think has
any kind of a chance of attracting a
crowd
so are there success in their future or
not
so explain your answer so what i'm
asking you to do is not to design your
own app this time but take a look at
other people's work
and see if you can see success or
failure in their future
so now let's move on to the second part
of our observations
so
let's talk about freelance work so
freelance app developers sometimes
browse
websites like upwork or freelancer.com
looking for jobs to bid on
so if you were
seeing these
three apps that were up for
development
are there any one of them that you would
be interested in
bidding on assuming you were going to be
paid several thousand dollars you were
going to be paid well for your time
which one of these apps would merit your
time
and then explain why you would apply for
one over the other
so you might have personal reasons such
as it's interesting to you or you think
that this
person has their act together and
probably
has a clear vision or what's what's your
reasoning so which of the three would
you apply for if you were a freelancer
and then
think about your own app now
so
since you might not be a designer a
professional designer
you're probably going to imitate those
that are
so using these three case studies you're
probably going to look at your own idea
and follow the same format good for you
because these are done in great formats
so these case studies are meant to be
imitated
so which of these three do you think
makes the best model
for you to imitate
in designing your own app successfully
so explain to me what you liked about it
and why you would follow their pattern
finally let's talk about the
deliverables
in this assignment if you were in my
class i would expect a one-page word
document and i would expect you to
compare the app design case studies did
i say four i think i only showed you
three if you're not in my class then go
ahead and write the comments below in
the youtube comments section about which
of these three cases you thought were
the strongest
and why you believe they are i'm going
to provide the link to the entire course
so if you'd like to see the playlist for
the business of app design
please join me there also don't forget
to subscribe if this content is
interesting to you thank you and we'll
see you next time
[Music]
hi and welcome to the business of
building applications this is a course
where you're learning how to create apps
as a business manager so we're in part
two which is chapters on designing an
effective app and in this video i'm
going to give you an assignment we'll
call this activity 2.2
and the goal here is that we are going
to try to develop what's called
user stories so when you're designing an
app you have to figure out what your
users want to do
and so the background here is that our
user stories are a prioritization of all
of the features in our app
so it's a natural language description
of every feature such as as a user i
would like to log in so that i can have
access to the application that's a user
story tells me who and what they want to
do so a user story is a short statement
that is written from the perspective of
the user so for instance you might say
as a role i want to do something so that
i can so for instance i might say as a
manager that's the role i want to
see a sales report to be sent to my
inbox every day so that i can track the
success or failure of my team and so
that tells you a feature of the app that
you want to build so your app might not
have any of the features that look like
that at all but that's an example of
what a user story looks like
now once you've got a bunch of user
stories it's nice to put them into
categories and so
probably a
sensible way to do this when you put it
onto some kind of a sticky note or a
virtual sticky note and then you and
your team would get together to say
which ones are these are the best ones
which ones are we going to leave till
the future so you can prioritize what
things you need to do right away
so what you would probably think of is
essential mvp features first so mvp
stands for minimal viable product we'll
get to that later but the minimal viable
product is the first version of your app
it's probably not very scalable
and it might not be perfect but it's
certainly going to tell us
what the app can do and you can provide
experiences to the actual users and they
can give you feedback on it
so for instance in a previous activity
we looked at a case study of a user for
a pet recipe app and so i put a feature
in here that might have been in that pet
recipe app that says here
as a user i want to search for recipes
to them for my pet so that i can find
something appropriate for his medical
conditions okay
and the reason why we would put that as
a high priority is because in our
interviews with our test users our
personas
we found that this was the most common
request from our user surveys
so we would be able to identify what it
is and give it a priority number two
they may have said here's another
feature of the app as a user i want to
read instructions so that i can prepare
a recipe
was also common from our users
and we would also categorize it as
essential to the core operation of the
app that's really what our app does
that's the main activity
how about the third one let's examine
that one too it says as a user i want to
read about the ingredients that are in
each recipe so that i can know what the
health benefits are associated with the
recipe this is essential
it's a common request
but for the app to actually work then
the users
don't really need that to see what the
app looks like we could put in some
dummy data here and just say hey if if
this app were finished then you would be
able to see
the contents of your meal so we gave it
a priority of one
well it eventually it'll hit the app but
for right now it's not going to hurt hit
version number one
so here's some future version priority
so we've pushed these away and said
maybe someday
so for instance i want as a user i want
to create a shopping list for the
ingredients based on my favorite recipes
so we said we're going to put this in
version 2.0
because of the complexity of the
development sounds like we're going to
take some more time
it's also essential to the revenue model
of this app because
we're planning on monetizing the app by
taking a cut out of every item that is
ordered from amazon
so if we don't include this feature we
won't make any money so that's why it's
essential
but remember in the first version of the
app we don't have to make money the
first version of the app we just have to
prove that people like the app
so we'll leave that as a future version
number two i want to fulfill the
ingredients on amazon and the order yep
i mentioned one same thing here we're
going to take a percentage of the sales
and then number three or the third item
here it says i want to track my pet's
weight
so maybe that's great but according to
the survey
we asked our people if they ever wanted
to weigh their pets and and most people
said no so
we thought it was a good idea we put it
on the on the list of things but our
users told us otherwise so that's maybe
an example of how you would prioritize
user stories so based on what you can do
and what your users want you to do
so what i want you to do then in this
assignment is to create a table
so write all the user stories that you
can think of that your app will do
all of the features and you write them
in that i as a user kind of format
and then put them in a chart to say
which ones are nice to have which ones
are going to be pushed off to future
versions so it's really just a table
with a bunch of sticky notes so that's
your deliverable i want you to create a
word document with a list of
minimal viable product features
and then also put them in the future or
the present categories if you were one
of my students i would grade you based
on the completeness of what the app
looks like
and how much thought that you can
justify for each decision
if you're not in my class then feel free
to do this on your own as you're
designing your own applications i'll put
the link to the course playlist here so
that you can go back and see some of the
teachings that are going to help you in
making this assignment come true so if
this is good for you then please make
sure you subscribe for the channel and i
will see you next time in class
[Music]
hi and welcome to the business of
building applications this is a course
for people who are not only programmers
but also business thinkers we're in
chapter two of the course right now
which is called designing an effective
app and i'm going to give you an
assignment so we'll call this assignment
2.3
and in this assignment what we're going
to create are interactive user
interfaces okay so in other words we're
going to create a small prototype a demo
of an app so the background is that i
want you to create something that is
functional and something that you can
put into the hands of your users to test
out and maybe you for the first person
will be the the first person to test it
so what this demo will do is will
clarify in your own mind how the app
will work you will find that there are
some gaps in your logic or design and
this will become painfully evident by
how it works so you can show it to your
potential users and business partners to
see if you're on the right track so to
do this demo we're going to use a
program called figma so figma is free
and so what i want you to do is to go
log in at figma.com
and get an account so that you can
design an app you can see in the
background here that i started designing
a mobile app and it's got two pages on
it right now so figma is pretty cool
i want you to look at the tutorial pages
to see how it works but it's so simple
if you've worked with any kind of
word or publisher or any kind of a page
layout document you'll probably
understand that you can drag shapes and
resize them but then the cool part is
you can click the play button and you
can actually go through the app and see
what the navigation looks like
so here are the instructions that i want
you to follow for sign up for an account
at figma and then create a set of
wireframes so that's the
drawings of your screen
and these will each represent one of the
actions in your app
so the actions are your user stories and
then connect them so that way we can see
the navigation links between each
then run the app and test it out make
sure that you haven't forgotten anything
and that it works like you expect and
then for you to submit it to me is to be
graded i want you to do a demo and
record the screen so you can record it
with something like quicktime
or if you use loom.com you can record
your screen and have an a narration that
goes along with it so the deliverables
if you were one of my students i would
ask you to submit a word document with
wireframe drawings and in that word
document you would have a link to say
hey this is the video this is how i
demonstrated my app and the prototype
works and i'll show you all the features
in it
so if you're doing this without being
one of my students go ahead and provide
links in the comments below so that
other people can see what you've
designed and maybe you can get some
feedback from them so thanks for
watching i'm going to put a playlist
link so that way you can check out all
of the other items of this course make
sure you subscribe if this is
information that is valuable to you and
we will see you in the next class
[Music]
hi welcome to this course here on the
business of building applications we're
in a section right now called the
business plan so if you've been
following me along you can see that we
have several ideas about how to make a
successful business app and so we're on
part three right now which is about the
business plans including marketing and
monetization however you can see that
there are other chapters in this course
that we're going to cover and so if you
haven't subscribed yet do that now my
name is chad slooter and i teach
software development at grand canyon
university including mobile development
and so welcome to class now let's take a
look here at what we're going to talk
about in the next few videos so we're on
the app business plan cycle which i'm
going to just put into four different
categories we're going to talk in this
section about your main business plan
and we'll put it in a format called the
business model canvas we'll talk about
ways to monetize your app ways to market
and get new users and talk about your
relationship with investors if you're
going that route and so this is four
videos about the business plan of your
app so now if you're interested in the
business plan obviously you intend to
make your app into a service or a
product that people are willing to pay
for
so the plan that we're going to look at
right now is called the business
canvas model so unfortunately i can't
take credit for the plan or the
organization of this model here so this
comes from a book here called the value
proposition design which is a really
interesting book you should check it out
it's like a picture book with all kinds
of ways to graphically show your
strategies of how to make a business and
so this is by alex osterwalder and you
can see some of his uh
people that worked along with him so
we're going to take a look at nine
business issues that he identifies that
you must clarify so who are your
partners what do you do for your
customers what resources do you have
what value do you provide
why do your customers love you what
channels do you use to either gain
customers or deliver your services and
products who is your customer and the
profile what cost will you incur and
what streams of revenue will you support
your business with so let's talk about
these individually now for some reason
we can't just put these into nine
different questions we have to organize
them into this plan this board and so it
makes you look smarter when you have a
way to organize your things on a board
perhaps i don't know maybe it makes it
easier to remember but
anyway we're going to follow the plan
here this board so the key partners is
the first question who are your business
partners who are your associates who do
you need to survive and the
relationships with them what activities
do you do what is the core service that
your customers look for you to provide
then we have key resources now these
resources can be things that you possess
or things that you must pay for or
obtain
and so this would refer to either the p
the human
capital that you have or the data that
you collect or
any kind of product that you're able to
manufacture so
value propositions are about your
customers and why they think you are
worth the money so do you make their
life easy do you provide entertainment
do you provide a service that they can't
live without so the value proposition
means
why do people want to give you money and
so you better have a good one
a customer relationship can be the
question is
why do customers love you and why do
they keep coming back or perhaps if your
plan doesn't work so well you could do
the opposite
the channels refers to how you are going
to reach your customers or how you're
going to deliver your services and
products and so what are your channels
of distribution or your channels of
incoming customers
also your customer segments
so it's ideal to have
a profile
the exact age
the gender
the location
the hobbies the problems you have a
profile that would tell you
who
john doe is and why he is your customer
and also there might be a variety of
john does that have slightly different
attributes and so you segment your
customers to figure out which ones are
happy and which ones need improvement
also the cost structure would you have
an ongoing process that cost you money
you subscribe to things do you have to
pay people for
giving you services that you pass on to
your customers and so your cost
structure is all about salaries and
ongoing expenses
and the last one is revenue streams and
so how do you make money are people
paying for your app are you selling
advertising are you getting commissions
and so those are all questions about
revenue streams and so there you have it
we've got the whole list here and like i
said you have to put it on this board to
make it officially your business
planning board i don't know if you need
this board but i i thought about it for
a while and i realized i actually do
remember all of these questions better
when i see these icons in the in the
layout so maybe you'll you'll find the
same process
regardless these are important questions
that you must clarify if you're going to
have a successful business and of course
you're going to find that if there's a
weak link in your plan that's probably
going to require your attention and to
make the process work better so to make
this uh more concrete let's take a look
at an example application so i pulled
something out of the app store and i
think i was looking for discounted
restaurant
coupons something like groupon and i
found this app and it appears to have a
number of users i'm not even sure if
it's used useful in the united states or
not but i don't think i've ever used the
app but anyway i wanted to pick this as
an example of how a process would go to
think about
how you would fill out this a business
board so we have to have concrete
examples right
so eatago is a restaurant reservation
app which offers time-based discounts
that means probably discount of the day
of up to 50 off every day for all of its
four thousand five hundred plus
restaurants there are no prepayments or
hidden costs etigo is a 100 free at
least it is to you the user and it's
simple to use search and rejoice enjoy
so the idea here is that this is an app
but it's really an app that is a
business it's a service you probably
don't have to make the food but you do
have to provide a stream of customers to
restaurants to be successful and so
here's some screenshots of what the app
looks like you can see that you're
getting groupon like coupons and you
probably are going to be sent to
restaurants that you're not familiar
with and you're supposed to try them out
and of course the restaurant is going to
hopefully see you again and they will
become your favorite place to eat so
let's take this example
and answer some of the questions that
will go on this business planning board
so let's start over so we have this key
partners now if you were that restaurant
app itago
who are the partners
well think of those 4 500 restaurants
that are willing to
give you the discount
so those would be probably
the key partners so i put down here
restaurants maybe caterers food trucks
hotels
anyone that's willing to pay you
to bring them a new client and so your
key partnerships here you better make
sure that you're really strong with
these people
and
you are on good terms if these things go
sour your whole business plan will fail
and so that's why they're called key
partners the second is what activities
do you do so if you had to give the
elevator pitch about this app you say hi
i am shad i have this app called eatago
and it
what would you say put it in one
sentence think about it
well here's what i put so if you want to
see my answer i said we match people
with places to eat
now there's uh there are other parts
about discounts and things like that but
that's pretty much it
what are the key resources what do you
have to have or obtain
to make this thing work what makes your
app valuable sometimes this is called
the moat
around your castle this is what prevents
competitors from moving in and taking
over your business you have a protective
ring so what resources do you have that
other people don't
well you can probably say i have a lot
of users hopefully you do
it's probably the most difficult thing
of making this app work properly is that
you need to have a critical mass
once you have some people
i think that perhaps the data is
considered a key resource
you have a user list
with knowledge of their preferences and
habits
so you obviously don't want to share
that that would be a key resource
think of your employees if you've got
somebody that's out selling your product
if you're trying to get new restaurants
into your
fold and into your collection
then your key resources would be the
contacts the sales people that are
trying to get new restaurants to
participate
and so those are some things that i
would say are key resources for this
example
what is the value proposition
so think of it
what what do people get when they use
your app
well i can see two value propositions
one for the restaurant
and one for the users or the clients for
me as a client that's how i see it why
would i download this app well i get
free food or i get cheap food and i get
to try something cool maybe a new
restaurant i haven't seen before
and then the restaurants what do they
get well they get a stream of new
customers so i would say the value
proposition here goes two ways for this
app we get a cheap meal
and the restaurants get a stream of new
customers now groupon some time ago was
a hot item it seemed like everybody
wanted to use groupon everyone was
trying to
get new customers in through groupon
and i think it's cooled off quite a bit
it was a it was an expensive proposition
for the re retailers for the people that
were giving away their services
because they would get customers in the
door
one time and they never came back and i
think that the value proposition was
rather low but anyway here's another
example of a app that's trying to do the
same thing as groupon maybe they're more
successful so your restaurants have to
have some kind of a
a payoff in the long term
of course you give them the the first
impression the restaurant's job is to
make it a good one
who are the customers and why do they
love you so the customer relationships
so i would say
that your way to make your customers
love you
is that every time they open the app or
they turn on their phone they get an
alert that says hey there's a new offer
you get a constant stream of good deals
and interesting places to eat
and that would make me want to open the
app and keep it installed on my phone
you can also say the key relationships
with your restaurants is that you have a
steady stream of good customers now i
think some restaurants might argue that
these are bad customers a bad customer
for a restaurant is somebody that
doesn't tip that doesn't pay
that only works with coupons i know i'm
certainly a bad customer when it comes
to restaurants i hate spending money and
so i usually look for rather inexpensive
places to eat so i would not be
one of the target
users that a restaurant would be trying
to get
here's another one what are the channels
so the channels for delivering your
product and the channels for obtaining
new clients so let's talk about this one
we would probably think about a steady
stream
of people downloading and trying our app
through social media
so if you go viral that's great where
you have recommendations from your
friends but to get to that point you're
probably going to invest a great deal of
money in acquiring new customers
so people
will probably see an ad on facebook
or maybe on tripadvisor or instagram
or maybe they're googling restaurant
names
so you're going to have to spend some
money to get their attention
and so the channel is going to be rather
expensive at first trying to get enough
people to try out your app but i would
think that those are probably good
resources for getting new people
what are the segments like i told you
earlier i probably wouldn't fit one of
these
but here here are some
segments that i would see are likely
people who travel you know you're in a
new city and you don't know where to eat
people that eat out a lot obviously
business lunches
and maybe you're trying to target
somebody that has an expense account at
work maybe maybe not
uh people that have expense accounts
probably don't worry about 50 off deals
maybe that's not a good customer segment
there's going to have to be some
research here obviously i'm guessing at
where their customer segments are
but people that eat out and like a
variety of food are likely going to be
good customer segments here
let's talk about the cost structure
where you're going to be spending money
we're probably going to be spending
money on ads you're going to have to be
able to collect new clients you're going
to have salaries if you have people
working for you
and so i'm just going to put down here
facebook and google are likely going to
be cost structure items that you are
concerned about and
any salaries that you have to pay
so
where do you make money
you're giving away uh coupons
you're probably going to have to think
about your revenue streams as coming
from the restaurants themselves
it's not likely that i'm going to be a
customer that pays to install your app
maybe maybe not i don't know costco
seems to be able to build people for
shopping at their place i don't
understand that why would you want to
pay a hundred dollars a year or whatever
from membership to go into your store
usually i think of memberships is where
i get something
value not i don't get to pay you money
but anyway maybe you have such a good
deal on the app that people are willing
to pay a subscription fee but i would
predict that the most likely way that
you're going to get this is that you're
going to take a cut
from every reference that goes in the
door of the restaurant
so either you collect fees from the
restaurants or you have a subscription
for a pro premium
model on this
and so if you look through all of these
is it nine different items
you're going to have the basic
structure
of your business plan far more than just
coding an app isn't it you have to think
about your customers and your
relationships and your costs and your
revenues so this business plan should be
challenged by yourself by your critics
by people that look at you by investors
that might want to be interested in in
starting your company might be able to
sell this to your employees as well but
you better have a clear idea of your
business plan so in the next video we're
going to talk about monetization so how
do you make money different ways that
you can get an income stream
also if you'd like to see the entire
course playlist i'll put that link here
and don't forget to subscribe if you're
interested in the business of
applications
[Music]
hi welcome to this course here on the
business of building applications in
this video we're going to talk about the
monetization that you can do and
strategies for making an app there are
other chapters in this course so if
you're interested in taking a look at
these you can also check out the
playlist that i'll put a link for so
we're on part three right now which is
on marketing and monetization however
you can see that there are other
chapters coming up so make sure you
subscribe and join us in class my name
is chad slooter and i teach computer
science and software development at
grand canyon university so come along
now let's take a look here at our app
business plans really that's the subject
here we're doing four videos right now
that refer to our problems that we're
going to have to face here so in the
previous video was out about the
business plan which is called the
business model canvas in this video
we're going to talk about monetization
say that twice and then the next one is
marketing and then following that we'll
talk about working with investors so
right now monetization there it is is
trying to figure out how you can make
money
by people paying for you on the app or
maybe showing you advertising and
there's a multitude of ways that we can
do this so let's get right into that so
first of all before we do that let's
talk about the app stores and the type
of customer that you're going to get on
each of the phones really you know
there's only two types of phones out
there there's android and ios and let's
compare them and you'll be surprised at
how much more money that goes to people
or from people that run an apple phone
so first of all revenue in the billions
this is talking about app revenue and
you can see obviously it's growing for
both companies but ios rakes in a huge
amount of cash in comparison to google
when it comes to their app stores now
this is not quite fair because this
includes china
and uh google doesn't sell apps in china
apple does
and so that's another whole story but
anyway you can see that china will be a
very big part of that market
now the second is
about the subscriptions so subscriptions
are things like
netflix or an annual fee that you would
pay for the use of an app so not just a
download but an ongoing thing and as you
know likely there is a 30 percent cut
that these stores take from you if
you're selling an app or any kind of
subscript subscription on it so if you
download netflix it'll be strange that
you cannot actually
subscribe to netflix in the app you have
to do that other website and of course
there's a good reason they don't want to
give 30 percent of their revenue to
apple or to google just for the
privilege of getting you as a customer
so you can use the netflix app but you
can't process any payments through
netflix now as i'm making this video
epic games and apple and google are all
in court fighting this out
because uh they've epic feels like this
is a very unfair model
but
you know it at the first it seemed like
a very good plan where you didn't have
to pay for boxing up your app or running
a store and selling cds
and so that was the original impetus for
30
now let's take a look here at the
markets so the countries that are
involved in the largest number of
dollars that are spent on apps or on
subscriptions
so you can see china is by far the
biggest market not too surprising since
there's over a billion people there and
they probably all have iphones the
united states of course a fairly large
country
uh japan europe and the rest of the
world i guess are the
third fourth and fifth uh people on the
list here so
think about who you're targeting
and
maybe that would impact on what kind of
an application you're trying to sell so
if you want to reach chinese people make
sure you have an apple app
if you're not interested in that then
make sure that you
target
the countries of your choice here now
also think about the value per user so
if you were to take the total revenue
that is being spent
through each type of phone and divided
by the number of users you'll get an
idea that
the ios user will spend about fifty six
dollars a year on this and the average
android person spends
some six dollars
so why is there such a vast difference
well you can probably see at the very
beginning when you filter out the cost
of the phone
people that are willing to spend a
thousand dollars on a phone probably
have more disposable income
so you probably know me as a rather
cheap person
i use android phones
and
i use an apple computer so i'm not i'm
not an apple hater
but i probably am not
a 56 dollar a year customer either
the value per app sale is also quite
dramatically different so the average
person or the average app that is sold
on ios is larger in its cost compared to
android
also take a look here this will probably
explain a big difference of the two
markets
so this table shows
the amount of market penetration for
each of these
platforms so ios
mostly is in developed countries
richer countries
and android has a dominant market share
in the developing world
not surprising since the price of the
phones are dramatically different so
let's put some graphs on the screen just
to give you a picture so as you can see
the uk is roughly 50 50.
germany
mostly android the united states is one
of those exceptions that has a great
deal of ios users canadians are about 50
50. japan is similar to the united
states with the dominance of ios
so it makes sense that japan and the
united states rather wealthy countries
china the biggest market
has a rather small section of ios
however
based on the population there's probably
just as many or more ios phones in china
that are being used as the united states
just because they are approximately four
times the population of the country on
this side of the world
also take a look at some of these at the
lower end so i'm going to pick some
large
countries that have lower or middle
income
so india perhaps
just as big as
as china as population has almost no ios
users and then if you look at
indonesia another massively populated
country you're going to see a domination
of android
and nigeria at the end is just the same
and so the the point here is that if
you're targeting wealthy countries and
wealthy phone users then it might make
sense for you to target your ios
audience first if you're
not really caring about if they pay for
your app but you're more targeted at the
actual service then of course
this is not as relevant information
let's take a look at the competition
though just one chart here that shows
an approximate this isn't any
statistical thing but
just to let you know
that if you think you're going to crack
into the top 10
your chances of becoming one of the
super apps in the time usage is probably
about as likely as you are going to
become
a movie star or an nfl quarterback so
just plan on finding a niche
and working with that and so check out
another video here i'll put a link on it
for
finding a niche and comparing your
competition so that you're not crushed
by grand ideas that are just
disappointments now let's take a look
here at uh some statistics that come
from google so i borrowed these from
these slides from google research
so here's one statement that they they
make here to to temper your expectations
half of the people that use applications
have never ever paid for an app
not too surprising most people just want
free right
and so why do people actually pay for an
app or subscribe to a service well here
are the top reasons
number one it had the content i wanted
so my prediction is on this survey it
was probably netflix that most people
decided to subscribe to or disney plus
or something like that
so you might be a sports fan and willing
to pay for espn or whatever favorite
movie channel you are on those are
content is king type of applications
the next one down it says here it
offered features and functionality
unavailable on free alternatives
so i would say that's a pretty unique
app if you can design something that
nobody else provides for free
that's pretty good
uh
i want an ad that is an app that is ad
free so
you can annoy your people so much that
they finally pay the dollar to get your
commercially free app that's that's one
way you can get paid
uh there were no free alternatives
seems unlikely
and the app had good reviews and so
i would say
if you would probably compare yourself
to most others you would you would say
this is a reasonable list of ways that
people are willing to pay for your app
so when you think about monetizing your
app do you have such a strong
set of content
or value in your app
that it doesn't exist in other places
then you might be able to charge
subscriptions or you might be able to
have people pay you so that's some food
for thought now let's talk about revenue
models because there's lots of ways that
people make money
when they're trying to create an app so
it's not just about selling your app and
so i put together a list here of about
what is it six or seven
of ways that people can make money as an
app developer and so let's go through
each of these so first of all the first
is you could just charge money for your
app
now look at minecraft that's one of the
most popular apps on the phone of any
type and you can see that it's 7.49 to
buy now no one in their right mind is
going to pay money for an app that's no
good but everyone knows or in their
target audience knows that minecraft is
a really cool game
and they're willing to pay it
so it's not common to do this it's for a
niche market uh people that need this or
really are liking your service
and it's good for complex or unique app
that no one else has so if you can build
the next minecraft or something like it
then go ahead and put a price tag on it
now the next item is advertising and so
this is pretty much what you can think
of as games right i mean every game that
i've played shows me super annoying ads
it works well
on the ad model only if you have a huge
number of users
and so if you are the lucky few that get
a
a viral app that everyone wants to play
you might make some money on an ad
however if you've got a very narrow
audience which is probably the more
recommended route
find your audience and and close in on
the ideal customer
that
is not a good candidate for advertising
because
you don't want to annoy the few people
that are really your true fans
you want to find some other way to
charge the money and so advertising
revenue might be great
if you are candy crush but for everyone
else not so much
the freemium is probably the best model
that you can think of
so it's the most popular model for
making money it's more profitable to do
freemium than by selling your app or by
putting ads on it and also you can
create quite a large audience because
everyone gets to try your app for free
and then if they bump into features that
they really want
they might be willing to pay you a
subscription or a fee to get it
and you can be guaranteed that
people are pretty satisfied with the app
if they've tried it they use it and
they're willing to give you that extra
freemium part
then you've got a true fan and so i
would recommend that if you're
contemplating a business model think of
freemium as the way to go so there's a
free service there's the standard and of
course the premium and so don't give
away all of the great features of your
app at the beginning
hide some of those that are going to be
critical
but still
give the user an experience to try it
out and so i think almost all of the
apps that i've paid for have been
through a freemium model now think of
ecommerce and you're trying to sell
items so
whether it's amazon or ebay or etsy or
somebody like that you're going to have
to have a massive business that will
actually sell things
and so good luck in competing against
amazon
e-commerce platforms however is a little
bit different you don't have to be the
store
you can be the store that connects
people to stores and so think of ebay
you know then ebay doesn't sell anything
they just connect people
offer up it's like craigslist but on an
app form that people like
hotels.com or orbitz or any of the
travel services airbnb of course is the
biggest hotel business in the world and
they don't own a single hotel room they
just link you with people that have
rooms and so
an e-commerce platform is a great way to
connect
buyers and sellers and you take a cut or
a sliver of the transaction fee
so just this past week i took a vacation
and rented a car through the app called
touro
never tried it before but it worked a
guy met me at the airport gave me his
car keys i borrowed his car for a week
and paid him
i was 300 and some dollars it was it was
uh
40 off of what the car rental company
was willing to charge me and it worked
out as well as anything that you would
expect at airbnb so think of a service
that people need and uh people that are
trying to sell something and you get in
the middle and take a snip of the the
credit and of course your profits will
grow as your user base grows
subscription models of course are
the content people so netflix spends
billions of dollars a year to get their
own movies
and so
you know you're willing to pay your your
monthly fee
language apps seem to be a great
subscription model because people
can't learn a language in just
a week or a month even or maybe even a
year and so
if you're doing a real good service that
requires constant use then of course a
subscription makes sense so i put on
here spotify i'm a customer of them all
trails i mentioned before in some of my
previous videos where i want to find
hiking trails and get maps of where i'm
going and
i'm willing to pay for an annual
subscription because it's a valuable
service to me so think of
ways that people are constantly using
your app
and you provide information that changes
over time or there's such a vast amount
of information that they they can't get
it all in one go
and so that might be a good model for
you with subscriptions
in the last category we have our in-app
purchases so these work really well with
games
so you know when you tried farmville
many years ago you could play for free
but then it took forever to grow your
crops
here's a list of games that are super
profitable and all of them are free to
play but cost you money if you want to
play it quickly or advance
to higher levels
and so
game makers have figured out that once
you have people addicted to your game
they'll sometimes pay anything even if
it doesn't make any sense
to continue on so you can see that
they're selling
ninety-nine dollars a hundred dollars
for pokey coins would you really pay a
hundred dollars for an app
not likely
but somehow if you're addicted you're
going to pay
99
for a bunch of virtual coins
go figure
if you're interested in learning how to
market your app then watch the next
video which is called marketing your app
and if you'd like to see the entire
course playlist i'll put that link here
as well so you can see the business of
applications make sure you subscribe and
join us again for class thank you
[Music]
hi in this video we're going to be
talking about the business of building
apps more specifically we're going to be
talking about marketing your app and
collecting customers
so in this unit we're talking about the
business of building applications we're
on part three which is on marketing and
monetizing so if you haven't subscribed
to make sure you do that to go back and
see the other chapters in this course so
my name is shad slooter and i teach
software development and computer
science at grand canyon university and
so join me for class to see all of these
topics and we'll learn together now in
this video we're talking about the app
business plans and so there are four
sections about planning your business
and we've already looked at two of them
so we're on part three right now which
is about marketing so how do you collect
customers how do you get their attention
and we'll talk about retaining them in a
new video in the future but we want to
get them in the door that's really what
we're dealing with here so marketing
your application so marketing is not
just the idea that it looks cool but we
have to reach the right people with a
value proposition that makes sense and
it's authentic to them and so what i'm
going to do now is show you some
discoveries that google provided me so
the slides that you're going to see here
are from google's market research so
take this with a grain of salt because
they think that search engines of course
are the only way or the best way that
people should work with but they have
some data to support up their
their their claims so it says here apps
are often discovered outside of the app
store so it's important that you have a
good description of your app there's no
doubt about it you should have a clear
selling point when people find you in
the app store however people usually
hear about you in some other way and so
family friends and colleagues are the
most important way that you can collect
new people so in another video we'll
talk about making your app addictive and
why it works when you have people making
recommendations for you and so that'll
be an important part of your app design
is making a share button or invite
button where people are required to join
together to do something on your app and
so
personal recommendations are your best
tool for gaining new customers however
you can see that there are others that
are just
worthy of your time as well so making a
good company website having a good
description in the app store and search
engines can work somewhat as well but
those main two categories at the top are
what we should consider are vital
information
now search is a driver in app discovery
so it says here one in four people use
search engines to find an app which
makes sense you're looking for a
solution to a problem and of course
google is there to collect your ad now
search is is
more effective in certain categories
than others
so here are three so tr travel and
technology
and local apps so apps that are
considered local i suppose for your own
city or something like that
so technology is
good for search so for instance you say
i want an app that can free up memory on
my phone
i'm going to go to google that's the
first place i would look for
travel of course i'm trying to
find a destination and there might be a
tour guide for the city that i'm going
to or something like that and so a niche
market for targeting people that are
doing searches about it
and so you can see the rest of them are
not quite as good
for your search results and in
collecting new customers so think of the
app that you've got your dream app that
you're trying to build and see which
category it fits in here and then you
can decide whether or not that google
search or buying ads on google will be a
main strategy in gaining new customers
for you so you'll be the best judge on
deciding if that is a good channel
so think about the factors that
influence the download why do people
click the button and install the app
so
here's some of them
so why do people install
well believe it or not search ads are
effective in in driving app downloads
so a search ad is perfect because you
know the what's on the user's mind you
you you've seen what they've looked for
and if you can target that then it's the
same same same strategy that that we've
been using for decades now with uh
targeting relevant ads to users
uh i can't believe the second one here
though it says banner and graphical ads
inside of apps
that must be uh skewed because
you get all these uh when you when you
play a game right you play a game and
you get ads they're for other games
which makes sense if you're into games
you'll probably download another game if
it looks fun
and then the others are different ads
for
website ads and video ads
so
i think it's probably goes without
saying if you know who your users are
and you know what apps and things that
they're already looking at you can
probably
cross-pollinate you can probably get
them to jump over into your
market as well if you already know that
they're in an adjacent market
and so look for competitors
uh interest and uh fun okay
recommendations for others so
why would you want to install here's
here's another factor so recommendations
from others
number two or the second one on the
right here is
familiarity with the company and brand
this makes sense because
let's say you're um
let's say you're talking about an
airline app
you booked a flight with american
airlines and now you know that you have
to check in with an app well you're
gonna you're gonna choose their their
app of course you're their customer so
this isn't so much about acquiring new
customers maybe is is serving your
existing customers better so does your
app
provide something that their website
doesn't
and so i'll provide you a link with
another question about
why would you choose an app over a
website
because you might not need an app at all
if your website's doing the job and so
there's some other factors
here is probably the most important
is about price
and so in a previous video we talked
about how you can monetize your app
and free apps with a freemium model
where you have certain features that are
extra money
is
far more effective than trying to charge
money for the app up front
because when it says here factors
important
uh 82 percent say price that means free
right
price means no price
and people are not going to pay you
money for an app that they've not really
tested out
get good ratings of course that goes
without saying people with bad ratings
are just going to scare away new users
the description you better have a clear
description and good screenshots in the
app store otherwise people will probably
not know what they're getting
and then the others are reviews
so most users expect their apps to be
free but that deter it is also
determined on the category
so check the top app out
technology apps
so i can think of recently i paid ten
dollars for an app
for a technology app i had a an app that
would allow me to extend my desktop
screen
to my um my tablet
and so it was like having a second
monitor kind of cool using me using the
usb cord connection or even a wi-fi
connection so i think i spent ten
dollars or something like that and i'm
not likely gonna spend ten dollars on
most apps but that provided me with a
portable second monitor
and for where my kind of work it was
great because i'm carrying my laptop to
different classrooms and working in
places that are not my office or at
least i did before the covid
scare and so i was willing to pay ten
dollars for a technology app so if
you've got something that is solving a
technology problem that might be a good
fee that you put on it
however at the bottom you can see the
other extreme is gaming people probably
not pay you for your game
they want to play free games because
12 year old
kids don't have a lot of money and for
them a two dollar fee is gonna be a game
game breaker you know it's not gonna
happen
and so make sure that you know your
audience so the next step in your
business process is probably talking
about investors and so the next video
we'll talk about pitching your plan if
you'd like to see the entire playlist
for the business of applications i'll
put this link on the screen as well the
business course on building apps my name
is shad make sure you subscribe and come
to class with me again thank you
[Music]
hi welcome to the business of building
applications so this is about mobile
applications and the business plans that
go with them so we're in a course that
has several units and we're on part
three right now which is called
marketing and monetizing your app so you
can see that there are other topics that
are here so if you're interested in this
kind of thing make sure that you
subscribe and you can join me for class
on other occasions my name is shad
slooter and i teach software development
and computer science at grand canyon
university so welcome to class and
please come again so we're in the app
business plan area right now which is
talking about money and how to make
money and so we're in part four which is
at the bottom here of this grid the
investors that you're going to deal with
so some of you will never get to the
investor stage or probably will never
get there because this requires a lot of
momentum in your business
so go back and talk about your business
model first and how you plan to make
money before you ask other people to
help you out
so
investors are kind of scary it's a whole
new field that is beyond what most of us
computer science people are good at i
mean we're building things that are
built out of bits and bytes and user
interfaces and now we're talking about
managing
money and partnerships so why do you
want an investor maybe you don't want an
investor but if you do you have to have
a good reason so here are some of the
reasons first of all you have to expand
what's already going and you don't have
enough capital maybe you need
advertising to grow your your market or
you have development of a new phase of
your business and you're going to need
some investment to help you there or
these partners will have networks that
will help you out so there are a variety
of ways where you would want to bring
somebody in
but there are course drawbacks people
don't just give you money they want a
segment of your company and so if you
give away part of your company you no
longer own that
and you lose equity so you may
start off with 100 ownership of your
company but by the time the investors
are done you will be a minority owner of
your own company you might even lose
control of your company they won't like
the way that you're running it and since
they have the cash they make the final
decision
and of course there's always the
possibility of conflict
i think the most uh famous example at
least from my world is steve jobs
the founder of apple or the co-founder
of apple was fired from his own company
by the board of directors
and of course the people that fired him
nearly drove apple into the ground
and were basically a bankrupt company
and they asked steve jobs to come back
so unless you're steve jobs you probably
won't get that second chance
but anyway
investors have a lot to offer but they
come at a price
so the stages of growth though are maybe
so far away that you're not even ready
for that
in the first stage usually most
companies are in their what they call
the bootstrap stage
you look at your own money first and so
you mortgage your house or you max out
your credit cards or maybe you were just
born rich but you have to have your own
funds and then the second is you ask
your friends and your family to help you
and of course you give them a share of
the company you say hey for ten percent
give me a hundred thousand dollars and
you can be a billionaire in ten years
maybe maybe not
but you have to have people that really
believe in you because you can't really
uh
sell your friendships
unless you've got some some pretty good
plans so you could have some potential
for problems
uh business incubators are probably
going to be in one of the stages where
you're thinking about growing so you've
got a product uh you need a you need
some office space you've got some
employees now and you got to have some
some space and so governments usually
are pretty nice they give you these
incubation centers or these business
playgrounds or i don't know what you
would call them but these these uh low
cost and
early stage kind of growth they might
even give you grants and give you some
free money if you promise to hire people
so where i work at grand canyon
university we have a place called canyon
ventures and so if you if you've got an
app or if you've got a business please
contact my employer they will give you
free office space
literally no rent
they will give you access to
internet and technology and advice
there's only one caveat
is that you have to hire my students
which is a great deal because my
students are really smart right
they
know how to program in different
languages and
well i've taught them everything i know
so if you hire my students the
university
gets the benefit that they think is
valued to them but you get free rent and
you've got yourself a great environment
where
i don't know there's at least 50
companies now working in the business
venture area
and a lot of them with are dealing with
technology and so you are networking as
well as getting some free
office space
venture capital is eventually going to
come where you've gotten a
certain stage your company is working
now when you get to this stage and angel
investors are willing to give you large
amounts of money millions perhaps
if they have some questions that they
can answer
so if you ever watch shark tank these
are usually the venture capital kind of
stage where people have some track
record to prove that they're making
income
and then far into the future
when your app really hits it big then
most people have what they call an exit
strategy where
they lose control of the company but
they get a couple of billion dollars out
of it if they're lucky and so they want
to be bought out or maybe the company is
unique and will stand on its own and
will become a public company and so you
have your ipo or your initial public
offering and you sell stocks
and so the idea is
you want to be a partial owner of
something really big
than to be a full owner of something
really small they say it's better to
have a slice of the watermelon than to
own the entire grape i guess that's the
analogy and so those are the stages of
your investment and the growth of your
company and where you're going to get
your funds to make it work
so let's give some examples here of some
apps that really hit it quite big so you
might remember if you're old enough that
instagram was its own company and it was
growing quickly and facebook bought them
they could see that they were a rising
threat and so for a cool billion dollars
facebook
quenched that problem
tumblr was purchased by yahoo well just
recently yahoo was being sold by i think
verizon is their latest ownership and
tumblr is no longer part of yahoo
anyway it's a old
old business but they paid a billion
dollars at one point for uh this web app
uh skype famously purchased by microsoft
for eight billion dollars
and uh microsoft somehow
missed it uh zoom became the thing in
the coved era of working from home
microsoft and its billions couldn't
compete
i don't know is skype that good or maybe
not
whatsapp was purchased by facebook for
19
billion dollars facebook obviously has
way too much money that they can just
buy their competitors
i predict that in the future the
government won't be so keen on letting
them buy everybody
and that starts to look like
anti-competitive behavior if you ask me
so most investors are thinking about
this kind of a long-term payback their
your business is going to grow really
well
and some other wealthy company will
hopefully buy you
and that's when they get their money
back and so everyone gets rich in the
process and hopefully the app continues
on working as well as it did before
large companies have a bad reputation of
destroying good products
just because they were competitors but
anyway the owner gets the cash and
hopefully the workers still have a job
after the merger occurs now if you talk
to investors they're going to have some
very specific questions
so
these are some of them are you committed
to your plan
so they're judging you just as much as
their product are you a trustworthy
employee because if they give you a
large chunk of cash they're investing in
you just as much as your idea
are you skilled enough
do they think that you're a competent
owner of the business
they obviously are not going to invest
money in somebody that will squander it
how much money are you spending that's a
huge question you might have a million
dollars of revenue but if it cost you a
million dollars to create that revenue
your company is really at zero and so
cost cutting is very important to
investors
how fast are you growing
investors don't want to see a five
percent annual growth in most companies
that would be for a mature company but a
startup has to be at rocket level
acceleration
because they expect to see huge returns
because many times businesses don't work
out
how do you compare to the competition
so do investors already own something or
stock in somebody else that is your
direct competitor if so then there might
be conflicts uh who else is invested so
you might come and ask for help from an
investor but you've already sold most of
your company to other investors and so
they're going to come in and be a
minority voice in your company they
might not be interested in that how
about this will you be profitable of
course that's the whole bottom line
isn't it and then finally how much of
the company are you willing to give me
and so this is a struggle do you really
want to give away control of your baby
to somebody else that just sees it as a
dollar sign proposition
because you are emotionally invested in
the idea that you created so i'm not
really a business expert so i i'm
probably not the best authority to talk
about most of this but if you if you
watch the pitch on
shark tank you get the idea people have
a story of who they are
what value they create and how
successful they currently are and so
some of the usual questions that i just
went through here are the same ones that
you get from the panel of judges on
shark tank they want to know how
profitable are you what your expenses
what what your story who else is
invested and and things like that once
again as i mentioned at grand canyon
university it's probably most other
universities we have these panels of
investors that are willing to take a
look at companies that even our own
students are working on and give them
help and support and investments and
guidance
so find out who is doing this kind of
work in your local area
and attend the meetings and watch other
pitches and maybe you can get some help
as well with your own business plan now
if you want to design a product that is
truly addictive then there are some
principles that we can go through here
in the next video if you'd like to see
the entire course playlist for the
business of apps i'll put that link here
as well and if you haven't subscribed
make sure you do that now
welcome to class and keep watching
[Music]
hi and welcome to the business of
building applications this is a course
for people who are not only developers
but also designers so we're in the part
three the chapter three of this course
which is about marketing and monetizing
our app or you might call it the
business plan and so i'm going to call
this assignment activity number three so
what are we going to do in activity
three we're going to write a plan that
will tell us how we're going to make
this a viable business who our
relationships are with how we expect to
get money and what our expenses will be
so the background of this assignment is
i want you to identify those things key
relationships and strategies to make
your app work so if you remember from a
previous lesson that i have
i talked about this
diagram here that is going to tell you
about all of the different parts of your
business so this is called the bmc or
the business model canvas and so it
identifies all the key partners key
activities key expenses how we are going
to make our business run and so in one
page you have a business plan so here's
the instructions following this model i
want you to create a one-page summary of
the plan for why your application will
be a viable business make sure that you
identify the key relationships and the
customers and the revenue streams that
you are going to have in your business
so then what i want you to deliver to me
then is a one-page document so this can
be a word document that has the plan and
make sure that you hit all of those high
points so if you haven't seen the video
on the bmc then go ahead and check out
the playlist
and if you have seen it then get right
ahead and start it on your thinking
process of why your business is a viable
business i would
grade you based on how thorough you are
and how thoughtful it includes all of
these different items so if you need to
include details then please do so if
you're not one of my students of course
if you're trying to create a business
then i recommend that you create a plan
that you can
talk to yourself about as well as with
your partners in any case i will put the
course playlist here so you can see more
details and the other chapters that
we're talking about and i will see you
in the next class
[Music]
hi and welcome to this video here that's
in a series about the business of
building mobile applications and we're
in a class right now which is going to
have several chapters and so we are on
part 4 right now which is about building
customer loyalty so if the other topics
here look of interest to you then make
sure you subscribe
my name is shad sluter and i teach
computer science and software
development at grand canyon university
and so this is one of the courses that
i'm involved with so if you like this
please subscribe and make sure you come
to class with me
so what we're talking about today is
building customer loyalty or you might
call this making your apps addictive
depends on how you want to phrase it but
the idea is that we want to retain our
customers and make our app successful
so why do people abandon their apps so i
have a few slides here from google that
will help us answer those questions
first of all there's an opportunity here
so if you're like me you're probably
going to build apps that fit this
category that they never get used after
the users create them so there's a
fantastic art in making an app that's
addictive or
loyal and so we want to find out what
some of those principles are
customers frequently never use their app
for more than the one time they're
forced to so you can probably relate
i've been on airlines where they force
you to download an app to get a boarding
pass
and i'm probably not going to fly for a
long time so i just delete the app so we
don't want users to treat our app as a
necessity we want to make something
that's attractive and even addictive
why do people quit using your app
well the number one reason is probably
obvious
they get bored with it
it's the same old same old there's no
variety so why bother so they just kind
of lose interest
or perhaps they had a need that they
wanted to fill
and your app did that and now it no
longer is necessary and so those are
some of the main reasons why people
would abandon an app
so google in their research says that
sometimes we can reward users for coming
back to an app so a coupon or a discount
or some kind of bonus content and so
when you get the alert on your phone
that says there's something new or
something valuable they'll probably open
the app again so what we're looking at
in this series is how to make those
things happen
if you're into a category that is about
sales then of course discounts are going
to be a big deal but if you're just in
an app that's meant for entertainment or
education or some kind of social media
there might be some other ways that you
can make them come back we have two
goals really goal number one is that
eventually you want to have an internal
trigger that when they see the icon on
your phone
they are going to want to open it for
some reason
it's the first to mine solution so
i have a question for you here when you
have a question
what's the first to mind solution that
you think of well it's google of course
google it what else would you use to
find an answer they have successfully
planted themselves in my mind at least
as the solution to this problem how
about this
you're alone
and you got your phone with you
what do you do when you feel lonely well
you're probably going to facebook or
snapchat or some social media item or
maybe your email or your texting
whatever it is
the solution here is to kill the pain of
being lonely
boredom
so when smartphones were introduced
somebody i remember once told me that we
will never be bored again so it doesn't
have to be just games
sometimes
looking at your favorite news site is a
way to kill boredom or casual games how
about this number two your customer
loyalty goal
is to try to create
a compulsion okay now we're getting into
some gray areas here about
either your app being a loyalty app or
being addictive apps well addictions
here are actually a case uh here's one
have you ever heard anyone say this
i have to harvest my strawberries
this might go back a few more years than
you're used to but i remember farmville
was an addictive app where people had to
plant crops and they couldn't leave them
alone
here's one that's probably a little more
up to date it'll always be in our
consciousness i posted a picture and i
went back three times to check how many
people liked it so we're pretty much
addicted to being liked
how about this one just one more episode
and so
whether it's youtube or netflix there's
more content than we'll ever be able to
consume in our lives and we just seem to
keep watching how about this one
we have a dilemma as i've already raised
is if you're going to try to design your
app to be loyal or addictive
we have a responsibility hopefully what
you're building is something that is
socially redeemable it's worthwhile
and so you're not here just to say
i want to make money on my app hopefully
you have a higher purpose in your
business plan than just to create money
maybe you could have it a little better
when you say like this i want to
encourage people to practice
healthy behaviors
so let's say your app is to help people
learn a foreign language or with their
math tutoring or lose weight
or to be able to save time or to connect
with friends those are all great goals
and so if you make somebody a loyal user
in something that is a worthwhile cause
then of course the morality of addiction
is is pretty good however if all your
building is something that will take
people's time and money then shame on
you
how about this let's go to the hook this
is a model
that we're going to follow through
a proven strategy that has been studied
to figure out why people keep coming
back to the apps that they do there's
four items first of all there's a
trigger that causes them to enter the
app then there's an action which better
be simple and it better be engaging then
there's the variable reward so that the
app did doesn't become boring so every
time you open up the app there's
something interesting and a little bit
unexpected that you are wanting to see
and so that way you're more motivated to
return to it and then finally you have
to have something from the user
something that they have to do
such as save their place save a file
build a reputation or something that
they invest in and so that they feel
like they have to keep coming back
otherwise they've abandoned some of
their work and so this idea of the hook
literally comes from a book called
hooked and you can see the subtitle is
how to build
habit forming products
so once again habit forming products can
be a bad thing if all you're doing is
hooking people
on destructive behaviors so before you
try to make your app so addictive that's
that you're hooking users
make sure that it's something that's
worthwhile doing
so let's review this hook
there has to be somewhere to start you
can't just put people on the circle
without a beginning and so the external
hook is really where we're going to
begin
so this external thing
causes a trigger and then that comes to
the action then that goes to the
variable reward and the user investment
and hopefully re-triggering again
so we need a trigger to get us started
so
how did facebook become a two billion
user app
well they had to start somewhere and so
they made it a cool thing
you're not going to be able to
immediately launch a very popular app
without some investment which is why
companies require a bit of money to get
started
so here's one way to do it you can just
buy google ads
i kind of probably are going to regret
this but i put into my google search
find a car loan
and of course you can see that there are
no organic search results every single
thing on here is an ad
and i bet it costs quite a bit of money
for those people to be placed so high so
anyway if a person has a need they're
going to go to google and search for
that this is probably a way that you can
start people on your app what is the
need that your app serves
buy an ad and you can acquire customers
through paid ads of course this will be
expensive at first but really there's no
shortcut to getting new people into your
app
well once you've got a few people
another way to get customers and to get
them hooked or the initial acquiring
stage
is to have your social connections
and so you're hopefully going to be able
to send an announcement or a text or an
email to somebody from a respected
friend and they're going to invite you
to come and so you can acquire customers
through friends
maybe your app requires that friend to
comment or to play a game with you or to
share a picture or something
but we want to be able to make the
growth organic because you can't pay for
google ads for very long
then the next item
is once you've got an app and you've got
it running they're going to forget about
it your users will install it and ignore
it and of course you better have a good
reason for them to come back for example
in this case it says hey two items in
your shopping cart are on sale
well if you're a shopper app and you
installed it at one time because you
wanted to save money this will probably
bring you back into the circle and so
this is all examples
of the initial hook
the part that gets you going so we want
to re-engage or to engage new customers
so let's summarize the start so we can
either do a search result or we can have
a notification from a friend
but there's another way probably the
most effective way of all other than
these mechanical and artificial ways we
want to do it naturally
we want to create an urge
inside our user's mind to be either the
first solution that comes to mind
or a solution to a pain or a problem
and so this is called an internal
trigger so an internal trigger
doesn't require any money
it's what we want to get to that's our
goal we want our users to have that
feeling that they have to open your app
so you look at your phone maybe when
you're bored and one icon kind of
jumps out
over all the others so in my case uh
instagram's a pretty common one i want
to open it i'm curious what's there but
what's the real reason that that app is
in my habit cycle
well there could be this fear of missing
out i want to know what's going on what
are my friends up to and what's
happening in the world or i have this
problem where i always want to seem to
take a vacation i want to travel and so
what a great app i can look around the
world and find creative hikes to take in
cities and beautiful places that i
haven't been yet and i want to go or
maybe you're more into the social
connections with these social apps
and you're lonely and you want to know
what your family or your friends are
doing well any way that you look at it
an app like instagram
has an internal motivation it's the
trigger
just by being installed
and showing up on the desktop you're
going to have a trigger to use it
so how do you trip those internal
triggers how do you get to that part in
a previous video we talked about the
five why's the five why's can bring you
to the root cause of something so why
would julie want to use email so that
she can receive messages of course
the second why in the list brings you a
little deeper and why would she want to
receive messages well she wants to share
information quickly why would she want
to do that well she wants to know what's
going on with her co-workers friends and
family
well why does she need to do that see
how the y's just keep piling on she
wants to know if somebody needs her and
why does she need to do that
because she fears of being out of the
loop and so there is that deeper need
she fears something and we're going to
meet that and that will become an
internal trigger if we can solve that so
that's the orange bubble that's what
we've looked at is the trigger part now
let's talk about the action so if you
want to make an addictive apps
what do we have to do in that action
stage so the action is the main activity
what do you do with your app you show
pictures do you share coupons do you do
something so that better have some
features that will call our app
experience and if you get that right
then people will have that feeling of
wanting to come back again and again
so in the action there better be two
principles here that are met first of
all it has to be easy
and then the second it has to be
something motivating it's emotionally
satisfying it's cool
i like it and so those are pretty broad
and
pretty hard to define really so let's
talk about some examples
so if we were to say we want to have an
ingredients to look at what causes an
action
we would say that there has to be three
ingredients there's the motivation the
ability to do it and a trigger
now we've talked about motivations and
triggers already
the action part the
part that you're trying to program and
that your users are engaged with is
number two
how difficult is your app to use and
like i mentioned it better be simple and
it better be kind of fun
so take a look here at the
percent of
ease of use we'll call this
compared to the number of users that are
actually using the product
and so you can see pinterest in the top
right corner is really easy to publish
something online and if you look back in
time
the other ones are slightly more
difficult and so the idea is
make it so easy that the users can't not
do it
so how do you measure effort well you
can measure it in several ways you can
say it's time
or it costs money or it's thought in
consuming it's difficult to understand
or you might do something that would be
embarrassing and we'll call that a
social cost or
it breaks the routine and that makes it
more difficult
and so the resistance to making your app
action happen goes up if we increase any
of those ingredients if it takes too
long if it's too complex if it costs too
much money or if you're going to
embarrass your users
they're probably not going to do it and
so we want to keep all of those things
to a minimum
now just a simple design in your app can
make that difference so think if you
were going to show a list of pictures
you could do it with the results of an
infinite scroll
so that the user has nothing to do but
keep moving their thumb
and see what's next so that's kind of
the instagram approach really no one
ever reaches the bottom of their
instagram feed however if you were to
break it up into pages and just showed
10 pictures per page you would have a
natural break and people would stop
after one or two page links and so
that's a real simple design of making it
simple and easy to use
one term that you'll hear in this in
this kind of a conversation is the idea
of frictionless
frictionless is usually about buying
things so amazon famously has the buy
with one click button that's pretty
frictionless they've got your credit
card saved and you don't have to think
too much or in your case maybe your app
has a registration screen well don't do
the one on the left you don't want to
make that too much time or too much
effort just have them sign up with their
favorite social media account
and so we've talked about the trigger
and now the action so keep the action
simple
and have something interesting to do or
something useful to do
now the third one that most apps use
that are very addictive is something
called
the variable reward so that's the third
item in this list so what is a variable
reward well the reward is the emotional
response or payback that you get from
using your app
but the modifier is we want to make it
variable so that way it is something
that we would classify as cool
or
new let me give an example so pinterest
is an app that has a variable reward
i opened up the pinterest page today and
took this screenshot
i had no idea what i was going to get i
look across here i see a craft it looks
like some photos some poetry
wow talk about variability
and the neat thing is
if you want if you open an app like
instagram or pinterest or facebook or
youtube
you never know quite what's going to be
there but you know you'll find something
so here's another picture so i went to
youtube.com this is just the front page
and you can see that the youtube
algorithm knows pretty much who i am i'm
interested in technology i like hiking
but i have no idea why i got this drum
line or i got this guy
that is
a
failed cash in transit heist whatever
it's just something that is kind of
interesting
so
check your youtube feed out and see if
they are meeting your variable reward
need
of course you probably remember if
you've studied this in psychology at all
that variable rewards can reinforce
behaviors and cause habits to form and
so the experiment was to give pigeons a
reward if they would tap a button they
would get a seed they could get
something to eat
and so the birds certainly learned how
to do that
but then they taught the birds that if
they tap a button
they would get a seed only on certain
occasions
and
it was like a slot machine it was random
now the birds
formed a stronger habit
when they had to tap on the button that
never gave them consistent results
and so the habit was stronger when they
weren't certain if they were going to
get what they wanted so if it was
consistently giving them every click of
the button
it wasn't so interesting but a variable
that was very interesting and so humans
are not a whole lot different so why do
people sit and look at a stupid game
that all they can do is press a button
and watch pictures
i honestly don't get the idea of slot
machines but a lot of people seem to
like them
they are doing
variable rewards
now if i offered you 80 cents for every
dollar that you gave me you would soon
stop that ridiculous transaction
but if we had it variablized we don't
know exactly who's going to win
then you would keep at it
now b.f skinner a great psychologist of
course in behavioralism talked about
these three types of variable rewards
so what kind of classifications are
these we got the tribe the self and the
hunt so let's reinforce this with what
our apps can do to meet these emotional
needs so first we'll talk about the self
okay what does that mean so in your
reward you're going to have some kind of
a self promotion you've reached a new
level you've unlocked a new feature
you've gained a certificate you have
accomplished something that makes your
own capacity greater and so we'll call
that your self-reward there's also a
reward that we could classify as the
hunt
so finding something that's really cool
before anyone else does and of course
pinterest looks to me like a great hunt
app
so i'm not sure what i'm going to find
there but i will probably find
something and so there's a variable
reward on this one called the hunt or
here's another one
the variable reward
of the tribe
and so sometimes when you make a post
you can only hope that you'll get a
million likes on it wouldn't that make
you feel warm and fuzzy to say that i
picked something that was cool and
everybody liked me
or maybe you're more into the technology
like with stack overflow
you answer a question or you post a post
a question
and people vote
reward points reputation points and so
who doesn't want to be known as a smart
programmer and so
that is a variable reward you never know
what quite you'll get every time you
participate
so we've covered three of the four the
last one's coming up here which is
called
user investment and so this one's just
as important as the other three
so what is user investment well it's
something that you contribute and it
makes the product more valuable some
people would call that the ikea effect
and so ikea of course is the company
that sells furniture in a box
and you have to put it together so first
of all it's cheaper that way they don't
have to assemble it but you also take a
little bit of pride to say i built the
desk
so here's an example of an app that
would have user investment
so you play this game called
gardenscapes for a while
and
probably you're planting vegetables in a
garden and virtually you've gone through
three seasons of harvest and now you're
quitting the app and as soon as you
close it it says hey stop
i want to help you you save your
progress you've invested your time
so don't just throw it away
or maybe uh you're in your airlines and
they say you just took a flight and
we'll save your travel miles and you'll
come back
so that's the idea uh here's another one
where you can have a collection so
you're under some kind of a
music play
or a
video play app
and you create a list of things that you
like well of course that's a user
investment
when you use the app and the more you
use the app the more it becomes part of
you
and that becomes an emotional attachment
or maybe something a little bit like
this is from linkedin
so you start
using linkedin you put your profile up
your job experience and then you stop
well they present this to you to say hey
you're making good progress we're almost
to this next level
level up if you can just add a summary
of your
portfolio or put a photo on it and so
they make it a game so that you can make
different levels
so
your user investment is going to
increase the people's emotional
investment
in your app and they're more likely to
return if they know they've already
collected something
and invested the time it's the same
principle that we have here when you
have a frequent shopper card
i'm more likely to go back to the a
restaurant if i know that i'm just one
punch away from a free meal
so
here's here's a kind of a statistic that
i think is very telling so 71 of users
will stick to an app if you can get them
to use it three times are or more
so you look at that uh
71 percent is pretty high so if you can
get them to use it more than once you're
on the right track
three times seems to be a pretty good
number so make sure that there's at
least three reasons for them to return
to check on something
so our goal here is to reach the habit
zone
so
the habit zone is going to depend on two
factors it looks like so the frequency
of your app of course how often they
come back
and the usefulness of your app so even
though
they might not be on your app every
single day if it's something they really
need they won't forget about it so i'll
give you two examples here so google
google is something that we use multiple
times many times a day and it's pretty
useful too actually but
they're uh one of the most addictive or
we'll call them loyal app user
apps that we can find the other we'll
call amazon so
i don't shop on amazon every day but i'm
sure some people do that are watching
this
i wonder if you could put in your
comments below here of
what's the most
number of purchases you've ever made in
a single day on amazon and i think the
poor delivery guy that comes here every
time i click buy
well that's the model and so the idea is
that your app should have either
something so useful that they can't
forget about you or something that is
easy and frequently used and that will
help you become part of the addictive
app now once again let's say that with
great power comes great responsibility
so make an app that actually is useful
and is something that people should come
back to
so don't just do an app because you
think it's going to make you money make
something that will make their life
better and then you will have a good
conscience about why people should come
back and use your app again in the next
video we're going to talk about which
tools that you should use to build an
app whether it's for cross-platform or
single app platform also if you'd like
to see the entire playlist for this
course i'll put a link here for the
course playlist so whichever i thank you
for coming make sure you subscribe and
join me again for the next class
[Music]
hi and welcome to the business of
building apps this is a course for
people who are not only programmers but
also business analysts so we're in
section 4 right now which is called
building customer loyalty and this is a
video that will help you through an
assignment that i'm going to give you if
you were one of my students that i am
teaching at grand canyon university so
in this assignment the goal here is for
you to demonstrate that you understand
hook so what is hook well the background
is that in a previous lesson we said
that hooked is the process of retaining
loyal customers or in a more cynical way
how to make your product addictive and
so that your customers are stuck with
you so the process of hook was these
four steps we had trigger action
variable reward and user investment so
i'm not going to reteach all this that
was in a different video so what i want
you to do for the assignment then is to
demonstrate to me that you understand
how this hook process works so i'm going
to ask you if you are one of my students
to write a paper that summarizes these
four steps in the hook process and of
course provide examples when appropriate
then i want you to look at your own
phone and look at the apps that you most
commonly work with so as you describe
these four steps in the hook process i
want you to provide examples of where
you are being hooked
what are the features of the apps that
you currently use how are they related
and how do they map to these four steps
so obviously if it's something you use
frequently it's something that makes you
a loyal customer maybe even an addicted
customer so the deliverables that i
expect to get from you if you're one of
my students is to get a one-page summary
of the hook model telling me about the
four steps make sure that as you do that
there are examples given from real life
in your personal experience where you
have seen hook
so if you haven't seen the other videos
i will leave a link to the playlist for
the course so that you can go and see
what the information here is
if you are not one of my students you
can probably put in the comments below
in the youtube section of where you have
seen these places of hook happen and why
they are effective in your life so in
any case make sure that you subscribe
because this might be a valuable
information to you at least i hope it is
and if you're coming back i will see you
again in the next class
[Music]
hi and welcome to the business of
building apps this is a course for
people who are designing applications
and the business decisions that go with
them so there's multiple chapters in
this course and we're on chapter four
which is about building customer loyalty
in this particular video i'm going to
talk about an assignment if you were one
of my students at grand canyon
university this is what i would ask you
to do for homework activity 4.2 and the
goal here is to apply the hook process
to the design of your own app now if you
don't know what hook is make sure that
you go back and look at the previous
videos hook is the process of making an
app work well so that way you become a
loyal or maybe an addicted customer so
what i want you to do now is to go and
review the business plan in a previous
assignments i asked you to create a
business plan which includes your
relationships uh your revenue streams
and your costs
and i want you to take a look at the app
that you designed and all of the user
stories that go with it
so you will notice that when you have
your
user stories in a chart that there may
be gaps of things that you didn't
include
of the hook process so think about this
way hook is the trigger the action the
variable reward and user investment so
like i said that's been taught already
so what i want you to do is with an
assignment i'm going to have you to
create a table so i'm going to show you
a table in just a second so you can
either do it on from scratch or copy the
one that i give you and i'm going to ask
you to review all of the features in
your app
and see if you can add some new ones
that would increase your customer
loyalty for each new feature that you
add tell me where it fits in the hook
model
so for instance
if there are four different things in
the hook model such as trigger action
reward and user investment
then which of the features in your user
stories
map to those items
and most likely there's going to be some
gaps
so what i want you to do is to add new
features
so for instance you might say you forgot
to put in here as a user i want to share
some feature of what i've done
with other friends
so
that may have not been in your user
stories yet
or you might have something like
as a user i want to be able to
save my progress so that i can come back
later and continue where i left off so
that may have not been in one of your
user stories i'm just suggesting that
those are two likely items that you
would put in this chart so the goal here
is to review all of the user stories and
see if you can fill in some gaps where
you have not made your app very loyal
friendly or addictive
so if you were to submit this to me as
your teacher i would expect to get a
word document that would have this table
in it and in that table there would be
improvements and new user stories that
are mapped to those four items in the
hook model so if you'd like to see the
entire playlist for the course i will
put that here so you can go back and see
what the hook model is and the other
items for building apps are so if you're
one of my students i will see you again
in the next class and if not please
subscribe and join us
[Music]
hi welcome to this video where we're
talking about the business of building
mobile applications and so we're in the
middle of a course which has got several
chapters and so if you like what you see
here make sure that you subscribe we are
on chapter 5 which is choosing the right
tools for your mobile application
so in this unit we're going to be
talking about what technically you can
do with a phone and maybe what works
better with a mobile website so my name
is chad slooter and i teach computer
science and software development at
grand canyon university and i'm glad you
joined us so make sure that you
subscribe to catch all of these and we
will become better programmers and
better business people as a result so in
this section here about our business
tools our application development tools
we're going to have three different
things to look at first of all
since it is a mobile application course
it seems strange that i'm going to say
in this video why you should not build a
mobile application there are some
reasons why it might not be a good idea
in the next video we're going to be
talking about the
companies and applications that utilize
mobile apps in a very effective way and
then finally we'll talk about
cross-platform mobile choices what
languages and frameworks are best and
popular today so right now though i'm
going to give you five reasons why it
might be a better idea
not to build your mobile app even though
you may have started with the assumption
that you need a mobile application so
why would that be if the teacher is
teaching a class on mobile applications
it's because there are some pretty good
alternatives when you compare what you
can do with a standard web browser and
what you can do in a mobile app
so compare these two pictures on the
screen
which one of these looks like a better
experience for the user
so the point is
they're hard to distinguish so you're at
a store you can browse the catalog you
can see all the products you can add
something to the cart you can check out
you can use your credit card
almost everything that you can do on the
mobile app you can do on the um on the
website
the website is designed to look good on
a phone that's why it's called a mobile
first design or a responsive design
and so
maybe your phone app isn't really a
necessity at all because we can deal
with a lot of things when we have just a
mobile website but let's talk about some
reasons why you would think that a
mobile app is required and then we'll go
to the reasons why you might want to
just go with a website
reason number one
you need to have high performance so if
your goal is to build something that is
uh graphically intensive
and like a game here then a mobile app
clearly is the choice because you will
never be able to create the same
performance in your web browser such as
chrome
now the second reason is you probably
should consider what phone features are
available and if you need them then you
build an app for example if you need to
scan something you're going to use the
camera
also think about the other features of
your phone it has a gps sensor so it's
location aware it has an accelerometer
so it knows when it's moved so you can
tell if your phone is being
shaken or if it's been turned around in
360 degree space
the camera obviously is something that a
mobile app will be better at than a
website and then there are other
accessories so for instance think of if
you plug in some kind of an external
blood pressure reader or some kind of a
credit card swiper those are going to
probably need a mobile app a native app
and not a website so that's probably the
biggest reason you would want to choose
a mobile app but if you haven't thought
of those if those are not in your scope
then this is a reason why you shouldn't
need a mobile app
let's talk about push notifications so
what is a push notification well that's
the alert that shows up on the phone
that says hey there's something new come
back to the app
and so if that's important to you then
you can probably use a mobile app and
not the website so you would probably be
able to send emails to customers or text
alerts
but if you want to have the pop-up
message then a mobile app is what you
need
also the value of the icon itself
so when you have an app installed you
own a square of real estate
and if you're really lucky the user will
give you the front page
so
that in itself might be enough reason
why you would build a mobile app
the user will come back they don't have
to remember your web page address so
those are good reasons for a mobile app
but let's talk about
if you would not do the mobile app and
you would just make the responsive
website
why would that actually be an advantage
so here are some reasons first of all
mobile apps don't show up in search
results very well
web pages do
and so when people search for a topic on
google they're going to pick one of the
first few links probably the first three
definitely the first page and so you
want to be able to design a web page
that is optimized for your keywords your
niche audience
and so a website is a better
attractor of search results
also think of the probably the cost of
your mobile application
and this is a very technical reason
one code base
so a one code base means that you have a
single server
that adapts to a mobile phone to a
tablet to a desktop and that all shows
up in the chrome browser or whatever
browser the user chooses
the single code base is super important
because
you either hire another programmer or
you split a programmer's attention to
two different code bases
essentially if you have an ios app and a
android app and a website you have three
applications as a business person you're
trying to reduce cost and a having a
single team or a single developer that
is focused on a website instead of
having three different developers or
three different teams you've cut your
cost in less than half using a single
code base so i would say that is
probably
a powerful reason for a startup to focus
on just a mobile-friendly website you
don't have to have so much code and
development cost
also think of the technical problems so
every time there is a
update to the operating system on
android or ios
you're going to have to make sure that
your app conforms to the new features of
the uh of the the operating system
sometimes there's new requirements
sometimes there's permissions that need
to be gathered and you need to go in
to your code of your app and update it
and if you don't you're probably going
to have this occur you're going to have
application crashes and people will hate
you and give bad feedback
now if you build a website this rarely
happens
if a website works on one client it's
likely going to work well on most
clients now there are exceptions to that
and you can certainly create a website
that crashes there's no doubt there
but i'm saying that there are less
problems with keeping a website up to
date than there are keeping three or
more different versions of a mobile app
here's another important reason for cost
there are no fees when you build a
website
so you would know that uh apps such as
um the app store and the play store
charge you a commission for every
transaction inside of your app so if
you're selling virtual goods or
subscriptions
they're going to take 30 percent of your
of your profit or your whole charge not
your profit but the whole price
and if you if you make a transaction on
a website no problem at all they would
just uh not even see that
this does not occur for physical goods
so amazon is not paying 30 percent to
apple for every time you buy
a
item from the amazon store but this does
apply to subscriptions and virtual goods
here's a term called instant updates so
this refers to also the technical
problems
if you have to update an app you're
going to annoy the user it takes a few
seconds
sometimes it's automatic but if you're
doing an update to a website the user
doesn't have to download anything just
the next time that they visit your web
page
the changes are in effect so there are
both advantages and disadvantages to
choosing a mobile app versus a mobile
friendly web page in the next video i'm
going to show you examples of eight
different companies that really nailed
it when it came to designing their
mobile app if you'd like to see the
entire playlist for this course i will
put that link here as well make sure you
subscribe and come back to class with me
thank you for watching
[Music]
hi and welcome to the business of
building applications this is a series
of videos this for a course that i'm
teaching and we're talking about the
business process and the management and
design of applications you can see that
there are several chapters that i'm
going to cover here and we are on number
five right now which is focused on
choosing the right kinds of tools for
the apps that you're building
so if this looks interesting to you make
sure that you subscribe my name is shad
slutter and i am a professor of software
technologies at grand canyon university
so please come to class with me if you
like this kind of thing these are the
other topics that are ahead of us so
there's still more to come now let's get
right to the point here we are talking
about the app development choices in the
previous video i said several reasons
for why you shouldn't build an app at
all which is kind of a strange thing for
a class on building mobile applications
so check that one out if you haven't
seen it now we're going to focus on this
one this video about several examples of
apps that really nailed it these are
good products these are companies
usually that make an app worth your
while and then we're going to talk about
cross-platform apps in the next video so
right now we're talking about nine
mobile apps that work so these are
things that actually are worth your
download what is not on the list are a
lot of things that you would probably
already like as apps so for instance
this this example here shows a store
where the mobile experience is very
similar to
the uh
the app experience on a chrome browser
and so really there's no advantage of
building a custom mobile app for this so
for instance amazon you can do all your
shopping on amazon right through their
mobile website and so
it might be a good idea to have the app
but not necessarily so what we're going
to focus on here are people's apps that
really require you to have a native app
let's start with the banks so banks have
done a great job of eliminating the need
for the bank itself and so you've seen
commercials where you can do all of your
banking online you just take a photo of
it and the bank will process with that
photo also it's good for alerts and so
banking has become
clearly not just a computer item
where you can add and remove and
transfer funds but you can make payments
mobile payments you can deposit checks
and so
the bank app that you have on your phone
is likely a good use of your technology
there
i'm going to put mcdonald's in here now
i could probably substitute the
mcdonald's app for most uh
most restaurants
this is just one that i happen to use
and there's a couple of reasons why i
picked it one you can reduce your time
through the drive-through like in half
you don't have to pay for anything it's
already pre-ordered also they give me
all kinds of a location aware kind of
ideas so i know the gps is watching me
so it knows my patterns so i included it
here as an effective mobile app that i
use on a regular basis the next app i'm
going to put on here is no surprise a
lot of people would expect lyft or that
other company uber we would might put in
there
why is this a good mobile solution and
not just a web solution well i think the
gps is pretty important here we have to
know where we are and where we want to
go
and so the com the computing there is
pretty high the graphics of the map have
to be good and most importantly we have
to know the gps location so i'm going to
include lyft as one of those apps that
is transformative without a phone you
probably wouldn't be able to do it and
so this is a great example now i didn't
include uber i have a long memory of
companies that i would consider evil
so so just check the the news from
several years ago about why uber might
be an evil company so the next company
up is walgreens now there's probably
other good pharmacy apps out there but
we'll just pick walgreens because well
they're famous so what can you do with
an app that you can't do with a website
well first of all you can refill your
prescription with a scan so your your
phone has a camera and they've built the
app right there so that it'll recognize
which bottle you have in your hand and
it will connect to your account also
with walgreens you can have telemedicine
so you can talk to the doctor or
pharmacist without an appointment
perhaps standing right there in the
store or as you uh
are on the way maybe hopefully you're
not driving and talking but the
walgreens app is going to eliminate the
need for a lot of time-consuming work
and
you can't do these things in a regular
website so that's why it makes the list
of a successful company app
ikea comes up next so remember ikea is
the company that will sell you
furniture in a box and you have to
assemble it so what does their app do
that's kind of interesting or unique
well they have a 3d modeling tool
which is based on the technology that's
in your phone like
augmented reality and what's called
lidar which is the kind of a radar
system using light waves and you can
place furniture in your house and take a
look at it you can paint your walls and
wallpaper your house virtually and you
can see the results as you move the
phone around so literally you spin
around looking at your phone you see the
room and then you have pictures of
items of furniture and accessories
superimposed over the picture so a great
tool
for selling their products i don't
really know if this is effective as far
as increasing sales
but i liked it because it was the cool
factor so maybe that will just allow
people to
look at ikea's furniture more often so
personally i haven't used the app but i
just think it's a great idea
l'oreal is a makeup company of course
and what are they doing that requires a
mobile app well you can try on their
products you can put lipstick on or
makeup of any kind you can style your
eyes
and it's a virtual kind of an augmented
reality experience as well
so this is kind of an instagram or
snapchat
idea but they're using it to sell their
products and you can see that you can
probably click the buy button and you'll
be happy with your results even though
you haven't actually tried anything on
here's an app that probably is just
picked out of
a classification of many golf shot so
what is golf shot it's a program that
allows you to see around yourself so if
you
select the golf course name that's in
the list
they have all the measurements to the
green to the shortcuts to the sand traps
and it's kind of like having a caddy
that knows the course
extremely well you can see ahead of you
other similar apps to this i've seen is
a peak finder app where you show
the the mountains that are around you it
tells you the mountain name it literally
points to an arrow to the peak and says
like this is long's peak in colorado
which is 14 520 feet tall
and in your golf game yes people get
pretty serious about golf right they
want to make sure that they have the
proper information and you get a map of
the course that you're looking at tells
you a little dot on the map where you
are how far you are to the green
and so once again this is a great
example of an app that requires a native
app it won't work in a website so
download the app it'll be worth your
while and i predict that
rich golf people
are going to spend a little bit of money
on an app if it'll improve their game i
mean for goodness sakes they buy all
kinds of expensive golf carts golf clubs
and clothing so why not invest a little
bit in your mobile app as well
the euphoria chalk is my next candidate
for a great app so what is it it's an
app that you would use
for the remote expert
and almost all the examples that you
would see on their website and other
propaganda that they show
shows a person who's a field technician
is this person
and he's looking at something very
specialized
and you you can see that superimposed
over the picture where he's working is
somebody else
that is drawing on the on the tablet so
the technician might not be familiar
with this piece of equipment and so the
numbers there say plug in here
disconnect number two attach number
three
and it's an augmented reality solution
again so a collaboration of people
looking at an object even though they
might be thousands of miles away so
some years ago i was involved in a
construction project where
we were in mexico and the experts were
in boston and
literally we were trying to use video
chat and cameras it was it was okay but
this would have been better if we could
have had this augmented reality where we
would see and touch
and
communicate in real time as if we were
both looking at the same thing
and so that's a great solution obviously
you can't do that with a website only
health monitoring apps are a big
category and it seems like
android and apple and google and apple
have already
given us some great tools but
there's probably a niche available for
others so think of
gadgets that must plug into your phone
so in this case we're measuring the
oxygen
in your blood and you can't do that with
a camera you can't do it with just a
fingerprint sensor
so there's this physical device that
plugs into the phone
and as soon as you have a physical
device going through a usb cord or some
other communications
you're not going to do that with just a
website you're going to have a native
mobile app
and so i know that like credit card
swipers would be a good example of this
so people that are in a food truck are
going to be charging you with a credit
card not with a machine except for
except for their phone
so another infamous example it was the
company called theranos uh look them up
in the news they're another one of those
evil companies that i would refer to in
my my long-term memory
they had a plug-in item to a phone and
they claimed that they could replace an
entire laboratory with a drop of blood
on a microchip and the app would take
care of all of the tests and it was a
little bit of a over promise and a a lie
a straight lie and so the founder of
theranos is in trouble and in criminal
court because of her actions
so these are companies that have built
apps that are great examples of why you
need a mobile solution and not just a
website in this next video we're going
to talk about ways to create
cross-platform applications and so that
will reduce the amount of code that you
have to write if you'd like to see the
entire course playlist i'll put this
link up as well and make sure that you
subscribe so welcome to class and come
back for some more mobile application
development
[Music]
hi welcome to this course called
building mobile applications we're
talking about the business problems that
are associated with building mobile apps
in this video we are in part number five
which is right here about choosing the
right tools so we're going to be
focusing on choosing the right
development tools for a cross-platform
mobile solution if any of these other
topics are interesting to you make sure
you subscribe and come back to class
when these are available my name is shad
sluter and i teach software development
and computer science at grand canyon
university in phoenix arizona so let's
get started on our topic today so we are
talking about development choices that
are about cross platforms we've already
asked the question about should we build
a mobile app and then we've talked about
some companies that really nailed it
with a great solution that was mobile
and then now we're here on the cross
platform issues so let's get started on
examining what languages what tools
would work best for your company so
really there are three types of language
development tools that you can work with
when you're talking about mobile
development first of all there's native
code so this is the android studio this
is xcode with apple and so you're
creating code that is running
specifically for that phone also there
are ways to create web pages that are
called responsive design and so if
you're a good web developer you should
think mobile first and you might not
even have to create an app and the third
category the most involved here is
hybrid apps using technologies that were
originally designed for web pages but
we've adapted them to work on phones so
let's first of all talk about the native
apps so if you're going to work on an
apple or an ios phone you're going to
buy a macintosh computer and install
xcode this is the
platform for phones as well as tablets
xcode is like visual studio if you
worked with that before it's an
integrated development environment
also the languages that you can pick
from if you're developing a native for
apple you're going to work with
objective c or swift now swift looks a
lot like you would expect in javascript
or java objective c
well it looks like nothing else
maybe cobalt i'm not sure but objective
c is certainly out of favor for most
developers these days now if you're
working with android you're going to be
building a native app as well and their
program that is for developing apps is
called android studio so android studio
looks kind of like xcode where you have
layouts and then you have coding
sections the languages that you're going
to be working with are going to be
either java or kotlin and so java of
course is super popular it seems like
developers have been working on java for
decades and so if you've got java skills
then you're ready to go with android
with
learning how the libraries of course
work but you're ready to program now
kotlin came along just a few years ago
and apparently it is more efficient you
get right you shorter code and it's
developed specifically for android so
the disadvantage obviously is you have
to learn a new language if you're
developing in android now what are the
advantages of choosing a native app over
some of the other technologies that
we're going to show later
so first of all if you want to have the
best user experience possible for your
app then pick native it's going to run
and look like you expect an app to run
it's a real app it's not some kind of a
clutch now the next one that you might
say is not necessarily how the app looks
but it's how apple and google treat you
they can tell when you submit an app to
the store of how how it was built what
platforms did it run on and i've been
told you get a better
rating you get higher reviews and more
likely to be promoted on their store
they want users to have good experiences
however the disadvantages are pretty big
too so
if you are a developer and you're
building in native apps you'll have to
learn multiple programming languages so
for some of you that's not a problem
you've already got your languages in web
development or other app development and
you're ready to just adapt them to
android so if you've already figured out
how to program in java
you're ready to go for most of the
skills that you'll need for android and
of course swift is very much like either
of those languages so you're probably
not going to be choking on that however
if you are a brand new developer if you
don't really know how to code yet you
want to build a web app the native apps
will be the hardest choice of the three
so a big problem that businesses seem to
face when they're developing native apps
is that they're actually creating double
the work
for one app you have to create an
android version and you have to create
an ios version
and that sounds easy if all you're doing
is creating a simple app however apps
can be complicated and require lots of
planning so you're going to have to
design your app twice you're going to
have to build
two different testing plans for it
you're going to have to deploy to do two
different platforms you might have two
development teams that are working on
individual parts of your app
and also you have to maintain your apps
so when things change on your phone you
grow up to new versions your app is
going to have to be modified as well and
so it is double the work of just
creating a single platform app so the
second way that you can think of when
you're trying to serve your mobile users
is just to not build an app at all
just pick a web page design that is
responsive
so i think almost every web page out
there these days is using mobile first
in their design so you look at a page
and you on your phone and you notice it
looks different than the one that you
see on your laptop and your tablet is
somewhere in between these are
common web technology
design patterns that front-end designers
use these days and so
it's not really an app
but it serves the same purpose as maybe
what an app would do your business has
to connect to customers and
make your page do both
mobile and web and you've got yourself a
solution so what are the advantages for
just using web for mobile well obviously
you don't have any extra coding you
don't have to figure out how to create a
mobile version of your company app you
just make your web page function for
them all also it's somewhat simpler to
just create your web page so
html and javascript might all all be
what your your web page has involved
with so i know that most web pages have
java and c-sharp or php or ruby or some
kind of a back end that is really doing
the the server work and of course
that i wouldn't want to discount your
development there
but you don't have to worry about
compiling a web app to you and you don't
have to worry about publishing it to a
store or promoting it you just make sure
that it has good google results or your
typical web page seo and you're ready to
make your mark so what's the
disadvantage of using just pure web
pages well apps work better
on phones they can a web page can be
slow
and obviously it's not available offline
so if your mobile users are out of range
which they frequently are your web page
just won't work
so you're also missing out on an
opportunity to promote your company if
all you create is a web page
the app store gives you visibility you
can attract visibility you can attract
customers you can get attention if your
app does well in the web store or the
app store
also
web pages don't do everything that you
can with a mobile app so think of using
your camera your gps your accelerometer
and things that are more
native and you will not probably get as
good of an experience if all you do is a
web page
now the third category brings us into
kind of a middle ground between those
it's called the hybrid apps there are
three ways to create a hybrid app the
first one we're going to look at is a
web view the second is compiling an app
that will be cross platform compatible
and the third is using something called
javascript core using javascript to
create native apps and so let's take a
look at these together
first of all if you're thinking about a
webview app the technology that's
probably at the core of this experience
is called cordova apache cordova is an
open source project and you can see from
the diagram that it takes the usual web
page using html css and javascript and
then it does its little black box
conversion and poof out comes an app
that you can put on the web store it
runs on apple it runs on
android and what's that other thing
there that square some kind of another
third mobile tool i guess i'm not sure
what that platform is but you can make
your cross platform app using just your
web technologies so the advantages of
working with that are that it's simple
if you're already a web developer then
apache cordova will make your app
out of the code that you've already
built and there's only one code base so
you create one app and it will compile
to any of the platforms that are out
there you can publish your app to the
app store however it's not going to be
as maybe popular as the native apps you
don't have to have an apple computer by
the way i think that should be said that
if you're if you're programming in ios
you're probably going to have to well
you have to have a macintosh to run
xcode
so what are the disadvantages
well
web view apps
look like web pages and they're just
trapped inside a picture frame and so
they will work offline but they look and
feel like a web page so you're kind of
cheating really when you're building a
kind of an app
here's an innovative technology this
company called xamarin has built a nice
niche for themselves
they will take a c-sharp program
written in visual studio
and compile it to work with native apps
so it doesn't use java it doesn't use
kotlin it doesn't use swift or what's
the other objective c it uses c sharp a
microsoft technology a microsoft
language and compiles into the native
app that you're looking for
so you have one code base to work with
and you have just one language to work
with so the advantages are pretty good
so think of you're creating native apps
you're not trying to shortcut anything
and you have used only one code base
that's probably the biggest reason that
people would use xamarin is that they
only have one version of their app that
they have to compile
so they keep track of all the errors in
one place do all the testing in one
place and do all the design in one place
just one code base it's a great
advantage and then of course it's one
language so c-sharp is a very popular
language
professional developers use c-sharp for
everything and so corporations have
already got a good army of developers
that can develop a web app or i'm sorry
a mobile app using the language they
already know
there's one disadvantage that i can
think of is that xamarin apps compile
somewhat larger sometimes double the
size of a regular native app
that has to do with something of how the
runtime libraries are attached to the
app
but xamarin is a good choice and it
might work out for you if you're already
a c-sharp developer or your company uses
c-sharp as other apps
now javascript code is the third type of
hybrid that we looked at here or we're
going to look at and really there's only
one big name you have to worry about
it's called react native so react is a
framework that is used to create web
pages it's super popular it seems to be
like everyone's using react these days
it's really javascript with some extra
twists in it and it creates these super
fast responsive web pages that are
updated in partial manners it's it's
really the best way these days to create
a web app that with angular those seem
to be the two types of web app
technologies but we take react from the
web world and now we have adapted it to
the
native experience in a app design
so it will not just
render react will render objects to a
screen you know like forms and buttons
and things
but you can use the same technology to
render native controls to the screen
so
react dom is what you would use with
when you're trying to create a web app
react native is what you use when you're
trying to
compile for a phone
so the advantages of react native are
that you use the same skills again that
you did as a web developer so if you're
a web developer using react you're ready
to go and you're ready to learn how to
use react native for mobile
also you have a single code base again
you only have one version of your app to
test and to deploy and so react native
is a great choice for crops across
platforms
and the key is that the native app
performance is there the apps are really
indistinguishable from the native apps
even though they're written in
javascript and so it's a great bunch of
advantages and so for the disadvantages
well i really couldn't think of any if
you're already developing in in c-sharp
with xamarin and just keep going with
that or if you're working with java and
android maybe you're fine but a lot of
people are saying uh i've already got
web development experience how do i get
into mobile well react native is your
best choice that's the easiest step for
you as a web developer to get into
mobile developments
there's also another category that you
could think of is that game engines such
as unity and unreal really the two main
competitors in this in this market are
both able to export their projects to
both android and ios
and so you can think of there are
multiple platforms you can export to an
xbox or to a playstation but android and
ios are mobile platforms that they can
work with but game engines are not just
for games either if you want to create a
virtual reality application or an
augmented reality applications for
training purposes or for some kind of a
advertisement
then
unreal and unity are probably going to
work better than trying to build that
app
on android studio or something like that
so game engines aren't just for games
and they work great with mobile now
before i end here i want to mention two
other technologies that are emerging or
at least they're somewhat popular first
of all kotlin is the language that
google prefers instead of java and they
have a version now called kmm or kotlin
multi-platform mobile and the idea here
is that you create the majority of your
application in the kotlin language and
then you rely on the front end
differences between ios and android
and so this is fairly new in 2021 i
believe and so honestly i don't know
much about it other than the fact that
it exists and google is pushing it hard
now you would think that google has
their mind made up on what their
multi-platform solution is but check it
out here so if you go to flutter.dev you
have create faster apps and all this
stuff and look it's also made by google
and so flutter is a framework that uses
the language called dart
and its purpose is to create these
multi-platform language uh
apps as well
and so both of these i've seen great
reviews from people out there that are
more knowledgeable about this stuff than
i am but i certainly have my own doubts
in my mind is
what does google think i mean they have
two solutions and they're promoting both
of them and they both try to accomplish
it looks like the same thing
so
those are probably interesting uh
questions to ask
let me give you an experiment here so
i'm going to open up indeed and type in
the word flutter and you're going to see
that there are
literally seven jobs
seven jobs
and some of them are about react native
so this tells me that
i wouldn't recommend this solution for a
business that's going to depend on a
technology that literally hardly anyone
uses now compare this with what if we
put in react
native and i'm still in the phoenix area
what comes up we have 65 jobs so that's
literally a 10 times amount of mobile
development talent that's out there
let's see what cmm looks like we're not
going to get a single result so this is
telling you what is not available people
don't use this yet and this is 2021 when
you're making this video so let's just
search for web developer to get a
context of what this compares with right
now so there are 399 jobs in the
category of web developer of course
that's going to be
a lot of different technologies but you
can see that mobile is kind of a niche
and then a smaller niche than that is
going to be react native and then
minuscule is
going to be dart and flutter and then
even smaller is kmm so
take that for what it's worth if i were
the business leader i would probably not
go for these technologies where you
literally cannot find any job postings
let's just do one more search here i'm
going to search for mobile developer and
see what kind of technologies people
expect out there so
i'm going to find a
company that i recognize here so
u-haul okay u-haul is headquartered here
in phoenix let's check out what their
requirements are what kind of mobile
technology and platform are they up to
okay this tells you what we want
so android development they want android
and they say java how about that so
they're not using the most up-to-date
language let's go and check to see what
some of the keywords are in their job
description so it says here
object oriented we're going to do mvvm
mvc so those are design things
android networking such as rest services
and i don't see anything here about
cross-platform it says here native
applications so they're not even
interested in
cross-platform compiling so i would
recommend that you do some searching
around and see what other companies in
your area are looking at
u-haul might be an exception here but i
doubt it i think that a lot of people
just
don't do the cross-platform solutions
they're just not meeting their needs
they're willing to spend the extra time
to get a native so looking at this you
can see that cross-platform solutions
are not the first thing that comes to
mind for some developers and it's
probably going to depend on who you
already have on your team
if you have expert
language skills in a certain area
or if you're willing to take a risk on
some new emerging technology
so that's going to be up to you and how
tolerant you are
for risk
in the next video we're going to be
talking about the back end and where you
store your data so that's really about
the full stack solution and if you want
to see the entire playlist for all of
the topics on the business of building
apps check out the other link and please
join me again for class and happy mobile
development
[Music]
hi and welcome to the business of
building applications this is a course
for people who are business designers
and working with mobile apps we're in
chapter five in this section here called
choosing the right tools and in this
video i'm giving you an assignment so
we'll call this activity 5-1
and so in this activity what i want you
to do is to make a comparison of the
current available dev tools so we're
talking about languages and frameworks
and cross-platform and all of the other
solutions that i've mentioned in a
previous video in this course
so the background is that you will
create a comparison with the
applications and the languages and the
frameworks that go along with them what
i want you to do is to identify what you
think are the advantages or the
disadvantages of each of them and so for
a moment you can ignore the opinions
that i provided to you in the video and
come up with your own what i want you to
do is to do some searching go find out
the experts that are out there and so i
recommend a google search such as
search for xamarin versus react native
versus flutter versus kotlin
and you will likely discover some other
tools that i have not mentioned but
those kind of versus
search key terms are a great way to find
the blog articles that will help you out
so i want you to search for google
trends as well
trends.google.com i think it is
search stack overflow and look at their
annual surveys of developers look in
indeed or glassdoor or github and find
out what's going on in the world and
what the trends are for each of the
languages that you're considering
so these sources that i mentioned here
provide impartial data points and
statistics not just some person's blog
opinion
and so i want to know if the solutions
are mainstream which is means that
they're being used in the real world by
real businesses
so it's a good idea that you do a
limited search so
if you search for anything in that was
published in the last year you're
probably going to have some pretty good
up-to-date information so you don't want
to pull something from 2003
and because back then there was
obviously different requirements and
different trends
so read blogs read reddit threads and
get a variety of viewpoints and opinions
so this is a research project based not
on academic journals but on real
programmers
so when you're done i want you to
collect all of these viewpoints
and i want you to give me a summary in a
table that looks like this
so the first column is to tell me which
framework you're looking at
for instance we could put react native
in there
and then advantages so what makes react
native popular why do people love it
or why do people avoid this that's of
course the contrary how many people
are using this tool is react native
showing up in job search postings
or are people just dreaming about what
they think should be actually used and
then how long has this been around
because of course age doesn't
necessarily justify why a solution is
good
but if you're picking something that was
just invented yesterday then maybe it's
not quite ready for you to build your
business on it so if you're one of my
students this is what i would expect you
to send to me i want you to have a word
document with a table
and on that table you're going to have
all the development tools and describing
the benefits and the items that i just
showed you a second ago
so that would be a way for you to
summarize what you've learned
and i would grade you based on how
complete your table was how well you're
able to summarize what's out there and
look for some factual data points to
back up your opinions so if you're not
one of my students make sure that you
subscribe so that you can get the rest
of this course i will put a link to all
the playlists here so that way you can
see some of the lessons that i've built
and if you are one of my students i will
see you again
in the next class
[Music]
hi and welcome to the business of
building apps this is a course that is
supposed to make you a better designer
and app developer so we're in section 5
right now which is called choosing the
right tools if any of the other sections
look interesting to you make sure that
you check out the course playlist so
that you can get all of them in this
video we're talking about an assignment
so i'm giving you homework if you're one
of my students and we'll call it
activity 5-2
in this i'm going to ask you to provide
a recommendation for a development
solution so in a previous activity we've
created an app design we have an idea
for a business we've got some wireframes
we're ready to program but we're not
quite sure what languages we need to
work with in a previous assignment in a
previous video we compared several
different platforms whether they were
single platform or cross-platform
there's a lot of choices out there now
based on the recommendation that you
provide me i want you to think about the
facts that you discovered and provide an
application that fits your needs
so not necessarily the most popular one
in the world
but the one that affects you the most
so your team will have unique factors
that may lead to recommendations that
other teams do not have
for example you yourself are an expert
let's say
in
c sharp or maybe you have never
programmed before i'm not sure what your
factors are maybe the people that you
are working with already have something
in mind regardless there's going to be a
justification for why you choose a
certain programming language
and a certain development platform and
so really that's the goal of this
assignment so here are the instructions
i want you to write a one page document
word document's fine and i'm going to
ask you to
make a recommendation on which language
frameworks cloud services and databases
and other tools that you think would be
appropriate for your app
and
make sure that you provide a rationale
behind it and so that's why i would
grade a good
good paper versus a poor paper is based
on how well you're able to make the
application so you might recommend a
different solution than another student
but you probably have good reasons to so
here are the considerations
if you choose
a cross-platform solution it's probably
because you're trying to save money or
save time
make sure that that is actually true
before you make the recommendation so
don't just go
on what might be true but that provides
some evidence to make that
a real conclusion
also something might be brand new but
does that make it quote better
according to some people yes the newest
thing is best but businesses have to
support a product for many years
and so if something disappears
you don't want to be stuck with a
product that was abandoned by google
also this implies that you're able to
find employees that are able to come and
to leave and hire new people that can
come under your team so make sure that
you have something that is relatively
popular
a business can have significant
investments already so
sometimes it's better to follow your
company's direction that's already been
laid out for you so even though you
might be a java fan your company is
using something else so whatever it is
don't be
too different from what's already been
laid down so what i expect if you are my
students i would expect you to send me a
one-page document a recommendation for
which language and frameworks and
databases and cloud platforms that you
would provide why you would choose those
and the justification of course is a
business case so if you're not one of my
students you can put your own
recommendations in the bottom in the
comments below to tell me
why you prefer one platform or one
solution over another and if you're not
one of my students please subscribe so
that you can get in on the rest of the
course
now i will see you in the next class
if you are following along so thanks for
watching
hi and welcome to the business of
building mobile applications this is a
course that talks about some of the
issues that you're going to face if
you're trying to create an app and a
business that goes with it so you can
see there are several chapters that
we're going to be looking at here and we
are now on the section called full stack
considerations so if these previous
videos look interesting to you then go
back and look at the playlists and of
course please subscribe if this is
relevant to the types of projects that
you're working on right now here's the
other two that are coming up and i
welcome you to join my name is shad
slooter and i teach computer science and
software development at grand canyon
university so let's take a look at the
first topic here on this section called
choosing a database so this is really a
full stack consideration we looked at
the front end frameworks that you can
use for building mobile apps in a
previous video and now we're going to
talk about how you store your data so
we're going to divide this up into four
sections types of databases that you can
choose from each of these has its
advantages and disadvantages each were
designed to solve specific problems so
depending on the type of application
that you're trying to create you're
probably going to select one of these
four so we're going to talk about the
purpose of each of these
and how well they scale in other words
how they go from hundreds of users to
millions of users and which ones are
going to work well for you in the end
the first one that we're going to talk
about the first type of database is sql
now sql is the most common and the
oldest most established and wide known
type of language there is so sql is not
really a database it is called a
structured query language that's the
type of commands that you talk to the
database with
and so if you know any programmers that
have worked with databases at all they
will probably understand
these kind of commands so if you want to
select data from a database you do
something like this where you say select
the type of data that you want and you
tell it which table the data is stored
in and the computer will return a list
of data for you to put into your
application
so here is what it looks like in
visual studio and you are going to in
this case
we are going to create a table of
employees and insert some data into it
and so this is the interface that you
would look like if you were on a sql
server
also
sql servers have arrangements so they
put data into tables and they link those
tables with relations
and so a sql server is sometimes
referred to as a
relational database and so you can see
that in this case we have an order
system where each order is associated
with a customer and each product is
associated with each order and so
this is a very important part of the
design of an application if you haven't
taken a course on sql and databases then
i recommend you do
in the degrees that i teach where it's
computer science and software
development this is a fundamental class
that we do early in this in the students
career
and we use sql databases throughout all
of the applications that we create in
their experience and so you likely will
do the same thing in your job if you are
a software developer so here are some
popular titles mysql is the first of the
category here it is free it's open
source it's used by pretty much
everybody and we use it in our classes
as our primary database postgres has a
few more features and people that use it
really say they love it
microsoft sql server is also used in our
courses
and of course microsoft is a major
player in any software development
oracle was the major giant that started
the whole
corporate database structure and people
kind of loved to hate oracle but it's
still used by large businesses
everywhere
the next type of server that we're going
to talk about is the nosql server now
nosql
also refers to not only sql so it's not
just the opposite of sql
the most common way that you would
create a nosql database is to store your
data in documents now this is an example
of a document of a user
and if it looks like a json text file
that's because it is and so that's the
way nosql documents are are structured
you have properties and then you have
values that go along with them so
there's no tables there's no joins going
on here it's very simple
and so there's a few advantages to that
and also some drawbacks here is a second
one we have user of susan and the first
one was mortiver now you notice the
difference here
is that not all of the data is the same
so in this case with susan you notice
that we are able to have a status called
active and it's a boolean value of true
so in a
sql statement you have to fill in all of
the data for all of your users the
columns are very closely defined they're
static they are
very restricted which makes the computer
work well with it but sometimes your
business problems change and so nosql
databases allow you some more
flexibility so you can have different
types in this case we have vicky a third
user and you notice we don't have very
much data on her at all now we could add
that data later or we could delete data
from her but the idea here is that a
nosql document is more flexible here's
what a sql statement looks like or a
select statement i should call it a
select statement in a nosql database so
we have
db.users.find and then we put in another
json object and the results come back
and look something like this so this is
an example from a mongodb database
and you can see that the results are
easily translated into a web server or
any kind of a application that can parse
json here's another example we're trying
to do a query from a list of users and
so you can see that there are a variety
of pieces of data in the user object
from strings to integers to booleans to
arrays so
nosql is very flexible in the type of
data that you throw at it and it works
very fast if you're just going to read
and write lists of data
so let's compare these two different
types of technologies so this is a
structure of a sql database on the left
you can see that a database is composed
of tables each table is made up of rows
and each row has multiple columns in it
so that is a correspondence to a
document database where we have the
whole thing which is a database
each table represents a document
collection so
for instance in the tables of your
database you might have a collection of
users
well we still have a collection of users
in a nosql database the rows represent
each
user
and so in the collection each user is a
document
and then for each column such as the
name id age weight serial number or
whatever properties you wish to assign
to a user you're going to have those
referred to as fields
in a nosql database and so the two
components are both there they're just
organized and named slightly differently
let's also talk about the contrast here
between a sql database and a nosql
database in some of the design
so as i mentioned nosql databases are
very flexible you can change them later
but in sql you have to think about many
of the decisions that your application
is going to need
right up front and that's a process
called normalization or a normalized
database
so you have relations between tables and
the advantage of a sql database is that
you don't duplicate any data
if you have a user's table there's only
going to be one place where the user
name is stored and the age and his id
number and and so forth and so there's
no danger that you're going to have
duplicate records of a single user and
so you're guaranteed to have good data
so a sql database will never have
duplicate data if it's designed right
now on the other hand on the other side
we have denormalized data when we talk
about a document or a nosql database
we're going to be talking about lists
and you're going to have a lot of data
duplication so the amount of storage
space is going to be larger
but that that disadvantage then turns
into advantages when we come to the
number of seconds it takes to
run a query let's do an example here so
let's say we have a blog application
where like an instagram people post a
picture and then they put a comment
and then afterwards we hope that other
people come and rate your photo and put
comments on it and then you can reply to
them and you have a whole comment thread
and then maybe later someone else
comments again so a pretty typical
example of a social media app now would
this be easy to develop in a sql
database or a nosql database
well we actually do this in one of our
classes we create a blog app and we use
a sql database but let me give you some
suggestions here of maybe why or why not
this is a good idea so let's take a look
at if we had this data for our blog app
and we had it in the the data was stored
in a sql table format so i have a users
table here on the left you can see
there's an id number for each user and a
name
on the right side we have the comments
table and so each comment has an id
number and it's associated with a link
on the id number of the user we have the
date and the text so if we say i want to
get all of the comments for a particular
photo i would write a statement that
looks like this so this is a sql
statement that says i'm going to select
or i'm going to pull out the data from
two different tables and you can see i
have a mixture of table names so i have
the comments table and the users table
then i'm going to join them
and i join them on a common number so
you can see that the id number of jerry
is a thousand two
and over in the comments table you can
see that there's a user id number for
that comment which is also
a thousand and two so we know that jerry
is the person that posted this first
comment and so we're going to pull these
two together when you're done you're
going to have a joined list so this this
table here is a generated table it
doesn't get stored anywhere it's just
created every time we want to pull data
from the database
and so then this is produced
in a nice sequential format that we can
use our in our application to print to
our web page
so the pulling together is called
joining so i'm going to pull together
the id number from one table i'm going
to pull the name from the other table
i'm going to pull the date and the text
so
joining tables literally means reading
twice we're going to read from the users
table we're going to read from the
comments table we're going to create a
list in the computer's memory and then
provide that to the application
so you can see that the strategy here
will will create a more cpu time all
these joins require processing but we
only save the data in one location so we
save on disk space
now let's go back to the same blog app
and let's see how it might be designed
and implemented using a nosql database
so it's the same comments we got a photo
and we've got a bunch of comments
so here's what the data would look like
so first of all in our database we would
have likely a list of users
and so you can see a bunch of json
objects it's the same data but now
stored in a json format now what are we
going to do for the comments we're going
to produce maybe another collection
called images the images will have each
image will have an id number and
probably a string to tell us which photo
is saved to the disk and following the
image id we're going to have the
comments and so you can see that the
comments is a list of lists of no more
json objects
so each list is going to have some
duplicate data you notice the word or
the name gwen
appears twice in here so we're saving
gwen's name into the comments now that's
a horrible misuse of the normalization
rules that most students learn in sql
programming and so we're breaking rules
we're duplicating the name gwen
however
there is an advantage for doing that
because when we go back to the
application we don't have to do any
joins we can just say
read the list sequentially there's no
computing to do just read and print
and so
that makes it very fast
now the disadvantage is let's say gwen
changes her username
now gwen has been printed in her
database
let's see twice here it could be a
million times
we would have to programmatically go
back and search for all of that
duplicated data and rename gwen to her
new username so that's a bad thing
obviously so read sequentially is fast
duplicating data
saves time on the cpu but it requires
extra programming and oversight to make
sure that your data is in a good format
so let's compare these two here because
these are the two most common database
technologies that you're likely going to
choose from
so sql is what we would call structured
if you know what your data is going to
look like then sql is a good choice if
you're not quite sure what your data is
going to look like then nosql is a more
flexible alternative
sql databases are more difficult to
scale and we'll talk about scaling here
in a minute but scaling means going from
your first hundred users to the first
million users or records or whatever it
is so a large database is more difficult
to handle in a sql server
also we have the i've mentioned no
duplication of data
so only one copy of each record is
stored in the database which makes it
easy to keep track of
what the username is for example you can
change data in one location in one
location only
so that's very consistent
if you have
a lot of updates going on and let's say
you're changing records
and you have only one copy of that
record
then obviously it's a one-time operation
if you change a piece of data that is
duplicated a million times in other
locations
every time you do an update it's going
to be thousands or millions of updates
each time the user
creates a change sql sql databases are
very good if you have lots of uh joins
going on to say i want to collect a
little bit of data from this table that
data merge them together and create a
new list and no sql is not so much in as
far as the document store goes and so
why would you want to choose nosql then
well it's faster
you can also scale it largely and it's
really quick if you're just doing a lot
of reads and so
you're going to have to analyze your
business process and your application to
decide which type of technology fits
better so
rule of thumb the default in my choice
maybe it's just because i'm old but sql
is the first choice and if you can't use
it with sql then you go find an
alternative and i have some data maybe
to show why that is a good way to think
here are two popular nosql databases
these are the document store databases
so mongodb by far is the most popular
firebase by google is used as a
real-time database which has some other
advantages so if you are
looking at a database your application
automatically triggers every time
there's new data coming in and so it's
some things that you really can't do
without uh doing a lot of programming
loops let's talk about another database
called a graph database it's a different
type of feel altogether so if you're if
you've taken any courses in
algorithms and data structures a graph
is a perfect way to model a lot of data
so on a graph you have things called
nodes so each node kind of represents a
record so let's say we have a node
called a person and we'll give that the
term the label so this node is a person
the properties of a node are just like
the columns in a in a table so we can
say that gene in age 39 is this person
so you could imagine lots of different
properties going on now we have
different types of nodes so let's make a
application that keeps track of movies
and who likes the movies so in this case
we have a purple node that says the name
of this node is star wars so
we can then put relationships between
those
so this person
likes the movie star wars since the year
2021.
so that's a relationship so there's
three pieces of data here not just two
the
the link itself is another record so it
keeps track of either a one-way link or
you can have a two-way link
well then let's take a look at the idea
of linking these because in a sql
database we already have relations we
have
links between tables
that's what it means it's a relational
database so it works well if you only
have to worry about one
one depth of your relationship
selects like for instance
this user
created this list of comments perfect
it's a one
depth one step depth of relationships
and so there's no reason to create a
graph database if that's all you're
doing
however if you have more indirect
relationships
like you want to know
in a movie
how many people
were actors and then you can also ask
and the actors how many different movies
were they in
and then you could start to get more
complex to say
did they like their experience who liked
the
who liked being in the movie which
actors
did not like the movie but were not in
the in the in the actors list and so
when you start to get these
multiple questions about who was where
and what they liked and who's related to
who and then
who are your friends of your friends
then you start to get very complex
and that's when a graph database starts
to make sense
so here's an example of some real we'll
call it empirical data
so neo4j
is a graph database it's the most
popular i believe
and here is an experiment that was made
some years ago
so we have a depth of queries going on
here so you can see in the left column
we have depth of 2 3 4 and 5.
so the depth means
who is a friend of a friend
so that's that's what we're asking here
but now when we get to the six degrees
of separation kind of a question is who
is the friend of a friend of your
friends of your friends of your friends
and now your
traditional database
is no longer a good solution so you can
see that they asked that question who
are your friends friends friends friends
friends
and
where do we go for the time computation
well you start making joins
in other joins and stacking on top of
other joins and you can see that sql has
an exponential time
frame here
and so by the time we had the depth of
asking who are your fifth degree friends
uh the mysql database didn't even finish
its computation in an hour of work
now compare this to the graph database
neo4 and you can see that it is a very
fast linear
time requirement and so literally in two
seconds they could ask to the fifth
degree
who your friends are and so same
computing platform same amount of memory
and all that
and so the algorithm itself of how the
database is designed
is
superior when it comes to that kind of a
question
so if you have a social media type of
application that has these strange
queries that can ask about relationships
and very flexible types of
questions
then maybe neo4 or other graph database
technologies is for you
now this is obviously the suitable
solution for this kind of a situation so
we have friends with and who likes who
you can see the graph going on here so
if you have many relationships between
records and you're going to be asking
questions on a regular basis
for instance facebook
how in the world can you
recommend
friends when you have friends of friends
going on then this is probably the the
right tool for you so let's take a look
at linkedin for example here this is an
image that is about types and the
relationships on linkedin
and to me this is just asking for a
graph database solution because as you
can see the profile has
different groups different companies
companies that you like companies you
follow
and so they're able to provide job
recommendations to you based on what's
in your
resume and then who who you like and
where you follow so this would be very
difficult to compute if you were using a
standard sql database so here are two
recommendations if you're interested in
looking at more about this
so neo4j seems to be the market leader
but i'm going to put azure cosmos
because it's a microsoft tool that is
used on the cloud the azure
cloud service and so they're going to be
pushing that if you're using their
service here's another kind of database
called the full text database
now full text sounds exactly like you'd
expect for a search engine
so let's say you're google and you're
trying to index every page on the
internet and somehow when you type in a
keyword search they give you instant
results
so what they do is they have this
inverted index set up so for instance if
i'm looking for the word fantastic i
don't have to go search through the
entire collection of documents that was
already done for me instead i get search
results that are based on document
numbers and so i will have a list here
of document 1 4 99 284 and 9 42. those
are the
documents that contain the word
fantastic and of course you can probably
wait that with
better search results by pushing those
numbers around based on the number of
times the word fantastic was used or
whether it was used in the title or
whether in the body of the text you get
the idea so that you have an index of
where the words are in your documents
and that works exactly like the index
that you find in the back of any
textbook you're looking for a specific
term the index will tell you which page
number it is on so that is like the
google search of your book it tells you
where you will find the terms that are
most valued to you so a full text index
is going to be the kind of solution if
that's the problem you're you're facing
so elastic and splunk are two database
technologies that you should explore if
that's your kind of a problem
now the next section here is how are you
going to scale your database from your
first 100 users to the millions of users
that you're likely to encounter
so let's start with an example here a
very concrete example of kevin systrom
who is the co-founder of instagram let's
hear what he says about his app and
before you knew it we actually had
overloaded our system and it was a very
small naive system it was a single
computer and a co-location space
somewhere in la everything was on one
computer yeah it was it was nothing more
exhilarating than seeing all those
people streaming and nothing more
crushing than than seeing you know
people posting on twitter or on their
blogs and saying like oh another startup
that doesn't know how to scale like oh
like so clowny we were both i mean at
that point like running on zero sleep
for two days just devastated and i was
like this is it we built this great
thing and we totally messed it up
so if you get so lucky that you're going
to have an instagram-like problem then
you're going to have to do some
solutions so i looked up to see what
kind of technology what databases that
are being used in instagram they started
off obviously with a small server and
they have since completely redesigned
their app and so you can see that their
technology that they're still relying on
is a sql database and cassandra which is
kind of like a mongodb it's a document
storage and it's allowing them to have
both relations and the ability to scale
horizontally now let's talk about your
goals here your short-term goals if you
are building a startup and your first
version of your app you're probably only
going to need to worry about your
minimal viable product and so scaling is
something to think about down the road
but right now you are interested in
proving the concept does your
application appeal to users and so
you're only going to have to talk about
a hundred or thousand people for your
first version your working version needs
to be something that literally just
works and so scaling is important to
think about but not to invest too much
time now
build your first version as a rather
simple architecture we're trying to get
something put together quite quickly
fast development and so don't worry
about the scale yet
i mean it's not a bad idea to think
about how it's going to scale
but don't scale it scaling now is much
easier than it was 10 years ago
so you can at least plan for it but you
don't have to make your first version
scalable now here are some considering
considerations will your application
have unbounded growth
if you're building an internal app for a
company you know that your company has
five thousand employees and you'll never
see any more than that then obviously
there's no worry about unbounded growth
if you're just having a few records
however if you're collecting a terabyte
of data every day and adding it to your
database then you're going to have a
problem now we're going to scan or span
multiple servers if we have a scaling
issue so you need a technology that can
be split into pieces is there going to
be a high volume of transactions for
instance if you're creating a database
that has an iot device thing where
you're recording let's say the the
heartbeat and blood pressure of every
user every five minutes
your scale of volume is going to go
exponential and so yes you will have a
scaling problem
if you have those kind of issues then i
would recommend that you think about a
nosql solution because they scale much
easier and mongodb is the first to mine
one for in my categories when it comes
to a nosql solution so
when you talk about your mvp app you're
likely going to be thinking about maybe
some limited number small number of
records it doesn't have to be hyper fast
it can handle interruptions you can you
can shut it down to do backups for
example
your expertise you want the most common
solution available because you're going
to be hiring people and the usual first
to mind solution is my sequel so [ __ ]
and my sequel are the first two things
that come to mind as a matter of fact
those are the only two solutions really
that we focus in on our college students
so when i'm teaching new programmers how
to develop an app and they've never seen
a database before and they've never
written a query
really my sequel and microsoft server
are the two solutions that we work with
most of the time for sql and then [ __ ]
for a more
advanced we would call it maybe our
junior level or senior level students to
see something else besides sql and we
don't even branch off to be beyond those
two because they're very common and they
meet a lot of needs but let's talk about
scaling
let's say if you are trying to do
scaling you can have either two choices
one is called a vertical scale and the
other is a horizontal scale
so this is vertical scaling we start off
with a small server it says here we have
about a three thousand dollar computer
it has one terabyte of storage maximum
and we can handle about 500 concurrent
users before it starts to get slow
and so we invest three thousand dollars
and we host one server well then our
application
grows we have a constraint and so we
just buy a bigger server we add more
memory and more storage and a better cpu
and things work great but you can see
that the cost then is no longer three
thousand
it is fifty thousand dollars we have a
hard drive then we have multiple power
supplies it's a pretty nice server and
then the maximum server that we might be
able to afford is a million dollar
computer i guess we're getting into
small mainframe size here now and as you
know mainframes were built to handle
large amounts of data but there's a
limit to how big you can build that
mainframe
and so
that is vertical scaling and so you can
see that when we get to a certain size
we have to wait until a newer computer
is invented
our scaling and vertical format only
goes so far
and you notice the cost starts to
escalate too because
as you know when you buy a laptop
you can get twice the
processing and twice the storage but the
price isn't just twice it goes in an
exponential format so most of us buy
computers that are 80 percent of the
market maximum at the time because well
that's a reasonable cost
performance trade-off so just for kicks
i went to find out what the biggest
things that you can buy are right now so
what is the largest hard drive available
on
amazon so it looks to me like 16 or 18
terabytes is the maximum that western
digital is selling right now and what's
the cost here
a 16 terabyte hard drive right now is
600 and free shipping
now what if you want to get a bigger one
than that they actually create these
things called a raid set so raid stands
for redundant array of independent disks
and so there are multiple hard drives in
a box and so even though you might have
a 36 terabyte drive literally you're
getting multiple drives and so there's a
physical maximum that we have at any
point in history and history has always
told us that we can never get enough
storage space and so this particular
hard drive is 2 600
and so you can see the cost starts to
get kind of high
now there's a better way or a different
way let's call it of scaling so instead
of scaling by buying bigger machines we
can just buy more machines so that's
called horizontal scaling and that
requires some coordination
so we build a server and then we have a
server manager or sometimes called the
master server he's the traffic cop and
he controls what's going on the other
servers that are being controlled are
called slaves and so we have this master
slave relationship now if slavery
doesn't ring true to you then we've got
other terminology we'll call this the
conductor or the primary server or the
source server or the coordinator or the
traffic cop
anyway the idea is that we have somebody
who is managing the other servers and
those can be called followers or
secondary servers or replicas or nodes
so it depends on your type of
terminology but we have something that
is controlling other computers and so
that master server is obviously an
important piece in this scaling system
so you can see in the configuration i've
set up here i bought three servers
and they contain
two
servers that actually hold the data so
one server is used just to coordinate
things and the other two
hold the data so what does that do for
us well we could have multiple servers
that are the followers
and they all are controlled by the
master
now as you can see that the cost here
does not increase exponentially we don't
have a million dollar computer anywhere
in this list so we have seven computers
that are storing the data of six
so
we have one computer that is overhead
and the other ones that are actually
doing the work
now there is no technical barrier then
to the size that we can add so
we probably will find some number that
the master is able to control but that's
pretty big
so we could add a master computer that
is massive and then lots and lots of
small ones that are the followers and
that's when you get these server farms
we call them these data centers where
you have this hardware that's in the
shelf that is relatively inexpensive
it's completely
replaceable and you get the scale of
manufacturing to bring the price down
and so these data centers can be the
size of football fields and you put them
near a source of cheap electricity and
in a place where you're not going to
have earthquakes or floods
and you have literally data warehouses
for amazon or microsoft or google
humming away
now you have a problem so what happens
when one of these servers fails
obviously we don't want that to happen
we're going to start duplicating the
data then so let's say this server is
going to store a file maybe it's a large
file
we're going to then make some copies of
it so let's take three copies
and the master server is going to choose
three locations in our data farm where
it's going to put that so in this master
computer we're going to have it keep an
index
so the index looks like i'm using number
one three and five if we start counting
at zero then one three and five is the
location of this file
so why do we duplicate it well obviously
if one piece of hardware fails then we
want to have that
respond by maybe making another
duplicate somewhere else and so we have
some redundancy also think about how you
could read the data let's say file
server number one the first one here is
busy then we can read it from another
location and so the hard drives
never really get maxed out
as far as having an amount of traffic
now in practice what we also do is we we
take data and we split it up into blocks
so let's say we have a huge video file
and we don't want to store that all in
one location do we no we we create
segments so we split the file up maybe
into three pieces in this case and then
we make duplicates of that and now we
have nine pieces to spread around our
servers and so the segment can be put on
different servers so that way it's load
balanced the server can have a maximum
storage space and the cpu both shared
and then we take those segments and we
scatter them according to some algorithm
to the entire collection so now we have
two things going on we have
redundancy so one server can fail and
also we have the load balance so that no
one server has to do all the work so
let's take a look an example of a
failure tolerance so we have
three different servers that are all
serving a file now one of these has a
disk failure and it shuts down
and we've got a problem the alert then
is sent to the master traffic cop
and he says take this one offline
he looks in the index and says where do
i have this file well i see that it's
still stored in two locations so we're
good
now i'm going to take that file and i'm
going to duplicate it and put it on
another server so it selects one
according to its algorithm and now we're
back to three so the fault tolerance is
there to keep us well
now that works with files let's talk
about how you would be able to split up
something like a sql server
and to scale a server horizontally is
difficult
it's called shards so a shard is a way
to split up your data
so in this case let's talk about a
read-only shard
so a master shard is pictured here on
the left so we have a table of users
and we know that these users are going
to be updated very infrequently people
don't change their address very often
and the
application might read from those user
tables very frequently so every time we
create a new order we want to pull the
user data that's that's an example
so if read is the constraining action
then all we need to do is make
duplicates of each table and that's a
read-only shard
and so when a request to read a user
comes in
we can just get it from one of the
shards so let's say we have an example
of where we want to write data we have
an update or we add a record
now that is going to then replicate that
data to the shards and so that way we
have a
a way to spread it around now when we
have a read data we would have a
scheduler program and then we would
select one of the shards that is not
very busy
and give him that job and so then we
would read from one of those three now
replicating shards increases the data
base response time or the performance i
should say so if you're reading data
from a lot of different uh tables then
just spread those tables out make
replicas of them and then the least busy
will respond to your request
it's not very scalable for write
operations and so sharding is usually
thought of in a different way where we
split up data so let's go back to our
data set and we'll talk about how we
would shard this
when we have millions of rows
so your performance of your database is
suffering and you realize it's because
you just have so much data how are you
going to do it
so we're going to shard that so we we're
going to start with our entire data set
and we notice that there are ways that
we could split it up so in this
particular data set we can see that
there are 50 states in the united states
and we have roughly
spread the users across those 50 regions
so we could create a separate data
using a shard map so let's say we split
up the dates the states from 1 to 50 and
now we start to
split it up now in practice you can do a
range like this you can have a range of
zip codes for example or a range of
state names
we could also do a hash value so we
could hash a name and then
put them in a particular range based on
the hash results or you could come up
with your own scheme so somehow we want
to equitably distribute these around in
this case we're going to put everyone in
the iowa region in shard one and then
shard two we're going to make another
table called users and that will be for
the illinois people and then shard three
will hold all of our ohio
users
so now the data table
no longer exists in a single location
it's now spread over three servers so
theoretically each of those three now
can grow to the maximum size of hardware
that we're allowed to provide to it so
this here is our shard collection
so now when we have a read operation
who are we going to ask
well let's say we have a request that
comes in to say
where's wendy
i want to get all the records that are
associated with wendy so we ask our
master shard map
wendy
is located in illinois
which server do i need to ask
and the response is i found wendy in
illinois which is shard number two
okay so now i'm going to ask the same
question where's wendy and i'm going to
select all of the records associated
with wendy and i go to
shard2.userstable to get that data so
there's a two-step process in getting
data
now you can see that there's a lot of
programming going on here so we have
shards and we have
different load balancing techniques
there
so sql sharding we'll call it it does
allow the scaling of horizontal
growth we can add servers
it requires extra programming and some
extra requests that go on with the
process
so here are two solutions for mysql
galera cluster is a
sql mysql solution for sharding data so
you don't have to do all the computing
yourself and then
i think it was 2016 or so
where my sequel 8
now includes something called group
replication and so it does the same
process where you can shard different
things now in my opinion
that scaling a mysql database
is kind of like trying to squeeze a
square peg into a round hole mongodb was
designed originally to scale
horizontally it's very easy to split up
a document
you don't have to worry about fragments
being
separated
and so even though sharding works with
sql
it wasn't designed to work that way in
the beginning and so perhaps not the
best design in the long run so now it's
your decision time so i'm going to
present you basically with two different
solutions you can choose a sql solution
and then you can also pick from a nosql
those are really the dividing lines so
what are the factors there so consider
first of all what you already have in
your organization
are are you already using sql in many of
your other projects
maybe it's a good idea just to continue
on with sql
almost everybody that programs in any
kind of database already knows sql
[ __ ] is a common skill
but it's not universal and so as i
mentioned at the university where i
teach everybody learns how to program in
sql and they do it pretty well
[ __ ] is something that we add on as a
second choice
and i wouldn't call them experts at
[ __ ] and that's probably common for a
lot of systems so the most common tools
that you can work with both of them are
free are either mysql or mongodb
now let's take a look at some practical
uh statistics from your area so i did
some indeed searching for
job postings in phoenix where i live
so i just typed in job postings that
have the keyword sql in it and you can
see that there were 1480 through 82 jobs
that referenced they want sql and so you
can see the first one says a java
developer not a surprise that you need
sql how about this searching for nosql
and the number of jobs that re reference
no sql drops to 253
and they still want a software developer
and nosql is apparently part of the job
description let's get specifically let's
talk about mongodb as a solution 116
jobs and then my sequel references 218
jobs so if you didn't catch all that
here is a graph that shows you or a
table that shows you all of these so you
can see that sql is a super common term
people are using it all the all the time
and everywhere and nosql is is not dead
i mean it's not insignificant but it's
certainly less and so if you wanted to
see that visually you can see that sql
is way ahead as the most common solution
that most people think of when they're
building software applications so when
it comes to cost though really it's not
a big deal almost every database
solution has a free option
linux servers means that you don't have
to pay licensing to microsoft however
your cloud hosting is going to be where
the cost hits you so the amount of
storage space and the amount of
computing power that's being used in the
cloud is going to affect you no matter
which of the solutions that you choose
uh at the beginning though remember that
if you're choosing single server
solutions you're probably going to be
okay for your first version of your mvp
now the next consideration that you
should think about is how you
communicate so
rest apis is an important topic that you
need to understand about building mobile
applications also if you'd like to see
the entire playlist for all of the
considerations of building apps then
i'll put that link here as well make
sure you subscribe and thank you for
joining me in class
[Music]
hi and welcome to the business of
building apps this is a course that is
designed for people who are doing
business case studies on application
development so we're in the part here
called full stack considerations which
is about choosing the right types of
storage so activity 6-1 is an assignment
so if you like homework then you've come
to the right video so in this i want you
to evaluate the various types of data
storage that are out there so we're
looking at database design so this
refers to sql or nosql databases or some
of the other now the background here is
that i've already given you a lesson on
the different types of databases that
are somewhat popular and so we can just
say that we know that various types
exist
so while they share the same goal of
storing and retrieving data each of
these different designs was solving a
different problem and so the goal here
is for you to be able to identify that
so as you go through the course readings
that i provided or the other videos that
i've made in this course that i want you
to research these categories of
databases so there's a relational
database
a document database sometimes called
nosql and then there's a graph database
and we pick search engine now there
might be others out there that you will
discover along the way because there are
certainly more than just four types of
databases so what i want you to do then
is to summarize what you understand
about each of these and so tell me the
strengths of each type and the
weaknesses and if you want to include
history about when they were developed
and who fixed who created them and what
they were trying to fix that would be
great too
provide examples of applications that
would be appropriate for each of these
types of databases of course they're
designed for some specific purpose and
then finally think of the app that
you're building or you're designing in
this course and i want you to then make
a recommendation for which database or
maybe a combination of databases would
work for the particular app that you're
working on so you have to understand how
these app or these databases are
designed and who they're supposed to
help and then make a choice on which one
would probably work for you so if you're
one of my students i would expect you to
submit this to me send me a word
document send me a paper that explains
the strengths and the weaknesses of each
data storage technology and so since
there are four different categories that
i've mentioned here i would expect at
least four four paragraphs probably an
introduction and a conclusion so then
the final is not only to tell me what
the four differences are but which one
you think is going to be probably
appropriate for your solution so if
you're not one of my students you feel
free to put anything in the comments
below that tells me about your
experience with these types of databases
which ones do you use that are somewhat
out of the ordinary do you have a strong
preference between my sequel or [ __ ]
for example and why would you choose
that so if you'd like to look at the
rest of the course i will provide a link
to the playlist here and if you're one
of my students i will see you soon in a
new class and if you're not a student
please subscribe and come back as well
thank you
[Music]
hi and welcome to the business of
building apps this is a course that's
about designing and running a business
with mobile applications we're in part
number six i believe which is the full
stack considerations and so we're
thinking about storage and online
services this is an assignment video so
if you like homework then you're at part
6.2 what are we going to do here i want
to make this assignment an exploration
of api services so apis or application
program interfaces or people might just
call them online services and so in a
previous video we talked about several
different things that were available
from google and microsoft
and we want to make sure that we're
aware of what things are out there we
don't have to reinvent the wheel in many
cases so apis provide data and
communications and computing for us for
example google maps is an api and you'd
be a fool to recreate an entire map
application since there's one already
available that you can just insert into
an existing app so what i want you to do
is to demonstrate that you understand
how they work and which ones would be
appropriate for your app so in a
previous video we've already designed an
app and now i want you to see if there's
some features that you can utilize and
make it better
so as i mentioned microsoft and google
have a lot of different apis that are
open
and free
and all you have to do is sign up and
configure them
so these services range from a variety
of things such as maps speech
recognition and artificial intelligence
so i'm not going to elaborate the entire
list because there are literally
hundreds of apis that companies like
microsoft and google are providing to us
so what i want you to do then is to
examine the app that we're building and
designing in this course
and see if there are any opportunities
for services that are out there that we
could utilize so write a one-page paper
with a recommendation for which if any
of the services the api services
would be appropriate for you to include
in your application
so make sure that you justify your
decision so i don't want you to choose
google maps just because you like maps
if your app has something to do with
maps then of course google maps makes
sense but don't pick an application just
because it's interesting make sure that
it satisfies or supports one of your
business goals
so if you're one of my students this is
what i would expect you to send me i
would expect a word document that's
probably about one page and it would
list any of the services that you would
find useful on google or microsoft or
some other similar service and why they
would be appropriate to integrate into
your application so if you're not one of
my students then feel free to leave in
the comments below which apis have been
useful for you in your apps if you'd
like to see the entire course playlist i
will provide a link to that so that you
can see some of the videos about the
business of building apps
and make sure you subscribe if you
haven't because this could be useful
information to you if you're an app
developer so thanks for watching
[Music]
hi welcome to the business of building
applications this is a course for
managers who are trying to create
applications in the mobile platforms so
the chapters that we've covered so far
in this course include all of these
topics that you see on the screen in
this video we're talking about hiring
the team and so we're going to be
talking about development roles
if any of these topics look interesting
to you make sure you subscribe and also
go back and check the playlist for this
course my name is chad slooter and i
teach computer science and software
development at grand canyon university
so welcome to class and i'm glad you're
here now we're going to talk about dev
roles mobile development in particular
and so we're going to talk about forming
a team
and presuming that you are going to be
probably in the hiring role manager or
if you're the startup founder who are
the people that you were going to want
to work with you so you're going to have
these four here you'll have a product
manager a designer a front-end developer
a back-end developer and there could be
more roles but we're trying to keep it
small here to save some expenses so
we're going to focus on these four now
you don't necessarily have to have four
people you might have just you and you
have to do all the roles or you might
find some people that can do multiple
things
hopefully you can and then you can save
some money so let's talk with the first
one here a product manager so a product
manager is probably somebody that's got
some senior skills they've done this
before it's not their first application
so their goals are pretty much this
number one they have to figure out what
problem they're trying to solve and so
this famous picture here about the
project and what it was described as
what it was implemented as and then
finally what the person wanted
is the tire swing so if you haven't
figured it out yet most of the videos in
this course are for you the project
manager or the product manager and your
goal is to do some of these things
figure out what has to be done the
second thing that a product manager has
to do is execute make sure that we have
a plan we know what things we're working
on first which ones are most important
what the users want what the users
should not see and we'll move this plan
forward also we're going to measure our
success and this pretty much works with
testing out our application with our
users our focus groups and our early
adopters and then we're going to modify
our goals so everything in this course
so far has been pretty much a product
manager's kind of work so look back at
the chapters in the playlist and to see
what your job is
so i did a quick search and picked out
one of the roles that was advertised
currently here i live in phoenix arizona
and aaa was one of the items that came
up when i searched for
a pm or a product manager so what do you
have to do well here's what they say so
you have to ma manage and monitor for
defects uh
monitor
enhancements to existing systems
identify customer needs uh solicit input
meets commitments made to customers in
other words you have all the
responsibility but you don't do the work
yourself you direct a team you get the
resources applied to it and you know
what's going on and you make sure that
you get the resources applied to what
you want to do so what do you have to
have well they want a college degree it
looks like
they pick five years plus experience so
you know their product manager is not
going to be the first thing that you do
out of college
you're going to be scrum certified so
you're looking at looking
managing teams sprints
you're doing the agile software
development kind of a role
and then it also says that we want uh
expertise and sql and proficiency and
programming so they want a experienced
developer that now is stepping into the
manager rules so this is probably your
most senior member of the team now let's
take take a look at the next item that
identified as one of your team members
is your product
designer so a product designer is going
to be the person that makes your product
look really good obviously and so user
interface is the first thing that comes
to mind when it comes to a product
designer this is a person that has some
artistic talent maybe has a degree in
product design maybe a degree in fine
arts the second thing is called user
experience and there's a slight
difference there so the user interface
is what it looks like the user
experience is how a product acts and and
feels to the customer so
navigation as you can see what's being
drawn here is the logical flow of how
you get through an app but user
experience can be broader than just what
you see on the mobile app so for
instance the last time you ordered
anything through amazon you had a user
experience
your user experience was that the app
worked well you clicked buy
and somebody
really hustled hard to get that product
to your door they rang the doorbell and
by the next day you were happy and if
you didn't like the product you could
return it without any cost all of that
is a user experience so it's not just
the bits and bytes on your app it's the
process of how the business works and so
user experience of course is a pretty
critical item if you want to keep your
customers
so what is a qualification for somebody
who is a designer so
not just user experience but we're
focused in here on on more of the
designer people so you can see their
goals
according to peterson technology
partners here in chandler arizona
they're looking currently for a designer
and they want this person to create
storyboards and wireframes and user flow
diagrams create prototypes and
interactive designs sounds a lot like
what we did in earlier activity in this
course
also we're going to be thinking about
thinking methods to construct concepts
that can be tested and validated with
users
so remember in a previous edition of
this course or the previous lesson in
this course we talked about finding the
niche for your product you build
something you show it to your users
and if they don't really care about it
or they don't care for it then you don't
include it so this is what they mean by
testing out your hypothesis with a group
of
potential users
actively participating in discussions
and workshops with key
key stakeholders so the point here is
that the design is a pretty early part
of the process of building a product and
crappy designs
just make a horrible first impression so
whether you have a full-time designer or
you purchase the services of an of a
contractor a designer's an important
part of your job
so here's some qualifications that they
say let's get a bachelor's degree they
didn't mention what kind of a degree but
where i work at the university grand
canyon university
we have an entire degree called
web design
and they are artists firsts
and programmers second and so i've
actually taught some of those courses
it's
pretty interesting when i asked my
students to pull out a piece of paper
and
draw some diagrams
i expected like most of my courses that
i've taught before that like in math or
in programming
people might have a pencil might not
have a pencil well these designers not
only had a piece of paper it was a it
was a tablet a square tablet of high
quality drawing paper they had a dozen
pencils of different shades of gray and
of course colors they had rulers and
protractors and
the work they did was three-dimensional
and shaded it was it was like if that is
your approach to
taking notes or making a concept come to
your mind then you're probably a
designer
most of the time though i'm teaching
courses on
how to manage database connections and
how to do encryption and security and
and honestly friends in my course you
know who you are
you can't even draw a square with right
angles so
there's a skill here
for people who have this innate artistic
talent and they like to use technology
so some of the technology that you'll be
working with of course is css which is a
design language
sas
is a kind of a quasi language that helps
you better with css
adobe products such as photoshop and
illustrator are probably things that you
have memorized and work with on a daily
basis
their experience level they're asking is
they want somebody that does some ui and
also ux which is the user experience and
so there are some qualifications for a
person that you want on your team now
we're going to have two developers here
we're going to split this role in the
front end and the back end so let's talk
about the front end so the front end is
probably somebody that is a javascript
expert they're going to be able to build
a webpage that looks nice you might call
it this you might call this person a
designer so your designer and front-end
developer might actually be the same
person so that's kind of typical i've
met a lot of designers that are very
good at programming in javascript so
there's certainly an overlap there and
so here's some of the tools that you'll
see front-end people working with css
javascript and then these two frameworks
angular and react seem to show up all
the time so pretty much you want to
react expert if you're looking for a
front-end developer now we're in mobile
systems here so what i put on the screen
applies to web development and somewhat
to mobile development so mobile
developers are going to be working with
the
framework of your choice and so
check out a previous video that i made
for how to pick the right framework
which will depend on who you hire then
for your front-end development so your
back-end developer this person is going
to be creating the logic the business
sense and the databases in the
background so you are probably going to
be able to pull this back end designer
or developer from other types of
programming so you don't have to be a
web a mobile developer per se to be a
back-end person you'll probably do
similar things
in other applications so front end is of
course the user interface and the back
end is how you manage the data so those
are the common splits now let's revisit
these developer roles so i've mentioned
four we have the product manager the
designer the front end and the back end
developers
however we've left out some things so
there are roles such as who's going to
test this thing so frequently you expect
your developers to be able to do their
own testing
that's a good thing if you're the
manager you're going to ask those
questions in an interview
not only can you write code but tell me
about your experience with testing
frameworks how about security
we don't we can't afford a security
expert or a security team so once again
you might be asking your front end and
especially your back-end developers
what do they do
about security what are some of the
practices they follow and maybe some of
the examples they've built in previous
applications if you don't know anything
about security then of course you want
to hire in that expertise
what about sales what about marketing of
course those are not even technical
roles but you're going to have to have
that maybe that's your expertise and
what you're trying to get done so a
pretty obvious question should be about
yourself
which of these roles are you good at and
hopefully you are the product manager
first of all because
that's the business of building apps in
itself but if you can do the other
things then you're well ahead of others
now a common practice that you might
find in some entrepreneurs is that they
are the product manager role or the
marketing expert and they really don't
know how to code or program
so from experts that have done this and
created their own startup applications
the usual advice is
learn to code yourself so you can at
least build part of the application and
you can talk intelligently to the people
that are doing the core work of your app
because if you're ignorant on that you
are flying somewhat blind and you'll be
less effective
now here's one way to look at it then if
we had all of these four what's the
cheapest way to
fill these roles
well there's you so can you do all of
them if so then you can maybe grow
slowly but you're on the right track how
about these let's let's see if we can do
some outsourcing or replace them so
let's start with the designer so a
designer is not something maybe that has
to be continually managed it's a
one-time thing so maybe you could
outsource the job or do it yourself or
if you have a front-end designer that is
also your front-end developer then
you've got that one covered or you could
buy a template so
see if you can get rid of one of these
or two of these roles here's another way
you can combine things so the front end
and the back end developer
can combine into what's called a full
stack developer so if you have one
experienced programmer that can do both
the front end work and the database and
business logic in the back then you've
saved yourself an employee so by the way
if you're looking for employees come to
grand canyon university because
what we're creating here are full stack
developers so
they understand various languages such
as c sharp java javascript
and php and several types of databases
so there's a commercial to hire my
students
so there's your roles now the product
manager we're going to leave as you so
that is probably a key position
that only you can really do well now
here are some principles that probably
should apply
thinking about getting a let's let's
assume that you're in a small company if
you're in a big company already then
this might not be a big deal but
remember this that employees are your
very best assets
but also
their most expensive parts of your
business
employees require work to manage
and so startups need to keep the
management simple and costs low so a lot
of small teams don't even have an hr
department for example
so at this stage of life i've
been in several different roles
including
the technician and the manager and now
as a as a professor
and so some of the principles that i
would put out there is work with a small
team with people that you really really
trust and appreciate rather than trying
to get a big team
be very careful and very deliberate on
how you hire make sure that you
get good recommendations check the
references don't take a risk because
hiring the wrong person is a painful and
costly mistake
and so you'll save yourself a lot of
stress and the stress of somebody else
if you put the person in the wrong role
that maybe they don't really want to be
in so in the next video we're going to
talk about how to create a job
requisition how to identify the actual
experiences that you need to hire if
you'd like to see the entire course
playlist i'll put a link here for how to
see all of these chapters make sure that
you subscribe if this is valuable
information and thank you for coming to
class with me we'll see you next time
[Music]
hi and welcome to the business of
building applications this is a course
for people who are interested in
creating businesses that work with
mobile applications
now in this course there are several
chapters so if any of this material
looks of interest to you make sure you
subscribe or go look at the playlist for
the channel now right now we're in this
section called hiring the team and so
we're focusing on the skills that you
need and how to manage a project and so
let's talk here about the differences
between mobile development and web
development and the skills that are
involved so this might mean that you are
either looking at it from the
perspective of the manager who is trying
to find a competent mobile developer or
perhaps you are more in the career path
of becoming a developer and you would
like to compare the differences in
what's required and what kind of
benefits that you can get so first of
all let's talk about the overall market
of talent pool that there is
this is a stack overflow survey result
chart from 2020. every year stack
overflow the website asks their users
about themselves and about their
preferences on on development tools so
one of the first questions is what do
you do
and so you can see that a great deal of
people classify themselves as developers
on stack overflow
and they say that they are either back
end
full stack
or front end in their main categories so
those three main
groups there are probably
web developers that's usually the
default expectation
and you can see down in fifth place at
19
that they consider themselves a mobile
developer so it's a minority of a job
market but certainly not invisible
obviously all of us use apps and so
this is going to kind of steer the
decisions about where you would get your
talent pool
first of all let's talk about the need
for why a company would want a mobile
application so let's take a scenario
where you are an established company so
we're no longer talking about making a
startup out of thin air with a mobile
app so you're you're a business that
sells products and you probably have
stores and you have a lot of employees
the people are going to find you through
a web search probably through google
and then people want to come back to
your company again and so returning
visitors are likely going to back to
their website
and then finally we have what we call
our regular customers the frequent
transactions and they're going to
install the app so we go from google
to website to app
and so if we were looking at the company
called expedia that's probably how it
would happen they would search for cheap
airline tickets
maybe expedia is a search result
if the customer is
liking the service they come back to
their website
and then they use it so often that they
get a better performance with an app so
my my point here is that the need for a
mobile app for a company like expedia
might be really in third place after
they get their website going
so here's how it looks then we have
contact with new customers through your
web page and you retain your customers
through your mobile now you might say i
want to choose mobile in my
application development career or in
solving my business problem because of
certain things that only phones can do
so for instance you're trying to build a
virtual reality app well obviously you
need a device like a phone how about a
phone app that is gps aware or has
augmented reality such as a self-guided
tour of your
neighborhood or maybe you have a map app
and you're going to require google maps
and
a gyroscope with a game of course is
going to be hardware driven or maybe you
have some kind of a camera specific app
more than just taking photos you might
be scanning images or
working with barcodes and then finally
augmented reality is a cool tool
that allows you to look around an
environment and place objects such as a
new piece of furniture or apply makeup
to your face or in this case as you can
see the example you can see examples of
signs virtual signs that appear on the
street and so all of these would
probably guide you to hiring a mobile
developer or to developing a mobile
solution rather than a website
now look at the contrast and overlap of
where you would learn how to do this
thing
most people when they start
making themselves into software
engineers or software developers
they would probably learn how to make
things on the web
so since that's the most common medium
that most of us work with
so this big bubble here represents all
the skills that you would need for a
mobile or i'm sorry for a web developer
now we have another overlap which is
mobile development now i'm not quite
sure how much there is an overlap
probably more than i drew here
because
everything that you learn in a
good software engineering degree is
probably going to translate right into
mobile development so maybe i could have
overlapped at least half of that here's
the point
more people out there in the job market
are already skilled in web development
fewer in mobile development
web languages are similar to mobile
technology as a matter of fact some of
the cross
cross platform tools such as react
native
are best learned first as a mobile i'm
sorry as a web developer and then
applied to the mobile environment
and they apply so well that a react
developer can probably pick up mobile
development and react native quite
easily
many businesses can then just find their
mobile development talent
right within their walls they don't have
to go out and hire a mobile developer
they just need to train
their existing team with a few new
skills and away they go so consider that
based on what you need on your team
whether you're hiring from scratch or
you already have some people to work
with you should know that there's
overlap in these skills
so
the trends
that seem to go this way are
we have
native apps
as the first choice for building a
mobile solution
and then what we would call
cross-platform apps which focuses in on
javascript sometimes
and so native apps were the first and
the 100 percent only solution and of
course
if we have any alternatives to that
that's going to eat into that market
and then the cross platform solutions
seem to be on the rise now i put here
javascript apps so that refers to react
native probably there are other
multi-platform tools such as xamarin
which is all in c sharp
or
kotlin
using
cross-platform compiling is somewhat
cross-platform
flutter and dart
is another combination
so just putting javascript here is kind
of misleading but the idea is that the
trends are
trying to get cross-platform solutions
and a lot of that
looks like web development
so
if you're a native app developer you're
going to know android very well or ios
very well
but
they're very independent
if you're trying to do cross-platform
work
you're probably going to also know quite
a bit about web development so anyway
that's the trends i see
is what the market is trying to do
and i don't know if the cross-platform
solutions are always the best but that
seems to be where we're trying to go
now let's talk about the skill levels
and the complexity so on the left side
we have
web development at the very beginning if
you've never done anything before you
can build web pages quite easily with a
tool such as
wordpress
or maybe squarespace or something that
is
just as easy to use as a
desktop publishing tool such as
publisher or maybe even microsoft word
going up from there you can call
yourself a web designer so you start to
learn a bit more about css
from javascript and then if you try to
get to the full stack you have the
database in the back end and so that's
kind of the progression that i would
teach my students and probably you've
learned as well if you're on that path
in the mobile development it seems like
we skipped that first stage there might
be some tools out there to create mobile
apps without code but
i i don't really know
how successful they are so most of the
time when i teach
app development we jump right in with
somebody that knows java and we start
working with pretty complex code
and then finally you get to the top end
where you have the full stack again in a
mobile app so
my perception i could be wrong maybe you
could correct me if you put these
corrections of course in the comments is
that there seems to be this bottom rung
of the ladder that is missing on the app
development side so more than likely if
you're in app development you've got
more skills than somebody that is just
beginning with cody
this was reflected in some salaries so
on the left side we have what i searched
for and i think it was
indeed.com they said an average salary
on the in the united states for android
developer was about 120 000
and slightly less for the software
engineer which is more general and
probably focused on
web development is is the majority of
their work so you get paid more as an
app developer probably because
as i said the difficulty level's a bit
higher
and your skills are probably a bit more
advanced so the conclusion then
uh your mobile app either you're an
established business
or it could be that you're just starting
directly with a mobile solution and
trying to launch your startup that way i
mean instagram for example
you use a mobile app only if you need
some unique capabilities
most of the time you can build an app
without building an app
you can build a mobile
friendly website so a responsive design
website can get orders and present
information to your customers quite
easily and so you might not even need a
mobile developer
but if you have these unique
capabilities in a phone and you want to
use them
then you'll obviously need to make a map
and make an app
more challenging for beginners and then
better pay so
that's the column for mobile
the case for web development is that
it's more widely utilized so you're
going to find people that can work on
your projects and you can hire them
if you are a web developer you're going
to have more choices to pick from and
also
if you decide you want to begin in one
or the other then i would probably
recommend that you start as a web
developer if you're a beginning
programmer
and you can transfer those skills later
to mobile after you've maybe got a year
or so of experience in the next video
i'm going to help you with the scrum and
agile process
and so that way you can manage a team
using today's most common methods if
you'd like to see the entire playlist
for this course i will also put that
link here so make sure that you
subscribe if this is good information to
you and we'll see you next time
[Music]
hi and welcome back to the business of
building applications in this course
we're talking about the management and
the business decisions that go behind
creating an application whether it's for
your business or for a startup but it's
about mobile apps and the process that
is used so we're in this section here
called hiring the team and so we're
going to in this video talk about
managing your team and using the agile
software process if any of these other
chapters look of interest to you then
make sure you subscribe so that you can
come back and watch them later my name
is chad slutter and i teach software
development and
computer science at grand canyon
university so welcome to class
so we've got one more section ahead of
us and then we're going to move on to
other greater things so right now we're
talking about managing the team with
agile and so agile is a software
development process so sometimes you're
going to hear in your life the letters
the sdlc the software development life
cycle and so this goes from the concept
of an idea
all the way to where you retire a piece
of software and no longer use it
so the sdlc is a way to bring
sanity into a complex process trying to
bring some structure into managing
something that frequently fails right
now there are two basic ideas for how to
manage any kind of an engineering
project waterfall is the traditional
method that's been used for centuries
and agile well it's the newest name for
a process that is incremental and so
agile is preferred and probably has some
good reasons to
be preferred in today's market so here's
what the
previous method looks like this is the
waterfall methodology and you can see
where it gets its name because
one step of the process is completed and
then falls into the next
so in a waterfall methodology you try to
imagine all of the details of your
product up front and you would design a
very comprehensive guide to how to build
it and so you really create it twice in
your mind once in your
idea and then second on your paperwork
and then you give it to your engineers
and they develop it now the design then
of course is structured it's static
it might be what you want but it might
not be as well
and the risk is that if you
have left out any details
they never get addressed
and so this process
leads to expensive dinosaurs that people
abandoned
and so waterfall methodology though it
sounds logical in practice it has some
issues and the issues are is that we're
trying to do all of our thinking about
the product up front at one time
and we don't usually do very well good
job of that
so in comes the second type of software
development which is iterative
we develop a feature and then test it
out and show it to our users and
incrementally we increase our product
and so this has been proven to be more
successful in the long run
and to get that process working we use
the process called agile
agile or agile scrum because scrum is a
meeting a name for a meeting that we do
on a regular basis in this process so
really it's agile software development
so what we do with agile software
development is we start with a project
backlog
which is kind of like the waterfall
technology where we say we've got a
pretty big picture of what we want their
app to do
we list all of those features
but we don't implement them all we just
implement the first one or maybe two
we create what's called a sprint backlog
which is a short list of things to do
and then within two weeks to 30 days we
do a sprint
and then finally we have at the end of a
short period of time at the end of our
sprint we have a product that works we
can test it out now it only might be the
title screen and the login
but at least we get a view of what the
the design is
so it's a very minimal product it only
has a few features
but we can show that to our users and
then they can decide if we're on the
right track or not and if we're not
then we've only wasted two weeks of time
or we can make adjustments so that we
can make corrections for the future
to make this work we do a few principles
one principle is called self organizing
your teams you put people together
and they have their specialties but we
give them the autonomy to work as a
small group
and so this grid here might show you how
you would organize an entire
company of agile teams and so you can
see that there are four people
or four teams
and each each person then is got their
own thing so
if you
you might have a bigger team than four
but usually small teams work best so you
can see the specialties specialty such
as somebody that's in the ui design
somebody's a software developer it looks
like we might need some data modeling
maybe a database expert but the idea is
that we try to come up with these little
pods of people
now when you come up with these groups
it's important that you pick the right
people on your team
of course we all want the people on the
top right corner
of our team
they have high capacity they're well
skilled at their job
and they're anxious to get started so
we'll give them a green light
so the low capacity people are your
second choice which is
they don't really know what they're
doing yet but they're really anxious to
get started
and then the other two on the left
the willingness part that's harder to
cure
so if we were to respond to these people
as they've been given to us maybe you're
an agile team leader and you've got this
mix of exactly these four people what
are you going to do with them
well first of all the green we're going
to promote we're going to give them
flexibility autonomy we're going to let
them
run their own schedule we're going to
make them creative
the low capacity people are going to
make mistakes of course and so we're
going to pair them up with somebody that
knows what they're doing
we're going to give them training if
they don't know what their language is
or if they haven't worked with a certain
technology
as the manager you're probably going to
want to keep track of this person you're
going to help them out share with them
what you know or pair them with somebody
that does
now our third person here is our high
capacity but low willingness and so you
as the manager of the team
are going to probably have to clarify
why we're doing what we're doing so
one-on-one meetings clarify the goals
the directions why this why this sprint
is necessary what the vision of the
company is try to clear out any
hesitations they have
maybe they need a schedule change maybe
they need something more interesting to
work on but you've got to find out why
they're not so willing and then for the
last part where you've got these
incompetent people that really don't
know what they're doing they're just
toxic and you should probably fire them
now so when you look at your
agile team you want to make sure that
you can get as many people in the top
right quadrant as we can because you're
going to make them work kind of
independently you're going to put them
in co-location areas hopefully where
they can see each other frequently
and so
studies have shown
that the further away people are
isolated
the less effective they are in solving
collaboration problems
so
unfortunately with the covet plague that
we experienced in 2020
many of us didn't have the chance to
work with our
teammates in the office
we'd started to do remote work but the
ideal is to have a close relationship
where unplanned meetings can occur quick
questions
where you can have people show each
other ideas you don't have to wait
formally to present something you can
either go with an idea or abandon it
based on immediate feedback
so if you do find yourself in the remote
work situation which is probably the
future
try to do as casually as you can
as you can see in this case we have a
mix so some people are remote some
people are close by
but the idea is to keep up a constant
flow of communication so that ideas can
be tested or
approved or abandoned quickly
now one of the things that you're going
to work with on a project is the product
backlog
now a backlog sounds like you're behind
but really what it means is
a product feature list and so that
feature list is going to be everything
that your app needs to do and so you can
see in the left column of this board
we have sticky notes
every sticky note is going to describe a
feature of the product for example let's
say on one of the sticky notes it says
i want to display all of the orders of a
of a of a user
in a date range and print a report so
that's a feature
now that feature is going to take
somebody some work
there's going to be lots of other
features
and each one of those is going to
require a sprint to be able to get the
work done but we want to identify which
which features in the backlog are the
most important
and when we find the first important
ones we're going to put them into the
next column the sprint backlog
so a sprint as you might recall is a
short period of time maybe two weeks
and we will work on a few items from the
product backlog
and then you can see the rest of it
we're going to move them on until we get
done
now when you have a sprint planning
session you and your teammates are going
to pick out some items from that product
backlog
and you're going to
take a look at what needs to be done and
prioritize them
so you might pick some feature because
it's easy to do or you might pick a
feature because it's critically
important for the app
but whatever the reason is you're going
to move
those items from the product backlog
that are going to be currently busy and
put them into a sprint backlog and they
will get your full attention for the
next two weeks
so our sprint backlog then is our guide
you're going to put that on a board and
you're going to talk about it every
single day
so your backlog is everything that has
to be done either in the app or in the
case of the sprint backlog everything
that needs to be done in the next two
weeks and then of course completing
those steps is a daily task
so
now we've gotten to the term called
sprint
what are we going to do in that sprint
and how long is it going to take
so a sprint typically is two weeks long
the first day is the planning meeting so
that you can decide what the next goals
are
and you can see that every day of the
sprint is a scheduled meeting probably
early in the morning that says your
daily stand-up so a stand-up meeting is
where you literally do not sit down so
it doesn't take too long so for 15
minutes you give a brief update on what
you're doing
and then when we get to the end of the
sprint you can see that there are two
items one's called a sprint review
and a sprint retrospective so you can
kind of look back to see what went well
and what didn't
so the product increment is what we're
trying to create in a sprint so an
incremental product is something that is
like i mentioned
less featureful than the full thing
but still
enough functionality so that we could
call it shippable
so shippable means you can show it to
your client you can show it to the
customer they can test it out and give
immediate feedback on it so this is the
magic of why you do incremental
development
is that if the product is a failure you
can find out right away
so instead of building a billion dollars
worth of software you spend a hundred
thousand dollars worth of software and
then you can change it or reject it
before you waste too much money so an
incremental approach
saves money
now the daily scrum is where you're
going to get together with your
teammates and what are you going to talk
about well really the agenda is three
questions
you're going to tell everyone in your
team what you did yesterday so yesterday
i created the report that would show all
the orders from a certain date range
and it now converts into a pdf file okay
so there's my
accomplishment
today what will you do today well today
i am going to make that available to
users or i'm going to make it available
to administrators some other new feature
and so something concrete
and then
is there any impediment is the third
question so is there something blocking
you
do i need help do i need a new uh
permissions to something do i need to
understand something do i need someone
else to do something for me
but in the daily scrum you have those
three questions
now if this is a good way to manage
employees because you know what they're
doing they can report
and they can report to each other so if
you have a lazy employee that is just
out at the beach
and he says what did i do yesterday and
he really doesn't have anything concrete
if that happens for too often
then it's obvious who is the dead wood
in your tree
and will probably either be terminated
or looked over for
any further
enhancements
now when you get to the end of a sprint
we're going to call this event the
sprint review
what we want to do in a review is just
to look back at what we created
so in this case
you're probably going to have your team
around your computer showing you the
product the digital project you made
and in front of us is the man in the
chair
he is the customer he is the person that
is paying you
and you can show off this is show and
tell to say
here's what we made this is exactly what
you told us
and at the sprint review this is his
chance to say
i don't like it or perfect you did it in
a creative way i love it and let's keep
going in the same direction so the
sprint review is that periodic checkup
point with your client to make sure that
you're on the right track
now the retrospective is also at the end
of the sprint and we just look at our
own work process and we ask is there
anything that's working really well
or is there something that we should
change
and what can we commit for the next
sprint
so a retrospective just kind of gives us
a chance to do some self improvement if
this is relevant to you then check out
this other video on the four roles that
you would expect to see in a software
development team
also if you'd like to see the entire
playlist of things that we've talked
about in the business of apps i'll put
that link here as well so thank you for
coming and join me again for class
[Music]
hi welcome to the business of building
applications this is a course to help
you as a manager of a small business or
a team in building mobile apps for good
solutions we've got several chapters in
this course that we've already covered
and we are coming up here to number
seven which is called hiring the team
in this video we're going to be talking
about writing a job requisition and a
good job posting that will get the
people that fit your needs we've got one
more topic ahead of us which is called
future trends
my name is chad slooter and i teach
computer science and software
development at grand canyon university
if any of this looks interesting to you
make sure you subscribe so that you get
all of the information that will help
you succeed in your venture
so in this video we're talking about
writing a job requisition and attracting
the right people that will make your
success a reality so first of all we're
going to talk about the difference
between an internal and an external
requisition
so if you're writing an internal wreck
it's because you're working at a company
that needs to know these basic things
and so i probably don't need to fill out
the form for you you can see
what your company would like but i would
predict that you're going to be asked
several of these things so you're going
to be picking a title you might not have
any liberty and what you call that job
because there's already predefined jobs
you probably have a salary band that you
are offering to your employees so you
don't really know exactly
uh what your upper and lower limits are
until you talk to your
boss and the company controller
you will probably have some requirements
that you put in there and you probably
have some kind of a contract and so
sometimes you see the words salary and
exempt
or non-exempt which is rather confusing
so exempt means they are exempt from the
rules of
overtime and union representation so
these are the people that you can have
work 80 hours a week and not pay them
any extra money you'll probably be asked
to set a budget so how much do you
expect to pay here and of course
you're trying to find somebody that will
be willing to work less than that
now quite different as the strategy of
producing an external posting because
this is what your candidates will see
not the internal documents so the
differences are because there's
differences in goals the internal
documentation is to meet your business
goals your hr requirements
and to budgeting probably
so when you write an external document
you have to clear away any of the
language that you're comfortable with as
an insider of the company and think
about people that are on the street or
working at other companies and they
don't know anything about you and so
you're trying to target the language to
the people that will likely fit the role
the best so
you probably want to start off with this
question about
what do i really require for this person
to have on the day they enter the job
and what would be nice to have because
if you put too many requirements of
course you're not going to have anyone
actually apply
so i picked a few job postings out of
indeed.com that are currently being
posted where i live and you can see here
that this was for a mobile developer
and the company called
signing day sports so i don't know
anything about the company other than
the fact that they are looking for a
mobile developer
notice they have the qualifications
listed here so they are looking for a
degree
they want some experience
and they they mention some specific
languages and frameworks that they work
on
so it looks like react native is what
they're building in so they've already
decided the technology and if you don't
know that technology then you're
probably not a very good fit
however you can see that they have
familiarity as a requirement so these
are the nice to haves and so things that
are not necessarily
directly on the job
and the first day so you have to
distinguish between
things that you need to have and then
what you're willing to train them on so
if you find a really good employee who
has got most of the skills then you can
probably make them work
here's another one you notice they use
the quote must in capital letters so
they obviously have a hard fast rule
so this comes from the nikola motor
company so this is a company in phoenix
that makes electric trucks
and i think they want to be the next
tesla
anyway they're looking for android
development so specifically you must
have
proven experience in android but then
notice below they have some other things
that they probably will not get in most
of their candidates so the android
compose framework
so
if they find somebody with the android
compose framework they're going to
guarantee them they're going to have an
interview likely so next let's talk
about what would be beneficial in a
cross-discipline candidate so if you're
looking specifically for somebody with
experience in another field this would
be important to put in your job
requisition in the public so we're
looking for the core developer skills
here but you might have other things
such as somebody that's worked in a
travel environment before have is your
product
geared toward travel agents or for
online purchases of airplane tickets or
something then maybe you would want
somebody that's worked in that field are
you working in a medical plan are you is
your app serving doctors or nurses or
hospitals
then if somebody comes to you with a
degree in nursing and software
development which would be a quite an
odd combination that would be certainly
a valuable thing and of course your
automobile mechanic could be another
example one of my students actually has
these two things now and wants to find a
job working where some software is in a
garage environment
military experience a lot of students
that i teach come from the military and
they're trying to transition into a new
career
and my career advice to them is if you
are looking for a job as a software
developer why not go back to the
military and work as a civilian
if you are serving military clients with
your app then maybe these are the kind
of people you want to hire people that
have worked in the military they
understand it and they also know how to
write code and of course
education comes to mind as if you're
trying to serve schools so it's not
really essential that your software
developer is cross
professions is it you'll have to decide
that but if it is important to you then
you probably want to put it in as one of
those nice to haves how about the
intangibles so you're going to have a
variety of people looking at you and
they don't really know what you expect
so think of your own expectations of
what your team is going to be
and see if you can filter out the people
that really don't matter so for instance
are you going to be working in close
teamwork with like agile systems or are
you looking to hire a single loan
developer
so that would be important for the
people to know upfront before they apply
to your job
so some people have strong preferences
both ways now the question is what is
your preference
so if you're looking for a certain
person make sure you put it in the
description
what is your parameters what are you
going to expect your software developer
to be
are you going to have strict guidelines
deadlines are you going to have code
that must be written in a right format
do you have specific languages and
frameworks that they must work with
or are you going to be so flexible that
they can choose their own technologies
and their own ways of building things
so
if you're comfortable with either one of
these
then you probably should specify in your
job requisition how you want it to look
because once again
people are going to waste your time if
you offer them a job that they really
don't fit with
how do you handle ambiguity so are you
going to have very detailed designs are
you going to require people to create
detailed designs or are you more
flexible to say let's just see how
things turn out
and what is the uh
what is the structure there be very
clear about what you expect whether it
is either
very strong or very weak in your picture
also when you look at job postings i see
these two
very often so what kind of intangible do
you have at your company
are you called
fast-paced and goal-oriented or are you
more flexible and work life balance is
important to you
now honestly i've never applied to
anything that had the word fast-paced
environment in it because i really think
that a place like spacex would be an
awesome experience if you have
180 percent of your life to give to them
however i have other things in life that
i do besides work and so
a job description that had fast-paced
environment would likely just turn me
off and say
i don't think i would turn out for more
than a year
in a high pressure system like that so
how are you going to treat your
employees are you expecting them to work
as a startup and dedicate their whole
life
or are you looking for them to
produce a balance between what they do
in their time away from work and what
they do at your job so
whatever your expectations are it's
probably a good idea to put them right
in the job posting now there's also some
hr language that you should include in
your posting so
probably required by the company policy
or even state law to have
non-discrimination phrases
you should have probably some company
language
the company probably has a statement of
their purpose or they have something
that goes into every job description and
so make sure that you include that or if
you're your own company and you're a
startup you might want to think about
what your story is why would people want
to work for you
if you're the greatest thing in the
world then tell us what it is
so you're trying to sell yourself when
you put the posting out there are you
going to require citizenship or will you
provide visa and sponsorship that's an
hr thing how about this remote work or
on-site work are you comfortable with
each
so if you're comfortable with remote
work you can have a wide group of talent
from all over the country or even around
the world
and if you're if you're a more face to
face person then of course you're going
to be limited by the people that live in
your area so that's a decision that
you're going to have to decide based on
your comfort comfort level with that
that system so whatever the case is make
sure that you are up front with your
employees of how you expect them to work
here
also think of adjacent skills so you
might have your must have lists but
don't be too restrictive on it because
you want to have enough people
that can really do the job even though
they might not have the exact experience
you need so a software developer
with web experience can probably
transition into mobile development
pretty easily
it depends on how many experience years
they have
languages also are very similar so the
syntax of java and swift and c sharp and
c plus plus and javascript they're very
similar
obviously those that are experts in each
of these are going to argue with me to
say there's huge differences but
honestly these are
all the
descendants of the original c language
these are c like languages and so if you
have an expertise in one of these then
you can probably pick another language
that is in that same family
also think of the structure of how
software is designed and architect
so the model view controller the mvc
frameworks and the and this the setup
there are very similar no matter whether
you're working in php or in java or
javascript
a lot of the strategies and designs are
the same so if they've got
heavy experience in a framework that's
not the framework you're on they're
probably going to have a lot of lessons
that they can carry in and so adjacent
skills work well so let's say if we had
a situation where we have a react native
developer that's the job we want and you
get these applications that come from
people with expertise in cyber security
or a web designer or a database
administrator or embedded systems or
electrical engineering
don't throw them out
and don't restrict them from applying if
you are willing to do the training
so once again think about what is
essential and what can be trained i
would rather pick somebody who is an
expert web designer and it can
demonstrate a great portfolio but yet
has not learned react native they've
proved themselves in some other field
that is adjacent
and so you might want to think about
inviting
related degrees and related experience
to apply if they can prove that they're
a good employee
now i would also recommend that you ask
people to apply with a portfolio a
portfolio of course is a collection of
things that you can
see that people have actually done so
let's take a look at an example of a
portfolio and you tell me if you would
like to hire this person or not so
holland a coin was one of my students
for several years at grand canyon
university and she just graduated
now she created for herself a portfolio
of everything that she's done in her
university experience so let's take a
look at her projects
so she's built this tool here in java
spring so you can see that right away
she knows how to program in java
and she sorted it nicely so that you can
see each of the languages that she's
worked in and the projects that relate
to them so let's say i want to see what
she's done in java
and let's see what
is going on in i heart rate
so i heart rate was something she did in
the spring of 2020 you can see all the
different languages that she's built
with the design and the final product of
what it works with so i believe
this was a watch application so that an
apple watch that would just record your
heart rate and put it into a database
and then you can have some web reports
to go along with it
so i recommend to all my students that
they create one of these portfolios
because it demonstrates in a concrete
way
what you know how to do
so as an employer you get to know a lot
about your candidates just from looking
at their portfolio as a matter of fact
there's not really very good information
that you can gather at a job interview
just by asking them questions and having
them tell you generic answers
so
a portfolio is a great answer to the
question is
can you build an app
now there's probably some other things
that i failed to include and how you
should write a job requisition so those
of you that are
looking to hire and have hired people
tell me in the comments below what has
worked for you the next video in this
course is about the future trends of
technology and especially with mobile if
you'd like to see the entire playlist
i'll put a link here so you can go back
and catch up on all the great things
about the business of running apps
please subscribe if you like this and
welcome back to class
[Music]
hi and welcome to the business of
building applications this is a course
about mobile app development in this
section which is number seven we're
talking about hiring the team now this
is an assignment video so we're talking
about activity 7-1 so if you're one of
my students at grand canyon university
this is what i'm going to assign you for
homework what we're going to talk about
in this assignment are the team roles
now in a previous video we talked about
four background specialties that would
be in a lot of teams so this is the
project manager
the designer
the front end and the back end
developers now there are probably other
roles in a team but we're focusing on
these four so in this assignment what i
want you to do is write a two-part paper
that compares the responsibilities of
these four roles so essentially i want
to ask you in part one of the paper what
do these people do what's their
essential job function and how do they
add value to your team then the second
is
in your particular situation based on
your expertise and your company or your
startup company
where are you going to fill these roles
who are the people that are most likely
to join you now that could be that
you're going to fulfill them yourself or
you've got friends in mind or you've got
a way to go and recruit them so this is
the two-part solution here so
instructions for part one i want you to
answer the question what important
service do each of these members provide
what education and experience would you
expect that these people would have so
if you were writing a job posting and
trying to hire them
what kind of experience and education
would you put as a requirement what
strengths does this person bring to the
team so is a designer just as good as a
developer or does one do something
slightly better than the other
in part two i'm going to ask you if
there are any opportunities for you not
to hire them
so for instance can you double them up
can you outsource the role do you have
to pay a full time
now are there any of these roles that
can be combined into a single person for
instance do you have a friend who is a
developer and a designer or are you good
at this on your own so what is your case
what's your situation how are you going
to save money which of these are the
most expensive to fill so based on your
market research
which of these do you think
are the most critical and you would
never outsource or which of these is
where you could save some cash
so then for your role are there any
roles that can be considered minimal or
are they all equally important to the
development of your app so only you can
really answer that based on how well you
work now describe your own set of skills
how strong are you in those four roles
is there anything that you feel like you
would want to do yourself
or is there something that you feel
inadequate on and you would want to hire
it out so that's part two and analyzing
how well these four roles would fit in
your team so if you're one of my
students this is what i would expect you
to send me a word document that has two
parts so part one is a description of
what these four roles are and how they
add value to the team and then part two
is a recommendation for you personally
how would you plan to consolidate or
fill these roles based on your own
expertise and the people that you
already work with
and so that's the goal here for this
assignment
so if you're not one of my students feel
free to put in the comments below what
you think of these roles and how
valuable are they for instance is a
designer a critical person on your team
or have you worked on a team where the
designer is you as the programmer and
how well did that go for you now if you
would like to subscribe you can see the
rest of the channel and see what the
ideas are on this course i will put a
link to the full course so that you can
see the other videos and the lessons
about app design thanks for watching and
i'll see you in the next class
[Music]
hi and welcome to the business of
building applications this is a course
on mobile development and the business
decisions that go along with it so we're
on part seven here which is a seven of
eight chapters and we're talking about
hiring the right people for your team so
this is a homework assignment video so
if you're one of the students in my
class at grand canyon university this is
what i'm going to ask you to do so we're
going to write an internal requisition
form so if you are a hiring manager
let's say you're now in a medium to
large size company you're going to have
certain documents that you have to fill
out to justify why you need a new person
on your team so put yourself in the role
of a team manager of a medium to large
company assume that there are multiple
levels of management and multiple
departments in the company in other
words a bureaucracy so what i want you
to do is to assume that you're going to
fill one of the roles in your team that
we've talked about in a previous
activity so remember that was the
project manager the designer the
front-end developer and the back-end
developer or if you've got another role
that's just as critical and i haven't
thought of then you could use that one
too so what i want you to do is to write
an internal requisition so think of how
you would justify adding a person to
your company so sometimes companies are
very hesitant to hire because
people are expensive so what we want to
do is justify it with a certain goals so
in the first part make sure that you
include a job title that re
that coordinates with the rest of the
company so don't invent something new
see if you can figure out what your
company already calls people make sure
that you get the right department and
you put your name for the hiring manager
and you probably have to just justify it
by what this person is supposed to do
right a job description and then you
have a reason why a person is needed
so did somebody quit or are you creating
a new position so depending on your
company one of those would be easier to
justify and get authority for hiring
than the others would so let's keep
going with part two of what you would
put in the internal requisition so you'd
have to do a salary estimate so you
don't just invent numbers out of thin
air you would have to justify it so if
your company already has very fixed
salary bands you might call this a
person level a or b or 3.5 or whatever
your system is and if you don't have a
system like that
then you would probably have to justify
it based on averages from
websites like salary.com or someone that
is like glassdoor and they are
estimating what is average for your area
so remember we hire people at average
salary and then we say to our customers
that we hire the best in the world so i
don't know how that works but anyway
that's usually how you justify a salary
range and then you put a start date on
it to say this is a going to coordinate
with either our fiscal year or maybe a
project start date and then we have the
number of hours that we plan to work so
sometimes you can hire part-time and of
course full-time equivalent would be 40
hours a week and then how long is this
going to work so are you going to have
this person as a permanent employee or
are you going to keep them on until the
project's over so that's some of the
things that you would justify in an
internal requisition so i forgot to put
a few others so contract type is this
permanent or is this uh temporary what
are the qualifications are you going to
expect to have a degree what kind of
degree or maybe just work experience
so trying to fit the role is appropriate
of course and then the budget so
you can put down what you expect to
employ the person as and of course the
game is you try to find somebody that
will tell you that they're willing to
work for less
and if they are then you hire them so i
don't know if that's morally
objectionable but i think that's how
most people do things now if you were
one of my students this is what i would
expect you to send to me you would send
me a word document that has the internal
requisition for a position on your
development team filling out all of the
details that are in the items that i
just showed you so this isn't really a
thought-provoking assignment it's more
of an exercise to investigate where you
work
and find out what kind of things that
are out there so your requisition
at your company will probably look like
nothing
similar to what other people's are doing
but it will not be identical and if
you're not working at any company then
of course you've got some flexibility to
say
what you would think would be a likely
way to requisition a new an employee if
you're not one of my students then you
can put down in the comments below what
you think about the experience of how
your company works and how difficult it
is to justify a new person on your team
make sure you subscribe to the channel
if you haven't so far and i will put a
link to the entire playlist for this
course and other courses as well so that
you can join me again in the next class
thanks for watching
[Music]
hi and welcome to the business of
building apps this is a course about
mobile app development and the business
decisions that go along with it so we're
in chapter seven of eight chapters we're
talking about hiring the team in this
video we're talking about an assignment
that i would give you if you were one of
my students so this is homework so
activity 7.3 which is about creating a
job posting so remember we're trying to
put you in the role of the team lead and
you're trying to justify why you should
hire somebody now once you've got
approval for that how are you going to
attract the right members to your team
so we're going to actually write a job
posting using examples that we would
find on indeed or on glass door or other
places and we want to apply the
principles that were taught in previous
videos of what makes an effective job
posting and how you can make it fit with
the people that you want to hire so
choose one of these four roles
whether it's the project manager the
designer the front end or the back end
or if you've got another role in mind
you could probably use that but somebody
that is relevant to your app development
process
and we want to be able to study the
materials for this topic so that means i
want you to go back and look at previous
videos that i've created they give
recommendations for how to post so what
are we going to put into our job posting
so this is some of the things you're
going to have the job title a clear
summary of what the job will do the
responsibilities on a daily basis or on
a monthly basis or whatever your plan is
we expect to put the qualifications
there so how much education and
experience or licensing or
certifications does this role need what
are the benefits that you provide to
them and describe your company why they
should work for you
and so some of the recommendations that
i put there earlier would give an idea
of the style you are and what kind of a
fit that most people would want to apply
for so make it look attractive but of
course make it look realistic as well
so
what i want you to then do is to
take a look at what you wrote
and do a one page self evaluation
compare this
to where other people have written
so
yours will be different than what you
would find on other companies so for
instance if you worked in phoenix where
i do you would probably think find
things like for intel or american
express or carvana
or paypal some of those are the big
companies around here
how do they differ from what you plan to
do and so
what i want you to do is to say if
you've borrowed from another posting
compare the two so i think
frequently that's how a lot of job
postings are created is that the manager
copies and pastes from a other company's
work and then tweaks it so if that's
your process then tell me
what you changed what you deleted what
you added because it's probably not
identical to other companies as well so
that's what i want you to do is evaluate
what you wrote so if you were one of my
students this is what i would expect you
to turn in
send me a word document that has the job
posting and then following that an
evaluation kind of a critique of why
this works what makes your posting
effective what did you emphasize and so
that would be a reflection to on what
you just wrote so if you're not one of
my students then feel free to write in
the comments below about some of the
greatest job posting errors that you've
seen things that are laughable perhaps
or things that would make you run red
flags you might call them of why you
would never apply to a company based on
what they wrote in their job description
so make sure you subscribe to the
channel so there's lots of other points
to this course and there's a playlist
here that would give you the other items
so thanks for watching and make sure
that you come back for the next class of
mobile app development
[Music]
hi and welcome to the business of
building applications this is a course
for people that are business leaders or
entrepreneurs so we've covered several
items already in this course and we are
on the last of our chapters so we are
going to look in this video about 12
trends that i see in the next decade or
so regarding mobile technology my name
is shad slooter and i teach computer
science and software development at
grand canyon university so if this looks
interesting make sure you subscribe and
then you can come to class with me on a
daily basis so let's get started here
we're talking about 12 mobile tech ideas
that are coming or developing in the
near future and so some of these are
here but they just don't work very well
and others will grow in popularity so
with the first one that i'm going to put
on the list is cloud computing and cloud
computing is far more than just running
a server on the cloud it means that you
are able to offload a great deal of the
work that your phone does as a low
powered device and put it in the hands
of super computers so the best way to
show you what is available is just to go
to
cloud.google.com for example google is
one company that has great cloud
services so what do they do they have
everything from machine learning and ai
to storage to ways to make
your finances work
so
you don't rely on your computer as much
as you used to
to actually do heavy computing items so
for instance think of the voice
recognition tools that are on your phone
right now so siri and cortana can
understand you pretty well
do you really think that your phone is
doing all of that voice recognition no
it's not they're sending your recorded
message
to the cloud and the super computers in
the data centers are doing the analysis
on your voice and then immediately send
back what they think the text is and so
all of these cloud services are a huge
variety of things from voice recognition
to all kinds of processing power
and your phone
doesn't really have to do the work it
just has to connect you to the place
that does the work for you and so i see
cloud computing growing even more than
it is today so the next trend that i see
a greater emphasis on is artificial
intelligence and so the
major software developers like google
and microsoft
have great tools that allow developers
like you and me to simply
plug in libraries and functions and apis
and we can just take advantage of it so
i'm not an iai expert but i can add ai
to my phone apps because of these
plugins you can see that this is
microsoft's
collection of things let's look at some
of them that we can understand so the
top right corner it says text analytics
so with just a simple plugin with an api
call on your application you can do
sentiment analysis it says on any kind
of text that is either written or spoken
to you so you can find out if somebody's
in a good mood if they like your review
if they hate your business and the
artificial intelligence agent will give
you a score and so that that's an ai
example and you don't have to do much
programming other than tell it analyze
this
so the next item here in the center is
the ai route planner so for instance
when you start using google maps or
microsoft maps
you don't have to compute the the best
route that a car should take there's a
ai agent that is doing that for you and
so like i said you don't have to be the
ai expert you just have to be a
programmer that knows how to access data
points and endpoints of apis so look at
the other things there's language
understanding and
video indexing so you can actually
analyze videos as they've been processed
and computer vision down in the bottom
is also where you can recognize objects
that are in the field of view of a
camera so
this is where ai is as of right now i
just see this growing and ai agents
becoming better and better and helpful
in their in their process of making our
apps more and more powerful so so i
don't mean that ai is going to become
like the overlord robots that are going
to control our life and ruin our
civilization
ai is just a matter of doing computing
that
makes the apps work more efficiently
so the next item up is cross platform
development so
the reason why i say this is going to be
a trend in the future is because
people are talking about it a lot and
trying to do some work on it but look
here at the actual statistics about what
apps are in the store today
so you can see that the android store is
much bigger as far as the number of apps
go
and the overlap here shows the number of
apps that are cross-platform they've
been
developed in tools like react native or
flutter or some other tool to
have one code base between the two
but the majority of apps are written in
a single platform environment why is
that is because that's the best
experience for the user and the actions
actually work well
and so there's a lot of improvement that
needs to be done on cross-platform
application development and so
i can only see it as a trend that will
increase
google is putting quite a bit of work
into their cross-platform tools such as
flutter
and their current edition of kotlin is
compiling the guts of your application
right now and leaving the user interface
to custom development so
there's attention being paid to this and
so i would expect that it's only going
to grow from its humble place that it is
in right now the next is m-commerce so
you've heard of e-commerce of course is
when we've turned stores into websites
so m-commerce is the idea that you can
run your entire store on a mobile phone
there's a couple of reasons for that one
is the idea of responsive design
applications so if you have a web app
that works well on your phone and your
tablet and your computer then you can
use your phone
in a greater degree so when you're out
in the store or the warehouse you don't
have to have your laptop with you and so
that's one reason why computing on the
phone is growing and eventually will
hopefully replace your desktop for the
majority of the purpose that it needs so
you've probably seen this in some of the
coffee shops you've been to where they
don't even have a cash register or point
of sale computer they have a tablet or
they have an ipad or something like that
and so that is m computing that is
running your entire business on a mobile
platform and so i just see that as a
great way for people to
save time and save money and save
devices so m computing will probably be
a growth area so consider that an
opportunity if you're an app developer
so virtual reality shows up next so
virtual reality has been a great thing
for the future it has always been a
great thing that's going to happen in
the future right now virtual reality
pretty much stinks this is how i see it
is people get headaches they get
nauseated it's as good as the 3d
televisions were what some years ago
it was a great technology that the
engineers loved and they promoted
and nobody bought them because nobody
cared that their tvs were
three-dimensional
and it seems to me a little bit like
that right now with vr
nobody really is buying into this even
there's a great deal of research being
put into it so the potential then is
amazing if we could get vr that doesn't
stink
then we are going to have a great
view for the future so right now mobile
phones on like the google cardboard
they're pretty much dead if you go walk
through goodwill or any second-hand
store or any garage sale you're gonna
see all these uh headsets that were
designed to hold mobile phones and
obviously everyone tried them and nobody
liked them so what's this what's the
current share so if you look at the
actual headsets that are designed for
virtual reality for playing serious
games and you plug into xboxes or
high-end computers you're going to see
that oculus is the market leader they
have about fifty percent of the share of
all the models that are currently
connected to devices this is a data here
that comes from steam so we're talking
about games here
and you can see that oculus
has this rift and quest and the rift ii
or the wrist rift s i'm sorry and so
they're obviously the leader so
if we can get a mobile phone to work as
well as an oculus
then maybe we'll have some potential
there so let's keep it in the future
category for a little bit longer virtual
reality may eventually become really
cool and people will adopt it augmented
reality probably has a little bit better
future because
as you can see the applications in
augmented reality allow you to stay in
touch with the real world you don't have
to stumble around in a headset
so the
people that i work with at grand canyon
university tell me that the best
experience that they have in their
students and working with ar is with
the microsoft tools so microsoft makes
the hololens and they have version 2 out
and you may have seen in the recent news
that the pentagon has awarded
some contract worth billions of dollars
to microsoft because they have this
augmented reality headset that really
really does work pretty well in
comparison to the others so you can see
a couple of applications here
is that here's a student it looks like
and he is uh pulling apart the spinal
column of a of a model here and you can
look at it in detail
even though you're you're still looking
at the world around you it's just kind
of the superimposed image over your
glasses so here's another application of
the technology looks interesting so you
go to ancient rome
and you see these ruins that are maybe
half there or 90 percent destroyed
with an augmented reality app you could
get to see what the original looked like
and so you go to a museum and instead of
looking at the skeleton they might show
you
a more realistic view of a model of the
dinosaur so
right now ar is kind of quirky it's kind
of gimmicky i don't really see this as a
necessary item that you have to have
and so we'll keep it in the future then
remember this is a video about what come
what is coming what's going to be
developed and what's going to improve a
great deal so we can still keep ar as a
developing and growing technology
so take a peek here this is a google's
developer website for what they
currently have for augmented reality
and so
you can experiment with this as you can
see you can put cartoonish looking
models on the street or on the table
and they've got plugins that work with
android and unity and unreal and ios
and so
right now you can do the cartoony kind
of a guy standing around your
neighborhood so go ahead and experiment
with this if you want to become a
developer that works with augmented
reality now i mentioned
so the technology is not particularly
useful i don't know of any apps right
now that you must have
that make this work
other than pokemon go so
maybe uh maybe you'll be the guy or the
girl that comes up with a great solution
why we all have to have our phones for
an augmented reality app
so no doubt in the future we're going to
be seeing higher bandwidth so 5g
networks currently are being rolled out
as i'm making this video what will that
mean for mobile developers well you're
going to see some trends which means
you're going to have greater emphasis on
connecting to the cloud resources your
gps will be more responsive you can have
higher resolution video conferencing
you'll have better response times you're
going to have always on services and the
iot revolution the internet of things
will become easier to develop and ar
will be better and what's going to then
in decreasing trends well if your phone
is working well with 5g then less
dependence on the computers you're going
to have fewer disconnections you're
going to have less reliance on the
storage in your phone and they promise
us that our batteries are going to last
longer so
less energy consumption so those are
some trends that will accelerate as we
have higher bandwidth now iot or the
internet of things
is a growing field and i honestly think
that mobile developers are in a great
situation to figure out how to use this
so i picked off this page here from
microsoft
azure iot edge it's called
and so the idea of internet of things is
that we're going to have a different
trend instead of more computing on the
cloud
we have more computing on devices
okay so that's the complete opposite of
the trend that i was showing you earlier
so what this means is that they're
working as i once i say they i say we're
talking about electrical engineers and
computer engineers they are
designing apps that are super low power
and have higher abilities to do
computing
so if you have these tiny little things
that require almost no energy
and can do a lot of processing on them
which is obviously impossible for most
of us to think of right now but if that
goal is met then the iot will it will
take that
that heavy cpu usage
from
the cloud or from the core
and move it to the edge
and so
less
computing power is going to be needed in
data centers if we can make the iot
devices better and more strong so what
are the iot devices you ask well
hopefully you can understand that those
are the smart devices so
don't even you don't have to think about
the smart coffee pot anymore iot devices
can be embedded in things like concrete
and so you know
what's going on with your bridge what's
the vibration and what's the load what's
the temperature so you build things into
materials
you have home security systems right now
which are current iot devices
but if you think of every object with a
smart chip in it from your car to your
ballpoint pen
to the chair you're sitting on to the
medical devices that are embedded in
your body
all of these things are considered iot
the internet of things
so really iot is another form of mobile
programming mobile application
development so if you're a mobile app
developer then you're in the right field
for the future wearable technology is
going to be more and more so right now
you've got the smartwatch
you've got maybe smart glasses
we've got the tools here right now at
android developing
sdks
so
you can build your own
watch apps right now security is going
to be obviously bigger and more
important than ever in the future
so
you're looking at any software developer
best practices guide whether it's apple
or microsoft or
google you're going to have best
practices in mobile
development going on all the time
so
make sure that you include security as
part of your design
blockchain is going to fit directly with
that increase on security so currently
we're all using our phones and credit
cards to make purchases so we're kind of
on the top row of this model here where
we're the customer and there's somebody
in the middle that's taking a cut from
everything that we do with our credit
card
and what we want to do or it would be
nice maybe is to use virtual currencies
and uh blockchain type things
to just do a direct transaction so we
cut out some costs so right now we have
the model on the left where you add a
credit card your app and then the
transactions are made through your bank
so in the future maybe we can have
direct payments using bitcoin or
something similar and so i expect that
that will be a trend that will
accelerate in the future
here's something i haven't actually
experienced much of myself but i see it
as a trending topic that will be in the
next few years is beacons so a beacon is
a small radio server that can tell you
that there is a phone nearby and then
you can get a message so in this case
somebody gets an alert that says hey
would you like a special drink now you
can do this right now with gps and so
maybe if
high bandwidth and improved gps
accuracies are are with us then beacons
are really just redundant they're
not even necessary but
it's not a tool that's in common use
right now so maybe beacons will be in
the future
so i'm kind of skeptical that
this will actually be something that i
would care about
i as a consumer i want less
annoyances not more annoyances so i
don't want beacons telling me hey you
got a new alert i mean i try to shut off
the alerts that i have on my phone
already because there's so many but
anyway beacons are something that people
are working on and we'll keep it in the
future if you'd like to see the entire
playlist for this course then take a
look here at the link you can watch
through all the things from designing an
app to hiring your team to choosing the
right platform so i appreciate you
coming make sure you subscribe and you
will become a better mobile application
developer
[Music]
hi and welcome to the business of
building apps this is a course that will
help you as a business manager and a
team lead for mobile development we're
in chapter eight of this course so we're
near the end we're talking about future
trends of app development and this is a
video for doing homework so i'm going to
give you an assignment if you're one of
my students at grand canyon university
this is assignment 8-1 what i want to do
is take a look back at what other
companies did in past decades when they
were predicting the future so we can
learn from the past
and predict how well we will predict the
future so for the background i've got a
couple of videos that i want you to
watch so first of all
called in from 1987 called apple's
future computer the knowledge navigator
and so in 87 apple provided a vision of
what they thought we would be doing by
today
and so
it's interesting to see
that they got quite a bit of it right
but it's kind of funny to see where they
didn't get it right either
then they have a second video that was
made in 93 which is called your world
your newton so the newton of course was
the early version of a smartphone
and the technology was kind of bulky but
for the time it was very compact
and some of the features that they
thought were great we don't use today so
both of those are great ideas that apple
had in the past
so these videos were created at a time
when personal computers were still
relatively new think apple ii and the
early macintosh the internet was still
10 years away
and smartphones were still at least 20
years away so
these were fairly forward-looking videos
so what i want you to do in this is to
write a one-page reaction tell me what
you thought about apple's predictions
what predictions did apple get that are
in common use today
in terms of percentages
what do you think their
their grade should be how good were they
in the quantity of correct predictions
and which features did they show in the
video that were complete failures why
didn't they succeed why were they not
adopted were they too clumsy were they
just dumb ideas or what do you think
went wrong
and then what did they not anticipate
very well so
are there things that they forgot to
include in the videos that we do today
and why did they miss them so let's take
a look at how apple did and based on our
monday mac monday morning quarterback
ability looking in the in the hindsight
let's find out what we think they did
well and what they did not do well
so if you're one of my students i would
expect you to submit this to me as an
assignment send me a one-page document a
word document's good that will evaluate
the apple's predictions how well they
did where they got it right where they
got it wrong
and what you think our prediction
ability is for the future so that's how
i would grade you based on your analysis
so send that to me if you're one of my
students if you're not one of my
students go feel free to add into the
comments below what you think about what
apple predicted or there other companies
that had just as interesting predictions
in the 80s or the 90s for what we would
be doing by now i'm going to add a link
to the course so that you can see all
the videos in this course called the
business of building apps and if you're
one of my students i will see you next
time and if you haven't subscribed yet
do that now thanks for watching
[Music]
hi and welcome to the business of
building apps this is a course about
mobile app development and being the
business manager in the process so we've
gone through a whole bunch of material
and we are on chapter eight which is
about future trends in this video i'm
going to give you an assignment so if
you were one of my students at grand
canyon university you now have homework
this is assignment 8.2 what i want you
to do is to analyze the current state of
development tools the process that we
can consider
things that are working well so look at
stack overflow for example
and they have a customer survey or a
user survey that talks about
what is popular so they analyze which
languages are growing in popularity
which frameworks are growing and of
course which ones are declining so
through this survey we can understand
the current trends and we can predict
the direction of certain languages and
frameworks so what's emerging and what's
fading away so the instructions what i
want you to do
is to take a look at a
survey data
and based on that
what are the current trends
and then applying that to what you're
working on right now such as your
application your business your plan
which languages have you adopted and
what do you think their future is are
they good in the future or not so for
instance if you've adopted xamarin for
your choice of development tools what do
you see in the future is it good or is
it gloomy and i want you to also think
about a cost estimate
so based on what other frameworks have
done in the past
how often do you think you're going to
have to release a new version of your
app
so that depends on the operating system
of the phone of course as well as the
language itself
and so if you're one of my students this
is what i would expect you to send me i
would expect you to send me a word
document that analyzes the trends and
the technologies used in your
application so what's growing what's
shrinking and how future proof is your
current app if you're not in my class
then you don't have to submit the
assignment but please in the comments
below talk about which languages that
you see are emerging or dying
what have you adopted and which are you
abandoning so if you have not subscribed
yet to the channel please do that i will
also provide a link to the playlist so
you can see all the videos about the
business of building apps and if you're
one of my students i will see you in
class next time thanks for watching
[Music]
hi and welcome to the business of
building apps this is a course about
mobile application development and the
business decisions that go with it so
we're in chapter 8 here which is about
future trends and this video is a
homework assignment so we're on
assignment 8.3 so if you're one of my
students at grand canyon university
listen up because this is what you're
going to have to do
so this assignment is about the future
of mobile technologies so what i want
you to do is to create a paper that is
going to examine what is growing in
possibilities for the future so future
trends are technologies that are
currently gaining popularity and they
might not be quite there yet so they
have significant obstacles to overcome
so if you want to see a background video
on this i have taught my own
lesson on my opinions and what's there
but i'd like you to do your own research
as well so here's the instructions i
would like you to write a paper that
answers the following questions so which
predictions mentioned in the topic
readings or in the lessons that i've
given you do you feel will be the most
successful so express your reasons for
why you think they will be successful so
for instance virtual reality and bitcoin
and augmented reality or things like
that so what did i mention and which
ones do you think are most promising
which predictions do you think are most
likely to fail
so
just because something gets a lot of
press doesn't mean that you think it
will be
where you would put your money so
explain your reasons for pessimism and
so based on both of these optimistic and
pessimistic views you would probably
think about
what you would put your investment in in
your own business
so how could they provide solutions to
you
and so in this course we've been talking
about your own app your own idea your
own business
and
what future plans do you see so we're
talking about five to ten years from now
how would you think your app will grow
so if you're one of my students this is
what i would expect you to deliver to me
i would expect a word document
that's maybe about a page long
that evaluates the likelihood of success
or failure for current emerging
technologies so you're going to give me
a ranking your top five let's say of
what things are in the future and why
you believe that they will succeed
now if you're not one of my students go
ahead and write in the comments below
what you think is probably the future of
mobile tech if you'd like to subscribe
make sure that you do that be and i will
put a link to the playlist for the
entire course so that you can go back
and see all of the great gems of
knowledge that have been shared here on
the business of building apps thank you
for watching